willkommen zu Phönix vor Ort vor Ort das
heißt an diesem Samstag morgen wir sind
hier in Berlin im Kosmos in Berlin hier
gründet sich heute das Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht das ist die offizielle
Parteigründung die hier heute
stattfindet die wir Ihnen zeigen die
soll hier jetzt unmittelbar vorstehen
dieser Gründungsparteitag soll hier
quasi jetzt jede Minute losgehen für 10
Uhr war es angekündigt und die
organisatorinen und Organisatoren haben
auch schon gesagt Sie wollen den
zeitfahrplan hier ein bisschen im Blick
behalten und auch pünktlich starten es
steht eine ganze Menge heute auf dem
Programm diese Partei diese neue Partei
die sich da zusammenstellt besteht aus
Sarah Wagenknecht das ist die Frontfrau
die soll hier heute auch dann formal
gewählt werden als Parteivorsitzende und
das ist ein ja etwas historischer Ort
kann man so sagen früher das größte
Filmtheater der DDR wir hatten auch
einige DDR grandanten sed granten
ehrenlogen in diesem Saal honneka und
Ulbricht heute ein ganz anderer Spielort
für Kulturveranstaltungen auch
Landesparteitage haben hier schon
stattgefunden und eben das Bündnis Sara
Wagenknecht BSW will sich hier heute
formal dann auch gründen und es gibt ja
schon Zeh
Bundestagsabgeordnete die diesen Bündnis
angehören das sind die die aus der
früheren Linksfraktion rüber gemacht
haben muss man so sagen mit Sarah
Wagenknecht vor einiger Zeit und jetzt
eben heute diese Parteigründung wir
werfen jetzt mal einen kleinen Blick
durch den Saal und in den Saal wie immer
können Sie hier bei phöniix das heute
live miterleben was hier passiert die
Reden zeigen wir Ihnen wir führen
Analysen Interviews und Gespräche hier
an unserem Set und wir haben natürlich
auch Kolleginnen und Kollegen die das
Ganze für sie einordnen und den Blick
behalten dazu gehört mein Kollege Erhard
scherfer mit einem Blick in den Saal ja
meine Damen und Herren das tun wir und
wir sind hier im Kosmos Event in der
Cosmos Event Location und eines muss ich
sagen habe ich tatsächlich in vielen
Jahren
parteitagsbeobachtung noch nicht erlebt
nämlich dass man hier tatsächlich
versucht pünktlich anzufangen es ist
jetzt 1 Minute nach FA pünktlich auf die
Minute betritt die Frau deren Namen
diese neue Partei hier trägt seit dem 8
Januar da ist ja das Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht gegründet worden von einer
noch relativ kleinen Gruppe
den Saal nämlich Sarah wagenkncht in
ihrem Gefolge Oscar lafontain der hat
auch schon manche Parteigründung hinter
sich auch manche parteiitgliedschaft und
sie sehen jetzt hier große Umarmung und
Applaus auch mit der aktuellen
kovorsitzenden des BSW Amira Mohammed
Ali ja am 8 Januar waren sie noch
relativ wenige jetzt sind 450 Delegierte
eingeladen zu diesem
Gründungsparteitag wo
man unter anderem das europawahlprogramm
verabschieden will und auch die
Europaliste aufstellen aber natürlich
auch den bislang nur von einer kleinen
Gruppe bestimmten und gewählten Vorstand
dann noch mal von einem größeren Kreis
bestätigen wird ja schauen wir noch ein
bisschen auf die Bilder hier Sarah
Wagenknecht natürlich im Fokus vieler
vieler Kameras und vieler vieler
Kolleginnen und Kollegen da sehen wir
Klaus Ernst im Hintergrund der war auch
mal in der SPD der war auch mal in der
Linken jetzt also auch hier beim BSW mit
dabei einige Gesichter werden sie im
Laufe dieses Tages natürlich
wiedererkennen aus anderen
Zusammenhängen die jetzt hier eine neue
heimstattfinden möchten im BSW und wir
ma machen weiter m Steinhäuser und
Gesprächspartner
Rinnen vielen Dank Erhard schärfer für
diesen ersten Blick in den Saal ja es
geht hier direkt gleich los wir nutzen
die Minuten die wir noch haben bei mir
Miriam Holstein vom Stern der Kollege
Timo Lehmann vom Spiegel ich grüße Sie
willkommen bei Phönix morgen Frau
Holstein was macht diesen
parteiründungstag hier heute so
speziell na ja ist der stchuss im Grunde
für die schwierige Phase also wir haben
ja man muss sagen das Bündnis hat einen
sehr guten Start eine sehr räibungslose
Parteigründung sie haben es geschafft
viele Spenden einzusammeln also gehen
auch mit dem finanziellen Grundlage da
rein und jetzt beginnt aber der schwere
Teil nämlich dass sie in den Ländern
Landesverbände Gründen müssen bei der
Europawahl und dann eben auch in den
Ländern bei den drei Landtagswahlen
antreten müssen und da müssen sie hier
jetzt ganz viel Schwung und Dynamik
entwickeln und auch so bisschen klarer
ihre Position
machen Kollege Lehmann wenn das jetzt
hier eröffnet
s Wagenknecht aosar lafon Seite an Seite
was ist das für ein Signal wie sehen Sie
das was wird hier ausgesendet na auf
jeden Fall dass das Bündnis SAR
Wagenknecht vor allem mit der Person
Sarah Wagenknecht logischerweise
verbunden wird also dieses was gesagt
immer wird es ist eine one woman Show
das wird hier noch mal zelebriert das
ist sozusagen der der größte Punkt ist
ihre Rede um 12 Uhr dort wird sie die
innertliche Botschaft setzen und auch
osar la Ehemann der wird heute Abend
noch mal sprechen das werden die
wahrscheinlich und interessantesten
reden hier auf dem Parteitag sein wir
werden das beobachten wir reden gleich
weiter wir hören jetzt einmal direkt
rein und werden diese ja
Gründungsversammlung hier mal anhören
wie sie beginnt sich auf ihre Plätze
denn ich werde jetzt den Parteitag
konstituieren und wenn sie dabei nicht
auf der Bühne stehen
wollen ich sag's
nur es wird
passieren
plötzlich liegt Stille über diesem sa da
ist die stille auch schon vorbei
liebe
Mitglieder der Partei Bündnis SAR
Wagenknecht Vernunft und
Gerechtigkeit liebe
Gäste liebe Gäste lieber Vertreterin und
Vertreter der
Medien
ich heiße Sie herzlich willkommen auf
dem zweiten Parteitag ich freue mich
außerordentlich dass wir hier als
Mitglieder der ersten Stunde unseren
Parteivorstand vervollständigen und
unseren Wahlantritt bei der Europawahl
am 9 juni vorbereiten können in den
kommenden Minuten werden wir die
arbeitsgrämien für den heutigen
Parteitag wählen hierzu gibt es einen
Personalvorschlag des
Parteivorstandes ich stelle euch jetzt
schon den Vorschlag für das erste
tagungspräsidium vor und zwar Jessica
taatti und Jana von Helden wir kommen
zur
Konstituierung des zweiten Parteitages
der parteibündnis Sara Wagenknecht
Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit der
Parteivorstand hat wie in der
Bundessatzung geregelt die Beschlüsse
zur Einberufung des Parteitages gefasst
der
beeinberufungsbeschluss wurde am 17
Januar 2024 gefasst und unmittelbar
danach
veröffentlicht der Beschluss enthält
auch einen Vorschlag für eine vorläufige
Tagesordnung und er enthält ebenfalls
die Festlegung des Tagungsortes alle
Mitglieder wurden rechtzeitig über das
Stattfinden dieses Parteitages und den
Tagungsort informiert alle Anträge
wurden den Mitgliedern rechtzeitig
übermittelt gemäß der von uns noch zu
beschließenden Geschäftsordnung des
Parteitages waren Änderungsanträge bis
dre Tage vor Beginn des Parteitages
einzureichen wir kommen zur Entscheidung
über die arbeitsgremmien des Parteitages
wir Verfahren nach der Regelung des
Paragraphen 6 der Bundessatzung der
Parteivorstand hat demnch folgenden
Vorschlag hier vorgelegt der den Antrag
pr02
ersetzt für das
tagungspräsidium Jessica Tati und janner
von Helden und für das nächste
tagungspräsidium Alexander Ulrich und
Günther Blocks für die Wahlkommission
Patrick Wahl Norman Wolf Johannes Zank
Frank Kemper Martina Thomas für die
Antragskommission Susanne herrhaus Kai
Merkel dia
AGU für die mandatsprüfungskommission
Andreas danne Stefanie Kemper und
Annabella
Peters gibt es Rückfragen zu den
Mitgliedern die hier für die
arbeitsgrämien vorgeschlagen
sind das sehe ich nicht dann beginnen
wir mit der Wahl der tagungs des
tagungspräsidiums gibt es Wortmeldung
dazu das sehe ich nicht wir beginnen den
Vorschlag nun mit der bunten Stimmkarte
ihr habt zwei wir nehmen nun die bunte
Stimmkarte wer stimmt für
den die
buntere
richtig wer stimmt für den Vorschlag den
bitte ich nun um das
Kartenzeichen danke schön wer stimmt
dagegen keine Stimmen sehe ich wer
enthält sich sehe ich auch nicht damit
ist das tagungspräsidium gewählt danke
schön dann machen wir weiter mit der
Wahl der
Wahlkommission gibt es Wortmeldung
dazu das sehe ich nicht wir stimmen den
Vorschlag nun ab wer stimmt für den
Vorschlag den bitte ich jetzt um das
Kartenzeichen danke schön wer stimmt
dagegen keine Gegenstimmen wer enthält
sich ich sehe keine Enthaltung danke
schön damit ist die Wahlkommission
gewählt dann machen wir
weiter die haben heute viel Arbeit vor
uns vor sich dann machen wir weiter mit
der Wahl der Antragskommission gibt es
Wortmeldung
hierzu das sehe ich nicht wir stimmen
den Vorschlag nun mit der bunden
Stimmkarte ab wer stimmt für den vors
lag den bitte ich jetzt um das
Kartenzeichen danke schön wer stimmt
dagegen sehe ich nicht wer enthält sich
keine Enthaltung damit ist die
Antragskommission gewählt danke schön
und damit meine Damen und Herr haben Sie
schon mal einen schönen Eindruck gewonen
V gewonnen von dem was bei Parteitagen
dringlich nötig ist nämlich die
sogenannte Konstituierung es braucht
diverse Gremien die natürlich von den
Delegierten gewählt werden müssen da
haben sie jetzt einen Eindruck bekommen
von uns und deswegen werden wir die
Gelegenheit nutzen während das hier noch
im formalen Bereich weiter stattfindet
ein bisschen inhaltlich zu gucken auf
das und was uns alle erwartet von diesem
neuen Bündnis und das macht der Kollege
Mark
steinhuser vielen Dank erh schärfer ja
in großem Tempo geht das hier los
pünktlich eher ungewöhnlich für ein
Parteitag bei mir weiter mirim Holstein
vom Stern Timo Lehmann vom Spiegel Herr
Lehmann ist das die straffe Organisation
von die jetzt in den ersten Minuten auch
erleben dieses Bündnis was ihren Namen
trägt soll das ja sehr schnell und auch
sehr nach Ihren Wünschen hier auch alles
heute laufen die Gefahr ist natürlich
groß dass irgendwas schief geht auf
diesem Parteitag ja also die Partei hat
noch keine große Parteizentrale es gibt
keine eingeübten Prozedere oder
sonstiges das heißt es gibt viele
Möglichkeiten dass bei so einem
Parteitag rechtlich oder technisch
irgendwas schief geht und das haben sie
jetzt soweit ich gehört habe in den
letzten Tagen versucht zu vermeiden es
muss alles perfekt funktionieren und
deswegen haben sie auch ganz ganz
pünktlich angefangen damit sie auf jah
nicht und sie haben unglaublich viel vor
also für ein Parteitag bei dem Listen
aufgestellt werden sollen ein Vorstand
gewählt werden soll alles an einem Tag
das ist ein ziemlich sportliches
Programm ein sportliches Programm sagen
sie Frau Holstein ein Programm was ja
noch relativ dünn ist was die Inhalte
betrifft wenn Sie auf das blicken was
man jetzt weiß zu diesem Bündnis SAR
wagenkncht wo ordnen Sie das eigentlich
ein nicht
also sich selbst bezeichnet das Bündnis
als linkskonservativ und was wir sehen
ist dass es in der Tat so eine Art
kesselbuntes ist und dann eine ganz auch
ganz interessante und auch bislang
wirklich einmalige Mischung hat aus
sozialpolitisch eher linken Position z.B
bessere Renten Mindestlohn erhöhen
vermögenenssteuer und eben was
Innenpolitik Sicherheitspolitik aber
auch Identitätspolitik betrifft eher so
rechtsautoritären Position und ich
glaube damit schließt man tatsächlich
oder bietet was an einer Lücke die es
bislang im Koordinatensystem gibt aber
muss gucken wie es dann in der Praxis
funktioniert jetzt wird hier ein Film
gezeigt ein Image Video wo auch diese ja
sage ich mal Leute angesprochen werden
sollen die ja vielleicht die man
erreichen möchte wir werfen mal einen
kleinen Blick in dieses Video was da
jetzt gezeigt
wird Geldbeutel der Eltern ab das geht
gar
nicht ich bin beuerin mit Leib und Seele
aber was dann da immer aus Berlin
das geht dir nicht in
Kop die Energiekrise die Inflation wie
soll ich da mein Handwerksbetrieb
rentabelbetriebe wie soll ich als
alleinerziehende Mutter Job und Familie
unter einen Hut bringen ohne bezahlbaren
kitaitapatz in der
Näher deutschland braucht ein neues
Bündnis ein Bündnis das den Menschen
zuhört das Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht
die Menschen bei uns fühlen sich mit
ihren Sorgen im Stich gelassen die Ampel
regiert mit Ideologie und blindem
Aktionismus statt die Situation zu
verbessern wir brauchen jetzt im Land
eine neue Kraft um das zu
ändern wir brauchen einen florierenden
deutschen Mittelstand mehr
Innovationskultur und weniger Bürokratie
um unsere Wirtschaft wieder zu stärken
und den Wohlstand zu sichern wir müssen
den Abstieg großer Teile der Bevölkerung
verhindern Gerechtigkeit heißt für uns
fair Renten motivierende Löhne und ein
Steuersystem in dem kleine und mittlere
Einkommen entlastet und Konzerne stärker
in die Pflicht genommen werden wir
brauchen mehr Kinderbetreuung
Chancengleichheit und endlich ein
einheitliches Bildungssystem in allen
Bundesländern wir müssen Schulen
sanieren und den Lehrermangel
beenden
unser Bündnis steht für offene
Debattenkultur Diplomatie und Frieden
für Entspannung Interessenausgleich und
internationale
Zusammenarbeit wir hören zu und haben
Antworten unser Ziel ist ein
zukunftsfähiges gerechtes und
lebenswertes
Deutschland dafür treten wir
an das s Wagenknecht Vernunft und
[Musik]
Gerechtigkeit ja das ist die PR Trommel
des Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht mit diesem
Werbevideo gucken wir mal auf die
Frontfrau SAR Wagenknecht kann das
funktionieren mit dieser Person die
jetzt
ein paar anderen kann das funktionieren
auf eine eine Partei zu gründen also ich
glaube das das ist sozusagen die größte
Stärke weil sie eine sehr charismatische
sehr eloquente Persönlichkeit ist die
auch Massen quasi für sich begeistern
kann aber zugleich die größte Schwäche
weil wir wissen aus ihrer Zeit als
linksfraktionschefin dass sie nicht
diejenige ist die organisieren kann sie
kann nicht zusammenhalten das mussten
andere machen die waren aber an ihrer
Seite z.B mit damals und jetzt ist es
eben alles auf sie fokussiert und das
heißt wenn sie ausfällt oder da das
nicht liefern kann wird ganz schwierig
werden mit Blick auf das was eine Partei
alles zu leisten hat da spielen auch die
Finanzen Rolle Herr Lehmann sie haben im
Spiegel darüber berichtet es gibt jetzt
weitere Geldgeber ein Ehepaar aus
Sachsen was sehr viel Geld gespendet hat
glauben sie dass genug Geld vorhanden
ist in der Parteikasse für die ganzen
Wahlkämpfe in diesem Jahr noch nicht
also jetzt sind es ungefähr 3 Millionen
Euro man muss sich vorstellen es stehen
drei Landtagswahl an wo diese neue
Partei antreten will und die Europawahl
dafür bräucht es noch wesentlich mehr
Geld es kann sein dass das jetzt durch
diesen Parteitag und so weiter an
Schwung nimmt aber das wird man sehen
die setzen natürlich auch darauf
möglicherweise keine großen Wahlkämpfe
zu machen sondern viel über W Präsenz in
den Medien und so weiter zu gewinnen
aber man sehen okay wir behalten das im
Blick auf jeden Fall besten Dank bis
hierhin für ihre Einschätzung Timo
Lehmann vom Spiegel miram Holstein vom
Stern hier bei phöniix vielen Dank ja
und wir wollen natürlich auch ein
bisschen im Blick behalten wer hier
eigentlich mitmacht wir wissen ja bisher
von Sarah Wagenknecht dass es etwa 450
Parteimitglieder sind die hier alle
dicht an dicht in diesem früheren Kino
sitzen und meine Kollegin Julia Grimm
die wird uns jetzt mal ein bisschen
erzählen was da so zwischen den Reihen
passiert und wer hier eigentlich
ist
vernichtungslag
iert jetzt höre ich mich das heißt also
sie hören mich auch fantastisch also
genau
ich ja wir haben gehört dass es auf
jeden Fall eng ist im wir haben auch
gesehen leider Einar technische
Schwierigkeiten noch mal in jedem Fall
geht jetzt hier auch die erste Rednerin
ans Kult die die erste Rede hält auf
diesem Parteitag das ist Daniela
DN
der der nachdrückliche Wunsch alle
Deutschen hätten für immer aus der
Geschichte gelernt hat sich leider nicht
erfüllt der Schoß ist fruchtbar immer
noch angesichts dessen was
Rechtsextremisten in Vorder und
hinterstuben an faschistoiden Plänen
auscken geht es um die kollektive
Zuständigkeit von uns
Nachgeborenen der Kapitalismus mit
seinen verheerenden militärischen
geostrategien mit seinen sozialen
Verwerfungen und der daraus folgenden
Ableitung von Wut auf
Sündenböcke bringt er abermals all das
hervor was schon einmal ins Verderben
geführt
hat ich muss in diesen Tagen an Fanja
finelon denken die Ausschwitz nur
überstanden hatte weil sie zu dessen
warnwitzigem mädchenorchester gehörte
wie estther bearano und Anita lasg
Wallfisch ich lernte die französische
Chanson Kennerin Sängerin kennen später
in der DDR wo sie einige Jahre gelebt
unterrichtet und Konzerte gegeben
hat eingeprägt hat sich mir die
Schilderung in ihrem Buch wie
Reichsführer SS Heinrich Himmler der
geistige Vater aller KZ zu Besuch
kam über seinen letzten davor von
1942 hatte sich herumgesprochen dass er
der Vernichtung eines eben
eingetroffenen judentransportes
beigewohnt hatte Befehle erteilte die
Selektion müsse noch weniger Abfall
hinterlassen töten sei wirtschaftlicher
als
ernähren und diesmal wollte er also ein
Konzert des mädchenorchesters besuchen
es hieß sie müssten sich extrem
anstrengen denn er verstünde etwas von
Musik horrorhass ohnmächtiger aufrohr
packen mich schrieb Panja der
Organisator unseres eigenen Todes wird
hierherkmen der Henker wird kommen und
sich seiner Opfer
freuen er kam hörte gelangweilt einige
Minuten zu und ging er hatte Wichtigeres
zu
tun sein Desinteresse verbreitete Panik
im Orchester war es das
Todesurteil am Morgen des 27 Januars
1945 stieß die Rote Armee zunächst auf
das Zwangsarbeitslager Monowitz hier
feuerten Angehörige der Waffen SS und
der Wehrmacht noch besinnungslos um sich
etwa 230 sowjetische Soldaten ließen
allein hier ihr
Leben im Laufe des Tages stießen ihre
322 infanteriedivision bis zum
Hauptlager vor nicht die Alliierten die
ursula von der leihen fälschlich
behauptete die sowjetischen Kameramänner
die sofort zu dokumentieren begann
schilderten unseren Augen bot sich ein
schreckliches Bild eine riesige Anzahl
von Baracken auf den britschen lagen
Menschen Skelette schon mit Haut
überzogen und abwesendem Blick
es war schwer sie ins Leben
zurückzuholen alle geknechteten und
geblendeten vom nsreime zu befreien
dafür hat allein die Rote Armee 13
Millionen Soldaten geopfert sie haben
ihr Leben dafür gelassen und dafür sind
wir Ihnen zu ewig zu Dank verpflichtet
wie immer sich die Weltlage inzwischen
verändert
[Applaus]
warum warum daran
erinnern das größte Verbrechen der
Menschheitsgeschichte ist von Deutschen
begangen worden es war alles andere als
ein
Vogelschiss und ich finde es wichtig zu
betonen dass sich am heutigen Datum eine
Partei konstituier der es am Herzen
liegt das Gedächtnis dafür wachzuhalten
und Folgerung daraus
zuziehen denn es geht auch darum
missbräuchliches erinnern nicht zu
dulden welch Schindluder hat ein
Außenminister der Grünen mit der einzig
richtigen Schlussfolgerung nie wieder
Ausschwitz getrieben als er damit den
völkerrechtswiegen Angriffskrieg der
NATO gegen Jugoslawien
rechtfertigte
[Applaus]
Auschwitz die ganze schor war nur im
Schatten des Weltkrieges möglich nichts
führt so direkt zu enthumanisierung Wie
krieg deshalb ist es so unverzichtbar
wenigstens eine konsequente
Friedenspartei im Parlament zu
haben
[Applaus]
zweifellos zweifellos wäre es auch mir
lieber gewesen die Linke hätte ihre
Kraft zu Vereinigung wie sie etwa mit
PDS und WASG bewiesen hatte beibehalten
auch in ihrer Friedenspolitik hatte sie
lange nicht nur meine Sympathie doch
spätestens als die Linken Parteiführung
es aus fadenscheidigen Gründen abgelehnt
hat die großartige Demonstration
Aufstand für den
[Applaus]
Frieden ihr wisst schon wie der Satz
weitergeht aber ich beende ihn trotzdem
äh also spätestens als abgelehnt wurde
diese Demonstration zu
unterstützen war der Bruch
endgültig längst hatte die Linke ihre
Aufgabe als unüberhörbare Opposition zum
Regierungskurs eingebüst eine
Entwicklung die die Grünen lange hinter
sich hatten
folgerichtig gibt es in der derzeitigen
Parteienlandschaft eine
repräsentationslücke etwa die Hälfte der
Bürger finden im gegenwärtigen Parlament
keine Partei mit der sie sich
identifizieren können wer der
Zeitenwende hinzug kriegstüchtigkeit
konsequent widersprechen will dem
irglauben an Sieg durch Waffen diesen
wahnsinnigen Werkzeugen des Todes wie
Papst franziskus sie nennt der könnte
sich genötigt sehen AFD zu wählen obwohl
er sie in allen übrigen Punkten von
Herzen
[Applaus]
ablehnt das ist ein unhaltbarer Zustand
denn der Frieden muss allen nicht vom
Krieg profitierenden Menschen das
allerwertvollste sein nur ein Leben in
Frieden ist
[Applaus]
lebenswert Waffen Waffen und der sie
begleitende Wirtschaftskrieg vernichten
Leben und den Rest von intakter Natur
der ebenfalls tobende
Informationskrieg soll uns Bürger um den
Verstand bringen den wir brauchen um
mündig zu bleiben
es muss verdammt noch mal möglich sein
Waffenlieferungen und die
Geringschätzung von Verhandlungen und
Demokratie abzuwählen ohne sich damit
das faschistoide und unsoziale
Gedankengut der AFD
[Applaus]
einzuhandeln Sara Wagenknecht hat
bewiesen dass gemeinnütziger Widerspruch
noch möglich ist sowohl gegen die sich
um sich greifende
Kriegsbereitschaft wie auch in ihrem
Engagement für die sozial
benachteiligten oder in der Kritik
totalitärer Tendenzen im Umgang mit der
Pandemie sie eröffnet Denkräume indem
sie neoliberale Mythen
entlarft SAR reflektiert die Vor und
Nachteile verschiedener Eigentums
denn von welchen Besitzverhältnissen wir
abhängig sind das entscheidet über
Selbstbestimmung und Identität wohl mehr
als alles
andere all das verdient
[Applaus]
Unterstützung gemessen daran sind die
offenen oder auch umstrittenen Fragen
nachrangig nicht
zweitrangig ich gehe davon aus dass die
Antworten im demokratischen inner und
außerparteilichen Dialog präzisiert
werden etwa die
Gretchenfrage nun sag wie hast du es mit
der
Migration als internationalistin bin ich
auch gespannt was hier für ein Europa
Wahlprogramm verabschiedet wird diese EU
als transatlantische ale der USA und der
NATO ist wahrlich vom Kopf auf die Füße
zu
[Applaus]
stellen aber dabei rechne ich auch mit
der anhaltenden Gültigkeit der
revolutionären Forderung präaria aller
Länder vereinigt
euch
[Applaus]
hier habe ich gar nicht mit Beifall
gerechnet aber ich sag ja man darf diese
Partei nicht
[Applaus]
unterschätzen beide auf ihre Art linken
Parteien werden nun wie alle anderen in
Konkurrenz stehen ich hoffe aber
ähnlich wie Gesine Lech dass sie sich
nicht als politische Hauptgegner ansehen
sondern da wo sich Gemeinsamkeiten
erhalten haben auch
operieren gestatten Sie mir noch eine
persönliche Bemerkung ich bin seit über
30 Jahren parteilos und habe auch nicht
die Absicht daran etwas zu ändern weil
sich meiner Erfahrung bestätigt hat dass
für meines gleichen der Platz zwischen
den Stühlen ist aber manchmal gibt es
Momente da muss man sich für einen Stuhl
entscheiden ich habe auch noch nie auf
einem Parteitag gesprochen aber es ist
ja nie zu spät auch Neues
[Applaus]
auszuprobieren etwa um dem Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht meinen Respekt zu bekundnen
für den Mut und die Kühnheit der
zunehmend militanten und restaurativen
Parteienlandschaft die Stirn zu
[Applaus]
bieten
möge dieses Bemühen erfolgreich
[Applaus]
sein mehr als wünschenswert wäre es wenn
wir alle einen dringend nötigen wenn
auch sicher bescheidenen Beitrag dazu
leisten können dass unser Land und ja
auch unser Europa zum 80 jahrestag der
Befreiung von achwitz zur Vernunft
gekommen sind vielen
[Applaus]
Dank Daniela D war das Schriftstellerin
Publizistin die zu Beginn ihrer Rede
erinnert hat an das wahrscheinlich
wichtigere Ereignis des heutigen Tages
nämlich die Befreiung des KZ Auschwitz
vor 79 Jahren sie hat aber dann viele
Punkte aufgegriffen die den Delegierten
hier sehr am Herzen liegen und damit sie
Frau noch ein klein wenig einordnen
können sie gehörte ail 22 zu den
UnterzeichnerInnen eines offenen Briefes
an Olaf Scholz den Bundeskanzler und das
Ganze im Zusammenhang mit dem russischen
Überfall auf die Ukraine damals hat sie
in den Brief mit anderen gefordert der
Ukraine keine Waffen zu liefern und die
Regierung in Kiev zu ermutigen den
militärischen Widerstand zu beenden und
sie ist erst Unterzeichnerin eines des
Manifest für Frieden vom Februar 23 und
außerdem coautorin eines Buches das den
Titel trägt tam tam und tabu
Meinungsmanipulation von der Wendezeit
bis zur
Zeitenwende das also im Hinblick auf die
Rednerin die sie eben gesehen haben und
schon ist die nächste
Gastrednerin am Pult das ist agatha wska
aus Polen die jetzt gerade vorgestellt
wird vom
tagungspräsidium herzlich willkommen
liebe
agath
gutag me Name ist Agata winiowska in den
Jahren
201025 war ich stellvertretende
Bürgermeisterin in der Gemeinde
chwienchim der Stadt die sie als
Auschwitz kennen und sie woll für alle
Zeiten mit den grausamen
Konzentrationslager verbunden sein
wird heute JT sich der Tag der Befreiung
zum
79 mal will erinneren am 27 januar an
das unendliche Leid das den isasen
angetan wurde Überlebende Reisen aus der
ganzen Welt an um an die um an diesen
des diesen
ordes schreckenes gesehen und gehört zu
werden und sie kommen um im ihre Stimmen
Mann zu lassen die Z mehr
Mitmenschlichkeit
aufrufen es ist unser brauch sich für
ein Moment sie erheben als eine zu
zugewandte zugewandte Gäste an jene
deren letzter Gang wo soll viel Angst
Schmerz
Einsamkeit und der nie endenden Frage
begleitet war
warum
bitte erhebt euch für eine
Schweigeminute
ich danke euch
danke
es ist mir eine Ehre heute zu dem
Parteitag von budnis Sara Wagen kncht
begleiten zu dürfen ich danke Ihnen dass
ich
stellvertretend vertretend diesen
eindrglichen Appel so ich so oft gehört
habe mit Ihnen teilen
[Applaus]
darf
wir brauchen eine Politik der Vernunft
und eine Politik der
Liebe denn wenn in Zukunft nicht Liebe
in Mitgefühl in der Politik im
Journalismus der Wirtschaft und in
unsere Gesellschaft einen einen ganz
dominanten Platz finden wir wird sich
zwei Auschwitz nicht wiederholen aber
das zu zu Grunde liegende
Muster
[Applaus]
die Bosheit Mensche Menschen die Freunde
am beleidigen demütigen entmenschlichen
und sogar Tüten gewinnt immer immer
wieder über die die Friedfertigen in
unserer Gesellschaft wir sehen die kalte
in so so wie vielen Ländern neu
erwachsen
glauben Sie mir ich habe mich über viele
Jahre mit der Frage beschäftigt wie wie
Menschen andere Menschen so ein Leid
zufügen können ich werde es nie
verstehen weil mir jlich Hass fällt aber
ich habe verstanden dass Menschen die
hassen nie wieder im politische Ämter
kommen
dürfen
ich habe mich entschlossen für den für
den Frieden Politik zu machen so wie
[Applaus]
sie während des Krieges zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine kamen etwa 30
Mutter und ihre Kinder nach oswenchim um
ihnen Nahrung um Kleidung zu geben ging
ich zu dem Kloster in dem sie wohnten
als ich an der Tür klinkelte ertünte ein
schreckliches Schrei die Kinder hielten
es für einen Alarm ich fand sie mit den
Hängen auf den Kopf unter den Tischen
liegen
was diese unschuldigen Wesen für müsen
wie viel Angst sie haben wie
traumatisiert sie sind der Krieg muss
Enden schon allein der
kinderwgen der Krieg muss
[Applaus]
Enden der Zeit lebend weltweit 450
Millionen Kinder im
Konfliktgebieten Kinder die
unvorstellbares
erleiden ich habe mich oft gefragt wie
anders würde unsere Welt Aufsehen wenn
nicht Egoismus Gewalt und Ignoranz
herrschen würden wir müssen es es
[Applaus]
herausfinden sie haben sich entschlossen
eine Partei für Vernunft und
Gerechtigkeit zu gründen deren Fundament
nicht nur ihre fachliche Kompetenz ist
sie zeigen mit Gefühl für eine Opfer der
schrecklichen
[Applaus]
machtpitik sie
verstehen nein sie leben denn Ruf nach
mehr Menschlichkeit ich werde die
Hoffnung nach
zurück neehmen dass sie Erfolg haben und
ich hoffe dass sich mehr und mehr
Menschen mit den tieferen Ursachen von
Auschwitz beschäftigt
[Applaus]
beschäftigen
bleiben wie mütig schenken Sie der Welt
mehr Mitgefühl nächsten Liebe und
Frieden
Applaus für agatha winiowska ehemalige
stellvertretende Bürgermeisterin des
Ortes den wir als Auschwitz kennen und
sie hat sogar noch ein paar
Namensvorschläge mitgebracht für dieses
neue Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht hier das
ja im Untertitel für Vernunft und
Gerechtigkeit führt sie hat jetzt
vorgeschlagen für mehr Liebe und Frieden
ließe sich doch auch noch einbauen in
den Titel dieser Partei die heute hier
ihren ersten Bundesparteitag hat und
wenn Sie Christian le den
Generalsekretär am Anfang gehört haben
der ja wiederholt gesagt hat dass SE der
zweite Parteitag da haben wir inzwischen
die gesicherte Information dass der
erste Parteitag ja der am 8 Januar
gewesen ist also der Tag der
tatsächlichen Parteigründung heute also
erster Bundesparteitag und diese
Zählweise wird sich weiter durchsetzen
wir gehen noch mal kurz zurück aufs
Podium um zu sehen wie es hier
weitergeht nach seinen Wünschen nach
oben oder unten zu
regulieren ich bitte jetzt um den
Bericht der
mandatsprüfungskommission so und dann
sind wir wieder bei sehr formalen Dingen
und dann nutzen wir die Gelegenheit zur
Analyse zur Einordnung denn unter
anderem deshalb sind wir ja hier wir
wollen ihn ja nicht einfach nur zeigen
was hier passiert sondern wir wollen
Ihnen auch sagen warum wieso und was es
für Folgen haben könnte das Wort hat
Mark
Steinhäuser besten Dank Erhard schärfer
ja wir bei phöniix zeigen diesen
Parteitag hier den ersten bundesparte
des Bündnis SAR Wagenknecht wir
besprechen das mit Julia ruschenbach
Politikwissenschaftlerin von der Freien
Universität Berlin willkommen bei
phöniix ja vielen Dank für die Einladung
Frau rchenbach nun ist es eine neue
Partei in der deutschen
Parteienlandschaft mit einigen
Besonderheiten hat schon
Bundestagsabgeordnete hat eine Person an
der Spitze und im Namen was sagt die
Politikwissenschaftlerin was hier heute
passiert wie speziell wie besonders ist
[Applaus]
das ber Moment ganz klar sie haben es
angedeutet diese Partei Neugründung ist
anders als viele in der Vergangenheit
von einer gewissen Prominenz geprägt
nicht zuletzt dadurch dass eben so viele
Bundestagsabgeordnete mit Sara
Wagenknecht die bisherige Fraktion der
Linken verlassen haben um diese neue
Partei aufzubauen auch die Gruppe die es
jetzt im Bundestag geben wird seit
gestern ist klar auch mit welchen
Rechten diese Gruppe ausgestattet sein
wird aufzubauen und in der Tat es ist
auch eine Besonderheit im deutschen
Parteiensystem dass wir so eine starke
Personalisierung so Zuspitzung auf eine
Person haben Sarah Wagenknecht hat ja
angedeutet dass womöglich irgendwann
einmal ihr Name aus dem Namen der Partei
wieder verschwinden könnte hat aber auch
schon gesagt bis zur Bundestagswahl 2025
wird das nicht passieren und daran sehen
wir dass man an dieser Personalisierung
offensichtlich doch jetzt auch ein Stück
weit festhalten will weil man merkt dass
das auch
verfängt nun wird jetzt hier dann der
Vorstand gewählt SAR Wagenknecht an der
Spitze aber mit einer kovorsitzenden
wenn man jetzt auf die
Parteienlandschaft schaut in Deutschland
und diese Partei da reinsetzt wo
verorden sie diese Partei Sarah
Wagenknecht sagt ja weder rechts noch
links ja das ist eine ganz interessante
Entwicklung das ist auch nicht nur bei
Sara W nicht zu beobachten wir konnten
das auch in anderen europäischen Ländern
sehen dass so
bewegungsartige Entwicklungen sagen wir
wollen mit diesem linksrechts schemat da
nichts zu tun haben die
Politikwissenschaft hält da aber ganz
gerne dran fest um ein bisschen
Koordinaten und verordnen zu können und
da würde man schon sagen können also es
ist eine Partei die in auf einer
wirtschaftspolitischen als auf einer
sozioökonomischen Dimension dezidiert
ihr im linken Spektrum zu verordnen ist
das heißt es geht um z.B Forderung nach
stärkerer Umverteilung stärkere
Besteuerung von reichen mehr sozialer
Gerechtigkeit sichere Löhne Renten die
aber auf einer soziokulturellen
Dimension eher sozusagen im rechten
konservativen Spektrum zu Hause ist wenn
es z.B darum geht das sind alles
Forderungen die auch jetzt in diesen
ersten programmatischen Papieren
auftauchen Parallelgesellschaften zu
vermeiden
zu sagen wir müssen Migration stärker
steuern wir müssen auch Menschen die
nicht in Deutschland sein dürfen stärker
abschieben beispielsweise und zwei
Themen die Sarah Wagenknecht auch sehr
stark gemacht hat z.B kulturelle
Überfremdung Gendern oder ein Gegensatz
von Stadt und Land danke bis hierhin wir
reden gleich weiter und wir hören mal
was die Parteivorsitzende Mohamed Ali zu
sagen hat danke schön Jessica liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde auch ich begrüße
euch alle herzlich die ihr heute hier
seid ich grüße auch all die vielen
Menschen die diesen parteit von zu Hause
od unterwegs übers Internet oder
Fernsehen verfolgen und die große
Hoffnung in unsere neue Partei setzen
viele von ihnen haben sich sicher
bereits als Unterstützer oder Förderer
unserer Partei registriert und ich
möchte jeder und jedem einzelnen von
ihnen ganz herzlich danken die
Unterstützung durch Spenden und der
große Zuspruch in den ersten Monaten
nach der Vereinsgründung und besonders
die Unterstützung seit der
Parteigründung am 8 Januar war und ist
überwältigend Liebe Freundinen und
Freunde mein Dank gilt natürlich auch
allen hier im Saal ihr seid bereit für
unsere Partei Gesicht zu zeigen ihr
macht in diesen stürmischen Zeiten den
Rücken gerade V eine Politik der
wirtschaftlichen Vernunft sozialer
Gerechtigkeit des Friedens und der
Freiheit und es ist schön heute in so
viele mutige und entschlossene Gesichter
zu
blicken
aber einer Person einer Person möchte
ich natürlich ganz besonders danken die
Frau ohne die wir alle heute nicht hier
wären vielen Dank liebe Sarah
Wagenknecht ohne ohne deinen Mut deine
Standhaftigkeit deine meinungsstärke und
deine Fachkompetenz wären wir heute
nicht hier und viele haben im Vorfeld
geog du würdest dich nicht trauen ich
glaube diese Leute haben vor allem Angst
gehabt dass du dich traust weil sie
geahnt
haben weil sie geahnt haben was das für
die Parteienlandschaft und für die
eigenen umfrageerte bedeuten wird und
ich kann schon verstehen dass die
anderen Parteien besonders die Parteien
der ampelregierung dass sie jetzt
langsam richtig nervös werden wenn sie
sehen was wir vorhaben und was für tolle
Leute wir neben dir liebe SAR in unseren
Reihen haben unter uns sind Handwerker
Pflegekräfte Betriebsschlosser Theologen
engagierte Rentnerinnen und Rentner
Musiker Regisseure Schauspieler Ärzte
Hochschulprofessoren Lehrer Unternehmer
Gewerkschafter Polizisten Rechtsanwälte
Profisportler Autoren Wissenschaftler
profilierte kommunal Landes und
Bundespolitiker Menschen aus allen
Bereichen viele waren schon vorher in
einer Partei aktiv in einer anderen
andere sind jetzt zum ersten Mal
Mitglied einer Partei geworden ja liebe
Freundinen und Freunde wir sind breit
auf aufgestellt wir kommen aus der
ganzen Breite der Gesellschaft und wir
machen Politik für all diejenigen deren
Interessen in der herrschenden Politik
immer weniger vorkommen und das ist
leider die Breite der
Gesellschaft
wir wir die wir hier im Kosmos in Berlin
zusammengekommen sind wir tragen eine
große Verantwortung aus den zahlreichen
Zuschriften die mich täglich von
Menschen aus ganz Deutschland ichen weiß
ich wie hoch die Erwartungen unserer
Partei sind ich weiß auch wie groß die
Sorgen bei vielen sind vor dem
wirtschaftlichen Abstieg und davor dass
Deutschland immer tiefer in
internationale Konflikte und Kriege
hineingezogen wird es ist an uns all
diesen Menschen wieder Hoffnung zu geben
wir sind das Bündnis wir sind die Partei
auf die so viele Menschen in unserem
Land so lange gewartet
haben
und wir wollen wir wollen und wir werden
kein Teil der abgehobenen
selbstgerechten politblase sein in der
man sich über alles Mögliche die Finger
wund twittert und dabei viel zu oft aus
dem Blick verliert wie schlecht es
vielen Menschen in Deutschland
inzwischen
geht die herrschende Politik die
herrschende Politik ist arrogant
geworden und das muss endlich ein Ende
haben und eines ist klar wir werden
unsere Politik nicht nach den Vorgaben
der mächtigsten Konzerne und Lobbys
ausrichten wir werden auch nicht bei
Gegenwind aus den Medien oder sogar aus
den sogenannten sozialen Medien
einknicken wir werden unser Programm
nicht von Stimmungen und meinungsmachen
diktieren lassen als einzige Partei
setzen wir einen Expertenrat ein den wir
bei unserer programmfindung zu Rate
ziehen denn dieses Land braucht nicht
noch mehr ahnungslose von Stimmung
getriebene Politiker ihre Meinung in die
nächste Kamera stammeln nein wir setzen
auf die Menschen die Ahnung haben wir
setzen auf echte
Fachkompetenz soziale Gerechtigkeit
wirtschaftliche Vernunft Frieden und
Freiheit das sind die Kernthemen unserer
Partei und es sind auch die Bereiche in
denen die Regierung grandios versagt hat
die deutsche Wirtschaft ist vergangenen
Jahr um 0,3% gestumpft geschrumpft die
ampelregierungen ampelregierung die zckt
die Schultern und schiebt das auf die
vielen Krisen der vergangenen Jahre aber
warum warum wächst die Wirtschaft in
dann in den meisten anderen
Industrieländern diese Länder müssen n
doch mit den gleichen globalen Krisen
umgehen wie Deutschland aber Deutschland
ist schlustg warum ist das so na ja
Deutschland hat das SAR hat das in einer
bundestagsrede einmal sehr treffend
gesagt weil wir die dümmste Regierung
Europas haben diese Inkompetenz die
Sucht wirklich ihres
Gleichen
wist ihr bei der Politik dieser Ampel
muss ich immer an das Lied Major Tom von
peter Schilling denken völlig losgelöst
von der Erde fliegt die Bundesregierung
ihrem Raumschiff völlig
schwerelos man sieht das man sieht das
an großen Dingen wie z.B den kopflosen
wirtschaftssanktion man sieht es aber
auch in Detailfragen wie z.B dass die
Parteivorsitzende der Grünen tatsächlich
annimmt dass ein Rentner in Deutschland
im Schnitt 2000 € im Monat hat ich meine
wie ahnungslos kann man eigentlich sein
wie weit entfernt vom Alltag der
Menschen eigentlich ich finde es
unglaublich und dann statt sich um die
wirtschaftlichen Probleme um die
sozialen Probleme der Menschen in
Deutschland zu kümmern bringt diese
Bundesregierung eine Zumutung nach der
anderen für die Bevölkerung auf den Weg
das idiotische heizungsgesetz der COC Z
Preis die Streichung des agrardiesels
die Erhöhung der Mehrwertsteuer in der
Gastronomie Kürzungen bei der Renten
Kasse im Gesundheitsbereich im
Verbraucherschutz im Bevölkerungsschutz
die Liste der Fehlentscheidungen der
Bundesregierung ist fast so groß wie die
Erinnerungslücken des Bundeskanzlers
beim Steuerskandal und seinen guten
Bekannten bei der
warburgbank und all diese Dinge all
diese Dinge werden gegen den wählen der
Bevölkerung einfach durchgeprügelt kein
Wunder dass immer mehr Menschen ihren
Unmut auch auf die Straße tragen zuletzt
die Landwirte Lkw-Fahrer Gastronom
Handwerker und andere haben das gemacht
viele Menschen sind wütend und das
zurecht die Antwort der
Regierungsparteien auf diesem Protest
ist leider so unbeholfen wie die
Regierungspolitik selbst so oft heißt es
oh der Protest sei rechts unterwandert
und da seinen doch auch Rechte
mitgelaufen ich erinnere mich da
wirklich an die große Friedenskundgebung
beim brandenburgour ist heute schon
erwähnt worden es war vor gut einem Jahr
oder vor knapp einem Jahr als diejenigen
die für Frieden und Diplomatie
aufgestanden sind damals als putinnechte
und rechtsoffen beschimpft wordurden ich
war auf der Kundgebung und ich muss
sagen es empört mich immer wieder wenn
kritische Meinung um sie klein zu machen
einfach mal als rechtsradikal oder
rechtsoffen diemiert werden und alle die
das tun alle die das tun die müssen
wissen dass sie genau damit den
Rechtsextremisten helfen und die
Gesellschaft weiter Spalten ist
unverantwortlich und das ist die
Wahrheit
eine eine offene Debatte ist in diesem
Klima der angeblichen politischen
Korrektheit oft nicht mehr möglich und
wer angestellt ist oder gar im
öffentlichen Dienst beschäftigt ist der
muss auch immer öfter mit ernsthaften
Konsequenzen rechnen wenn eine
abweichende Meinung hat und die auch
kund tut und dagegen stehen wir auf
statt kindischen Dauer beleleidigt sein
wollen wir eine erwachsene politische
Kultur in der Menschen frei miteinander
reden und in der das bessere Argument
gewinnt so müsste es nämlich
sein liebe Freundinnen und Freunde wir
das Bündnis sarer Wagenknecht Vernunft
und Gerechtigkeit sind die seriöse
Adresse für alle Menschen die sich
schlecht regiert fühlen wir sind die
Partei die sich mit Herz und Verstand
für all diejenigen einsetzt die täglich
spüren dass ihre harte Arbeit nicht
vernünftig gewürdigt wird deren Leben
durch politische Fehlentscheidungen
immer härter und schwieriger und teurer
wird wir bringen Sachverstand und
Vernunft in das Chaos der deutschen
Parteienlandschaft und Liebe Freundinen
und Freunde es liegt an uns von diesem
Parteitag ein klares Signal der Stärke
und der Einigkeit auszusenden ich freue
mich auf den heutigen Parteitag mit euch
und auf einen kraftvollen europag
Wahlkampf mit unseren tollen
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten packen wir
es an vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit und schon gibt es den
ersten stehenden Applaus in diesem Fall
für Amira Mohamed Ali tparteivorsitzende
des Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht Frieden
Freiheit Vernunft das sind die Begriffe
die hier heute wiederholt die Runde
machen werden und tja was soll man sagen
wer hätte schon was dagegen wir hören
mal ganz schnell rein was der SAL so
sagt aber wir seht ja Julia ja ganz
genau ich stehe hier in den Reihen hier
wird gerade noch Standing Ovations ich
habe aber Gelegenheit einfach mal mit
jemandem zu sprechen hier der hier mit
dabei ist vielleicht können Sie einmal
sagen wer sind sie und was treibt sie
zum bündnisar Wagen also mein Name isten
und ich komme aus
Bochum treib Bündnis war sagknecht ich
wurde lange gefragt schon von Leuten aus
parteal von rabier und Christian le ob
ich nicht rüber wechseln wollte von den
Linken also sind ehemaliges linkenmglied
ja ja die beiden haben mich sogar zu den
linken geholt früher und we das jetzt
nicht mal meine politische Heimat sein
kann weil nur blind
hinter
wichtige Themen angesprechen werden
dürfen habe ich mich dazu entschieden
Hal mit ich leider muss ich schon wieder
nach vorne geben es geht ja zack zack
zack durch wir hören jetzt einmal die
Rede des stellvertretenden
Parteivorsitzenden zuuschauen sondern
selber etwas zu tun mir ist dabei eines
klar geworden wenn sich die Politik der
letzten Jahre in Deutschland in Europa
nicht gravierend verändert steht unsere
Demokratie für die Millionen von
Menschen über Generationen hinweg
gekämpft haben auf dem
Spiel es haben sich einfach zu viele
Menschen
abgewandt zu viele haben sich
zurückgezogen zu viele haben
resigniert und wer will es diesen
Menschen
verübeln eine Politik die die soziale
Frage und die der Gerechtigkeit nicht
mehr in den Fokus stellt wo die
hartarbeitenden Menschen immer mehr
belastet werden wo Lebensleistung von
Rentnern Eltern und Alleinerziehenden
nicht erkannt wird wo Unterstützung für
die Schwachen und schwächsten gekürzt
wird und wo Bildung immer mehr zu einer
Frage der Herkunft wird eine solche
Politik zerstört den sozialen
Zusammenhalt und das Vertrauen in
Demokratie und
Staat eine Politik die grob
fahlässig manchmal denkt man auch
mutwillig die Bedingungen für unsere
Wirtschaft
verschlechtert wo Bürokratie und Regeln
ungehemmt wachsen und Innovation und
Risikobereitschaft ersticken wo in
Behörden oft
absicherungsmentalität vorherrscht statt
Serviceorientierung für Bürger und
Unternehmen wo Energie für Industrie und
Mittelstand sinnlos verteuert wird und
wo notwendige Investitionen in Bildung
und Infrastruktur ausbleiben eine solche
Politik führt nicht nur dazu dass unser
Wohlstand sinkt sondern damit dazu dass
soziale Spannungen immer größer
werden und Politiker und Politiker die
die Bürger immer dann mögen wenn Sie von
ihnen gewählt werden dieselben Menschen
aber verachten wenn sie sich
herausnehmen Regierungshandeln in Frage
zu stellen wo Menschen mit
abweichenden wo Menschen mit
abweichenden Meinungen als rückständig
oder extrem etikettiert werden wo
Entscheidungen als alternativlos oder
Transformation verkauft werden um
letztlich über Ideologien hinweg
zuutäuschen oder von lobbyinflüssen
abzulenken und wo Menschen die andere
Auffassung vertreten öffentlich
diskreditiert und herabgesetzt werden
solche Politiker erreichen dass sich
immer mehr zurückziehen weil sie an an
den Rand gedrängt
werden kurzum wenn regierende entkoppelt
von der Realität völlig schwerelos nicht
mehr die Interessen der Bürger im Blick
haben wenn ein Kanzler Respekt
verspricht aber selbst dieses so
großartige Wort zu einer hohen Phrase
verkommen lässt dann sind wir als
Gesellschaft auf einem gefärrlichen Weg
und es sind sicher nicht die Menschen
daran schuld die sich abwenden liebe
Freundinnen und
Freunde das alles hat mich in Letten
Jahren sehr bewegt und für mich und
viele andere ist es ein großes Glück
dass es mit unserer Partei wieder eine
politische Heimat gibt eine Partei die
Menschen Hoffnung und Zuversicht gibt
mit einer einzigartigen Kombination an
Programmatik und die einzige relevante
Partei Daniela dann hat es gesagt die
eine konsequente Friedenspolitik
verfolgen wird liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde
ja es gibt eine
repräsentationslücke und ja es ist gut
dass wir sie füllen und zugleich bin ich
davon überzeugt dass sich die Menschen
neben anderen Inhalten auch nach einer
anderen politischen Kultur Sehnen viele
wenden sich ja deswegen von Politik ab
sind geradezu abgetörnt von davon die
Politiker sich
verhalten mit unserem Neuanfang haben
wir nun auch die Chance zu einer neuen
politischen Kultur beizutragen eine
Kultur bei der Politiker zuerst an
diejenigen denken für die sie Politik
machen sollen und nicht anen eigenen
Vorteil oder an lobbyinessen bei der in
der Sache hart und kontrovers gestritten
wird es aber im Dialog respektvoll
zugeht gerade auch mit politischen
Wettbewerbern bei der politischer Streit
so geführt wird dass man sich nicht als
Feind begegnet sondern in der Lage ist
anschließend zusammen Lösungen zu finden
und dabei glaubwürdig zu bleiben bei
der
bei der Politiker mit den Ressourcen
über die sie verfügen sorgsam umgehen
und über Verschwendung nicht
achselzuckend hinwegblicken und bei der
Kompetenz und Fähigkeiten wieder zu
Kriterien werden nach denen Menschen
politische Verantwortung übertragen
wird und ich bin sicher wenn uns das
gelingt eine solche Kultur in der Partei
und im politischen Wettbewerb vorzuleben
werden viele Menschen Politik und
staatlichen Institutionen wieder
Vertrauen
schenken liebe Freundin und Freunde
viele aus meinem Umfeld haben mir in den
letzten Wochen für den Schritt in die
Politik Respekt gezollt dennoch empfinde
ich es zuallererst als Vorrecht und auch
als Verpflichtung diesem Land dem ich so
viel zu verdanken habe durch meine
politische Arbeit was zurückzugeben und
in diesem Sinne freue ich mich sehr
darauf mit euch zusammen ein neues
politisches Kapitel in Deutschland
aufzuschlagen und danke euch allen sehr
für euer Vertrauen lasst uns gemeinsam
daran arbeiten vielen
Dank chervin Hino stellvertretender
Parteivorsitzender des BSW bekommt
natürlich auch stehenden Applaus hier
von den rund
450 Anwesenden
Parteimitgliedern er wird nur noch kurze
Zeit der einzige stellvertretende
Parteivorsitzende sein denn heute im
Laufe des Tages wird er zwei weitere
Stellvertreter Rinnen
dazuekommen und jetzt sagt Jessica Tati
die im Moment das tagungspräsidium
leitet bzw durch diesen ersten
Bundesparteitag für den nächsten
redneransagen und das ist Ralf suikat
Bundesschatzmeister des
bsw
ist stark wenn er verbunden ist das
spüren wir heute hier und es hat vor
über 200 Jahren schon Wolfgang Johan
Wolfgang von Gothe gesagt liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde heute am 27
januar stehen wir hier im Kosmos Berlin
um uns miteinander zu
verbinden um gemeinsamin hat gesagt ein
neues Kapitel
aufzuschlagen Kapitel das nicht nur die
Geschichte unserer neuegründeten Partei
prägt sondern auch weitreiche
Auswirkungen auf unsere Gesellschaft
haben
wird Kosmos das klingt nicht nur
irgendwie schön es bedeutet auch die
unsumgebende
Welt
bezeichnenderweise ist Kosmos aber auch
der Gegenbegriff zum
Chaos woanders
als hier können wir also beginnen
gemeinsam das Chaos aufzuräumen dass die
Ampel und 16 Jahre lang CDU geführte
Regierung hinterlassen
haben wir treten hier und heute an um
gemeinsam das Land zusammenzuführen
auskömmliche Arbeits Verhältnisse zu
schaffen Schuldächer zu reparieren
Bahnstrecken zu
sanieren wenn Spaltung und Konflikt die
Welt beherrschen liegt eine unserer
zentralen Aufgaben darin eine Vision zu
schaffen eine Vision von der Welt in der
wir leben
wollen diese Vision möchten wir
gemeinsam mit euch kreieren und zusammen
mit den Menschen in unserem Land in die
Welt
bringen wir möchten das Gefühl der
Gemeinsamkeit und Verbundenheit wieder
erlebbar machen
Verbundenheit bedeutet sich für die
Rechte und Freiheiten eines jeden
Einzelnen
einzusetzen Verbundenheit aber auch das
Verbindende in den Mittelpunkt zu
stellen nicht das Trennende zu
suchen es bedeutet auch Liebe über den
Hass zu stellen so schwer dass auch in
einer spezifischen Situation ein ums
andere Mal sein
mag in einer Gesellschaft der
Verbundenheit un das Wirtschaftssystem
nicht für einige wenige sondern für
alle liebe Freundinnen und Freunde ich
war ein
ampelwähler heute sind nur noch 8% der
Bevölkerung mit der Regierung zufrieden
das ein absoluter historischer
Tiefstand die Message ist klar Menschen
lehnen eine Ideologie Politik
ab die Konsequenzen sehen und erleben
wir jeden Tag immer mehr Menschen
verlieren den Glauben an die Politik sie
wenden sich ab sie resignieren sie gehen
gar nicht mehr wählen oder Sie wenden
sich aus Protest einer Partei zu deren
Werte sie eigentlich nicht ansatzweise
vertreten
für mich als Unternehmer wurde es immer
unerträglicher der Ampel beim Regierung
zuzuschauen und das nicht nur wegen der
wirtschaftsfeindlichen Inhalte ich finde
insbesondere auch die Art und Weise wie
über die Bürger hinweg regiert wird
mittlerweile
unerträglich die Ampel hat
politisiert das BSW ist zu meiner
persönlichen zu unser aller politischen
Heimat
geworden mir persönlich ist es wichtig
dass es BSW zu einer Anlaufstelle der
Zuversicht wird eine Anlaufstelle die
Menschen in unserem Land die daran
glauben dass ein andere ein
funktionierendes ein besseres
Deutschland möglich ist aufsuchen
können eine
Anlaufstelle für Menschen die sich eine
Regierung wünschen die ihre Sorgen und
Nöte ernst nimmt eine Anlaufstelle für
Unternehmer die sich in ihrem Kampf
gegen Bürokratie und steigende
Energiepreise Unterstützung
wünschen eine Anlaufstelle vor allem
aber auch für all diejenigen die
gemeinsam mit uns Politik gestalten
wollen wir stehen heute nicht nur als
Mitglieder einer neugegründeten Partei
sondern auch als Gemeinschaft die für
eine bessere Zukunft kämft eine Zukunft
in der soziale Gerechtigkeit
wirtschaftliche Vernunft Frieden und
Freiheit nicht nur Worte sondern das
solide Fundament unserer Gesellschaft
werden
lasst uns die Zuversicht die heute hier
im Raum zu spüren ist mitnehmen in
unsere Familien an unsere Arbeitsstellen
lasst sie uns ins ganze Land tragen und
lasst uns die Botschaft aussenden
Deutschland kann dank
euch
Ralf suikat ist der Bundesschatzmeister
des BSW kommt jetzt doch noch etwas
verspätet zu stehendem Applaus auch er
spart nicht mit pauschal Kritik an der
Politik oder an der Ampel wir werden das
im Laufe des Tages immer wieder auch mal
hören wir sind ja nicht nur hier um
Ihnen zu zeigen was hier passiert
sondern wir sind auch hier um hin zu
hinterfragen
hier passiert und hinterfagt hat Mark
steinhuser das ganze hier im Gespräch
mit Amira Mohammed
Ali Amira Mohamed Ali sie teilen sich
die Parteispitze jetzt mit Sarah
Wagenknecht was können Sie jetzt hier
heute auch tun damit das Ganze keine one
woman Show wird so wie es im Namen steht
ja das ist ja erstmal auch
Interpretation das es eine one woman
Show wäre aber heute ist unser großer
Bundesparteitag wir werden hier heute
den Vorstand wählen also den Vorstand
komplettieren so muss man es ja sagen es
wurde ja bereits bei der Gründung ein
Vorstand gewählt wir werden heute in
Europaliste aufstellen und da wird man
schon sehr deutlich sehen dass wir
wirklich viele ganz tolle und
qualifizierte Menschen in unseren rein
haben also sie heben ab auf weitere
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten die noch
dazu kommen nun ist es ein Ort an dem ja
früher SED granten ins Kino gegangen
sind was für ein Signal haben Sie
eigentlich ausgesendet oder was wollen
sie aussenden mit diesem Ort hier
ja das finde ich jetzt tsälich ein
bisschen überinterpretiert ich meine das
ist das kosmoskino hier finden
regelmäßig viele Veranstaltungen statt
es ist ein Ort hier mitten im Herzen
Berlins wir wollten natürlich den
Parteitag gerne in Berlin machen halt im
in der Hauptstadt und diesen Ort haben
wir dafür gebucht und ich finde es ist
ein sehr schönes Kino und sehr schöner
Ort um das zu machen ein schöner Ort
ohne Signal ja ohne Signal das ist
einfach ein guter Tagungsort der von den
Räumlichkeiten gut passt und ja genau
deswegen sind wir hier also wir haben
jetzt gehört Kandidaten kommen auf die
nicht nur Sara Wagenknecht sie sind mit
dabei und was wollen sie insgesamt
aussenden mit diesem Tag heute es gab ja
schon viele Pressekonferenzen in den
vergangenen Wochen wo sie in der
Bundespressekonferenz saßen und ein
bisschen skizziert haben wo es hingehen
könnte was ist das jetzt heute für ein
Schritt heute geht es uns auch darum zu
zeigen dass wir wirklich breit
aufgestellt sind dass wir Menschen aus
der ganzen Breite der Bevölkerung bei
uns haben hier sind Leute aus allen
berufsgrumen wir haben Pflegekräfte wir
haben Hochschulprofessoren wir haben
Handwerker wir haben auch Politikerinnen
und Politiker die bei uns sind und
lauter andere Menschen die wirklich sich
hier einbringen wollen und damit wollen
wir zeigen dass wir ganz breit
aufgestellt sind wir kommen aus der
Breite der Gesellschaft und wir wollen
auch genau in diese breite wirken wen
wollen Sie erreichen bei den Wählerinnen
und Wählern sie haben manchmal gesagt in
der Sozialpolitik sind Sie dafür dass
die Renten erhöht werden sie haben an
anderer Stelle gesagt beim Bürgergeld
soll es nicht so viele berechtigte geben
man fragt sich ja doch was ist das für
eine Sozialpolitik wofür stehen sie
eigentlich wenn Sie die Sozialpolitik
ansprechen kann ich das kurz
zusammenfassen wir stehen für soziale
Gerechtigkeit und natürlich auch für
einen Sozialstaat der wirklich
funktioniert wir erleben das dass viele
Rentnerinnen und Rentner in Armut leben
und armutsrenten betroffen sind das ist
ein riesen Problemem ich finde das ist
für ein Land wie Deutschland einfach
unwürdig dass Menschen im Alter arm sind
wir wollen auch dass wir ein
vernünftiges und gut a ausgestattetes
Gesundheitswesen haben dass alle
Menschen gut versorgt werden dass auch
auch wenn man dann irgendwann im Alter
pflegebedürftig ist dass man dann nicht
in der Armutsfalle ist oder die
Verwandtschaft in der in die Armutsfalle
kommt wir wollen dass Menschen gute
Löhne bekommen sichere Arbeitsplätze
bekommen wir wollen das kurz
zusammengefasst dass diejenigen die
jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehen und fleißig
sind und unser Land hier am Laufen
halten dass deren Arbeit auch vernünftig
gewürdigt wird das zielt ab auf die
arbeitende Bevölkerung gleichzeitig
haben sie auch in den vergangenen Wochen
gesagt haben sie auch in anderen Themen
Ansätze die man sonst eher bei
konservativen verortet Sarah Wagenknecht
hat schon gesagt rechts und links das
gilt nicht mehr können Sie vielleicht
mal sagen wo sehen Sie denn Punkte wo
sie konservativer sind als die
Linkspartei sie waren ja Fraktionschefin
der Linken wo Grenzen sie sich da jetzt
ab ja man kann es in unserem Programm ja
lesen also was wir machen wollen ist
eine pragmatische Politik eine
realistische Politik die wirklich ganz
konkret ansetzt und konkrete
Verbesserungen vorschlägt ein Punkt bei
dem wir uns also es gibt einige Punkte
aber ein Punkt bei dem wir uns z.B auch
klar unter unterscheiden von den
Forderungen der Linken ist dass wir
sagen in der Migrationspolitik brauchen
wir Steuerung wir brauchen eine
Begrenzung der Migration denn wir sehen
tatsächlich dass heute viele Städte und
Gemeinden sagen sie können nicht mehr es
sind zu viele Menschen das war früher
auch schon mal anders im Jahr 2015 als
ich auch die Meinung vertreten habe dass
eigentlich alle Menschen zu uns kommen
sollen war eine andere Situation aber
heute ist es halt die Lage wirklich
angespannt sie haben noch 2019 in dem
Interview gesagt sie sind generell gegen
Abschiebungen und keine Abschiebungen
nach Afghanistan keine Abschiebung nach
Syrien gar nichts das waren ihre Worte
warum sagen Sie jetzt was anderes ich
hab's ja gerade schon gesagt die
Situation war damals auch eine andere da
war es eben nicht so dass wie heute
viele Städte und Gemeinden sagten wir
können wirklich nicht mehr und wenn man
das sieht wenn man sieht dass immer mehr
Überforderung da ist das ist auch immer
mehr Akzeptanz dafür da ist dann muss
man einfach feststellen dass das System
wie wir es jetzt haben nicht
funktioniert hat und es muss doch darum
gehen dass die Menschen die wirklich
einen asylanspruch haben dass die den
auch bekommen dass die das auch
realisieren können und dass sie sich
auch nicht um den lebensge über den auf
den lebensgefährlichen Weg übers
Mittelmeer machen müssen und
Schlepperbanden dafür bezahlen müssen
für teuer Geld um herkommen zu dürfen
nein Menschen die ein Anspruch auf
Schutz haben die müssen auch Schutz
bekommen aber diejenigen die keinen
Anspruch haben damit muss man auch
umgehen und dann muss man auch
abschieben ich fürchte das ist leider
die Konsequenz weil die Realität uns
zeigt dass es anders nicht geht damit
sprechen Sie was an wo vielleicht auch
der ein oder andere bei Ihnen ein Kreuz
machen könnte der sich im Moment
vielleicht der AFD zugeordnet fühlt wie
wollen sie sich da eigentlich abgrenzen
von der AFD äh klappt das aus ihrer
Sicht denn schon ausreichend wissen Sie
es ist unsere feste Überzeugung dass wir
für unsere Inhalte stehen und wir
richten uns jetzt nicht an anderen
Parteien aus und lassen uns gar von
anderen vorschreiben was wir sagen und
was wir fordern dürfen und machen solch
Unterschiede nicht oh weil a das
gefordert hat dürfen wir das jetzt nicht
mehr sagen nein wir stehen für unsere
Inhalte und wenn man unser Programm
liest wenn man unsere reden hört wenn
man sieht W bei uns dabei ist ehrlich
gesagt ich finde diese
vermeintliche AFD nee ich finde es
völlig absurd sagen sie andererseits
gibt es ja auch eine Diskussion darüber
die AFD insgesamt zu verbieten da haben
sie schon gesagt das sehen Sie kritisch
das heißt sie wollen lieber der AFD in
den
Wahlkämpfen mit ähnlichen Positionen
Paroli bieten anstatt diese Partei mit
einem Verbotsverfahren zu überziehen
also auch das ist jetzt eine
Interpretation ich weiß nicht inliche
Position da haben sie jetzt wieder
irgendwie Vergleich aufgemacht den ich
so tatsälich nicht sehe aber ich möchte
mal was zu dem Thema Verbotsverfahren
sagen erstens muss man sagen so ein
Verbotsverfahren dauert lange Zeit das
dauert viele Jahre ich persönlich halte
es für sehr unwahrscheinlich dass das äh
von Erfolg gekrönt sein wird aber das
Problem ist doch ein anderes wenn ich
sehe dass in Deutschland rechtsextreme
immer mehr Zuspruch haben aus der
Bevölkerung wenn man die Umfragewerte
ansieht dann ist es ein politisches
Problem und dann muss man sich ernsthaft
fragen was läuft in der herrschenden
Politik falsch dass so viele Menschen
ernsthaft meinen ihr kreuzb rechtsextrem
machen zu wollen da muss man doch
ansetzen und ich glaube so ein
Verbotsverfahren wird das Gegenteil
bewirken das wird dazu führen dass die
AFD wie sie ja gerne macht sich wieder
in die Opferrolle begibt und sagt ach
guck mal da alle gegen uns und so weiter
man kennt es ja das heißt es wird eher
der AFD nützen als dass ihr in der
Realität schaden wird das Problem ist
ein politisches und ich muss schon sagen
ich finde das auch
insgesamt fast ein bisschen zynisch wenn
gerade die Regierungsparteien so etwas
unterstützen und dazu aufrufen die nun
wirklich einen erheblichen Beitrag dafür
leisten dass Partei überhaupt so stark
geworden ist wenn man mal schaut die
umfragewte der AFD haben sich verdoppelt
seit die ampelregierung im Amt ist da
ist doch ein Problem zu sehen und so
muss man das auch angehen dann schauen
wir mal wie sie das tun sagt die
Parteivorsitzende hier im Gespräch bei
Phönix Amira Mohammed Ali vom Bündnis
SAR bknecht besten Dank sehr
gern und da sind wir wieder live meine
Damen und Herren im Kosmos in der Kosmos
Event Location hier in
in und wir sind beim Gründungsparteitag
des Bündnis s Wagenknecht und wir sind
beim
teilungsordnungspunkt Wahl von stell
weiteren stellvertretenden
Parteivorsitzenden chervin h haben sie
ja vorhin live schon gesehen jetzt
stellen sich hier weitere Kandidaten für
den stellvertretenden Parteivorsitz vor
im Moment am Pult war Friederike Bender
die mal Mitglied der LINKEN war hier in
Berlin sich jetzt auch dem BSW
angeschlossen hat und in ihrer
Bewerbungsrede hat sie kritisiert die
ganz große Koalition aus SPD FDP Grünen
und Union in Sachen Rüstung und
Friedenspolitik hat sich gegen
Rechtsextremismus ausgesprochen aber
auch gegen weitere Waffenlieferungen für
die Ukraine der Krieg in der gegen die
Ukraine hätte verhindert und beendet
werden können russland hat sie in ihrem
Redebeitrag übrigens nicht erwähnt und
jetzt gibt es die Möglichkeit der
parteitagsmitglieder
an
die unterliegen solltest würdest Du
darauf verzichten für den zweiten
sozusagen Platz als
stellvertretende Parteivorsitzende zu
kandidieren ja gut
danke dann kämen wir jetzt im Alphabet
zum nächsten Kandidaten für den zweiten
Platz und zwar das wäre
amid rabie amid komm bitte auf die Bühne
und amid Rab war mal stellvertretender
Landesvorsitzender der Linken in
nordrehein-westfalen liebe Freundinnen
und Freunde meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen jede große Veränderung beginnt
mit einem ersten Schritt und ich bin
froh und dankbar diesen wichtigen
Schritt heute mit euch gemeinsam zu
beehen denn nach dem heutigen Parteitag
ist unsere Strukturierung vollendet und
spätestens dann müsste es klar sein hier
entsteht eine neue politische Kraft die
das Potenzial hat die gesamte etablierte
Parteienlandschaft ordentlich unter
Druck zu setzen und es ist doch
allerhöchste Eisenbahn dass sich in
diesem Land mal etwas
bewegt denn die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
haben genug von einer Politik die ihnen
permanent ins greift und sie dann doch
wegen gleichstörungen liegen lässt die
Folge ist doch dass immer mehr Menschen
mit niedrigem und mitittlerem Einkommen
fürchten müssen dass es am Ende des
Monats dann doch nicht mehr reicht
Abstiegsangst und Unsicherheit prägen
ihren Alltag und während knapp 10
Millionen Bürger nicht mal mehr genug
haben um regelmäßig gesund zu essen
steigern große Lebensmittelkonzerne wie
edik ihren Gewinn um über 30% und das
ist ja nicht vom Himmel gefallen das ist
politisch gemacht und dann wundern sich
die Regierungsparteien die seit
Jahrzehnten die Bedürfnisse und Wünsche
der Menschen in diesem Land mit Füßen
treten dass diese sich zurecht von ihnen
abwenden und es ist wirklich
bemerkenswert das ausgerechnet diese
Parteien jetzt auch noch so tun als
hätten sie die Demokratie erfunden nur
weil sie gegen die Früchte ihrer eigenen
Politik auf die Straße gehen zur
Wahrheit gehört dass Armut und soziale
Ungleichheit pures Gift für die
Demokratie sind und wer die Demokratie
in diesem Land stärken will der muss für
mehr sozialen Ausgleich sorgen und
deswegen ist es uns eine
Herzensangelegenheit ja wir wollen mehr
Demokratie wagen indem wir mehr soziale
Gerechtigkeit Wagen liebe Freundin und
Freunde denn nur so wird ein Schuh
daraus und noch nie gab es in der
Bundesrepublik so große Hemmungen seine
politische Meinung zu äußern wenn nur
noch 40% der Bürger der Auffassung sind
dass sie ihre Meinung frei äußern können
dann ist es klar wie vergiftet das
Meinungsklima inzwischen in diesem Land
ist und was werden einem da auch die
Worte im Munde umgedreht da versuchen
Sie uns den Export von Waffen als
Beitrag zum Frieden zu verkaufen und
wenn eine deutsche Außenministerin
ankündigt ein einziges
ein ganzes Land für die Fehlentscheidung
ihrer Regierung ruinieren zu wollen dann
hat das mit Völkerverständigung nichts
zu tun und wir sagen in aller
Deutlichkeit wirtschaftskriege sind kein
Beitrag für den Frieden und
Waffenexporte sind kein Beitrag um
Konflikte zu bewältigen liebe Freundin
Freunde im
Gegenteil für uns ist es klar und
eingangs haben schon andere gesagt wir
sind inzwischen noch die einzige
konsequente Friedenspartei deswegen ist
es für uns klar wir wollen die Sprache
des sebbelrasselns und der Waffenexporte
die Sprache der Diplomatie der
Verständigung und des
Interessensausgleich entgegenhalten ihr
seht es gibt viel für uns zu tun liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde und ich würde
gerne als stellvertretender
Parteivorsitzender die Ärmel
hochkrempeln mit anpacken und die
Strukturierung unserer Partei noch ein
Stück weiter voranzubringen und ich
hoffe dass ihr mich dabei unterstützt
vielen Dank glück
auf
amit lieber amit vielen
Dank auch hier jetzt die Möglichkeit
Fragen an den Kandidaten zu
stellen gibt es jemand der Fragen an
amit
hat das
scheint mir nicht der Fall zu sein dann
würde ich sagen amit du bist erstmal
entlassen und wir gehen in den ich werde
auch nicht kandidieren genau aber es
gibt ja auch das musstest du an der
Stelle deswegen nicht erklären weil es
gibt keinen weiteren Platz auf dem du
hättest antreten können sof das haben
wir alles mit berücksichtigt
hier und wir
steigen jetzt gleich konkret in den
Wahlgang ein und zwar haben wir ja wie
amid sagte ja zunächst festgestellt dass
äh es keine weiteren Plätze mehr gibt
und nicht die Möglichkeit dass einer von
den beiden noch mal auf dem anderen
Platz kandidiert das heißt im
Umkehrschluss die Voraussetzungen die
rechtlichen Voraussetzungen für eine
verbundene Einzelwahl liegen weiterhin
vor
ähm die Helfer äh der Wahlkommission
werden sich jetzt gleich postieren an
den Rändern der
Reihen ich hoffe sie kommen jetzt
gleich da sehe ich schon die ersten
genau also jeweils links und rechts an
den Rändern der der Stuhlreihen werdet
ihr gleich die Helfer der Wahlkommission
sehen und die Idee ist folgende die
Helfer der Wahlkommission werden durch
die Reihen durchlaufen insofern ist es
wichtig dass ihr nach Möglichkeit sitzen
bleibt es sei denn ihr möchtet von der
Möglichkeit Gebrauch machen in einer
Wahlkabine zu wählen draußen im foryier
sind Wahlkabinen aufgestellt wer möchte
kann den Wahlzettel mit nach draußen
nehmen und in der Wahlkabine Wlen so
jetzt glaube ich haben wir das Prozedere
verstanden dass Patrick Wahl hier
erklärt der N ist Omen auch der Leiter
dieser Wahl ist und es wird ja nicht die
einzige Wahl sein die heute hier im
Laufe des späten vormittags frühen
Nachmittags stattfinden wird wir sind
jetzt bei den zusätzlichen
stellvertretenden Parteivorsitzenden es
gibt zwei Kandidaten eine Kandidatin
Friederike Bender und eben amid Rab
beide ehemals Mitglieder der Partei DIE
LINKE beide da nicht mehr zufrieden
gewesen mit dem Kurs und beide haben ja
ausdrücklich erklärt dass sie für eine
Friedenspartei sich engagieren wollen
also eine die sich konsequent für
Frieden für Abrüstung einsetzt über die
Argumentation werden viele Beobachter
sagen dass man darüber streiten kann
gerade im Hinblick auf den Krieg gegen
Russlands gegen die Ukraine wir nutzen
die Gelegenheit für weitere Analysen des
deswegen sind wir ja unter anderem auch
hier und deswegen gebe ich ganz fix ab
an Mark Steinhäuser während ich Ihnen
noch die Information mit auf den Weg
gebe dass sie jetzt Stimmzettel
eingesammelt werden und anschließend
ausgezählt Mark vielen Dank er scherfer
ja die Details die sind wichtig bei
diesem ersten Bundesparteitag des
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht mit uns
beobachtet das ganze die
Politikwissenschaftlerin Julia
Reuschenbach von der Freien Universität
Berlin willkommen zurück hier danke
fr wir werden jetzt ja diesen Wahlgang
hier beobachten undun gab es ja schon
diese
Gründungsversammlung es gibt 450
Mitglieder aber nicht jeder kann im
Moment mitmachen vielleicht noch mal
ganz kurz zu diesen formalen Dingen was
ist jetzt hier anders als sonst bei
einem Parteitag na ja also die
Besonderheit liegt sicherlich darin dass
diese Gründungsversammlung so ein
bisschen unter dem Radar stattfand das
war so ein gemeinsames Treffen und da
wurde eben dieser Parteivorstand wir
haben es eben gehört Sarah Wagenknecht
Amira Mohammed Ali Stellvertreter
Schatzmeister die wurden sozusagen dort
schon bestimmt und jetzt erleben wir
hier im Wahlgang eben die zusätzliche
Wahl von stellvertretenden
Parteivorsitzenden aber wir erleben
nicht im Grunde das was wir vielleicht
sonst erwarten würden dass ich jetzt
auch die beiden Vorsitzenden noch mal
zur wahlstellen sonder sind schon quasi
im Amt genau die sind schon da und Sara
wanken nicht z.B wird ja auch erst
später sprechen insofern sehen wir so
ein bisschen eine Veränderung und in der
Tat man hat sich auf die fahen
geschrieben als Partei Neugründung
Miriam Holstein hat das heute morgen im
Gespräch ich bei Ihnen auch schon
erwähnt
langsam Schritt für Schritt die Partei
aufzubauen also auch erstmal die Zahl
derer die Mitglied werden können zu
begrenzen und so ist eben die Zahl derer
entstanden die heute jetzt hier
zusammengekommen sind dann vielleicht
noch mal gefragt bei anderen
Parteigründungen in der Vergangenheit in
der Bundesrepublik nehmen wir mal die
Piraten oder die Alternative für
Deutschland da kamen ja dann am Anfang
auch ganz viele Leute dazu die Parteien
wurden relativ am Anfang relativ groß
auch das ist vielleicht etwas wovor man
hier Angst hat dass dann Leute dazu
kommen die man nicht kennt
ist das der Grund aus ihrer Sicht warum
Sarah Wagenknecht ja sage ich mal diesen
Aufnahmestopp erstmal vorgenommen hat na
ja also der Grund liegt natürlich auch
darin dass ja in den ersten Wochen Tagen
als klar war dass sie tatsächlich eine
Partei aufbauen will viel darüber
berichtet wurde wo sie womöglich denn
potentiell Wählerinnen und Wähler
generieren könnte und da ist eben es
gibt auch aus der Politikwissenschaft
einige erste Studien die zumindest grob
versuchen dieses Wähler Potenzial zu
skizzieren und da deutet sich eben an
dass sie insbesondere dort wo die AFD
erfolgreich ist bei Wählerinnen und
Wählern womöglich punkten könnte und das
hat diese Frage auch ausgelöst wer
sozusagen strebt womöglich an in einer
solchen Partei dann auch mitzuwirken
Ämter zu übernehmen sichtbar zu sein und
aus ein strategischen Sicht aus Sicht
der Partei also dieser neuen Partei hier
ist es sicherlich klug zu sagen wir
machen das langsam weil sara wangnicht
hat glaube ich auch in der
Pressekonferenz den Begriff der Glücks
Dritter benutzt hat gesagt da wollen
immer ganz schnell dann auch viele
mitmischen wo man ein bisschen gucken
muss dass der Laden sozusagen nicht
gleich wieder auseinander fliegt ähm
aber sie ist da sicherlich
sensibilisiert für umgekehrt haben wir
aber aus meiner Sicht gerade in allen
Redebeiträgen doch deutlich rausfören
können dass man zumindest in der Art der
Sprache äh sehr nah an dem ist was die
AFD auch anbietet nämlich vor allen
Dingen wirklich viel
sehr ja von populistischen narrativen
geprägte Kritik
Amira mit Mur mit Ali z.B hat hat gesagt
sie möchten äh die Partei das Bündnis
wolle nicht Teil der herrschenden Elite
sein sowieso der Begriff der
herrschenden viel relativ häufig so
diese klare Gegensätzlichkeit von die da
oben versus wir hier unten ähm und das
deutet schon an dass man natürlich auch
da bei diesen Menschen auf Wählerinnen
und Wähler spekuliert die Frage ist ja
ob das funktioniert die Umfragen die
Erhebungen sind ja sehr unterschiedlich
je nachdem welche Messmethode verwendet
wird welches Institut da fragt manchmal
sind die Zahlen einstellig manchmal sind
die Zahlen zweiständlig dann gibt es
irgendwelche Zahlen wo es heißt 17% der
Deutschen könnten sich vorstellen Frau
Wagenknecht als Kanzlerkandidatin zu
wählen was für ein Potenzial sehen Sie
das wäre natürlich jetzt ein Knaller
wenn ich jetzt sozusagen belastbare
Zahlen dabei hätte im Grunde haben sie
ja einfach deutlich gemacht dass es ganz
schwierig ist eine Partei die noch wenig
programmatisches hat die noch keinen
Wahlkampf führen musste die auch noch
wenig Gesichter hat wir dürfen nicht
vergessen für die Landtagswahlen in
Brandenburg Sachsen und Thüringen
braucht des landesverbändes es braucht
Menschen die auf diesen Straßen in den
Bundesländern sichtbar sind da wird
vieles über die Popularität von sarabank
nicht gehen aber längst nicht alles
insofern ist es sehr schwierig das zu
beurteilen was man andeuten kann ist
sicherlich dass sie als Person oder ich
gehe noch mal ein Schritt zurück die
Politikwissenschaft würde ja immer sagen
wir haben so drei Dinge die wichtig sind
wenn wir auf eine Partei schauen das
sind die Parteibindung die können
naturgemäß noch nicht so stark sein die
Partei ist neu das sind Partei Programm
und Person und bei den letzten beiden
kann man zumindest sagen die Person ist
enorm populär Sarah Wagenknecht hat
einen extrem hohen Bekanntheitsgrad es
geht ja nicht nur um Beliebtheit sondern
auch um die Frage wie viele Menschen
kennen eigentlich die Person um die es
geht und sie sicherlich zugfährt sieht
man auch daran dass der Name jetzt so
prominent erstmal vorläufig im Namen der
Partei geblieben ist beim Programm haben
wir zumindest die Vermutung und das sind
die Studien auch aus unserem Fach die
sie erwähnt haben wohin die Reise gehen
könnte und dass es tatsächlich im
momentanen Parteienspektrum ein bisschen
eine Lehrstelle gibt an so einer
linkskonservativen Position aber ich
würde mich weder den 17 noch den 7%
Umfragen jetzt anschließen wollen
sondern ich glaube wir müssen Geduld
haben auch wenn das schwer ist und
abwarten wie sich wirklich jetzt dieser
parteiafbau
zeigen wird denn im Grunde ist ja der
Tag heute so der erste Höhepunkt der
sehr viel das sehen wir ja auch hier im
Raum enorm viel mediale Aufmerksamkeit
bekommt aber so die Mühen der Ebene das
was jetzt ansteht in den nächsten
Monaten das wird eigentlich wirklich
zeigen wie viel Potenzial für dieses
Bündnis tatsächlich da ist vielen Dank
bis hierhin Julia Reuschenbach wir
werden jetzt weil der Wahlgang ja auch
noch läuft und uns natürlich auch
interessiert wer macht denn hier
eigentlich mit außer SAR Wagenknecht wer
sind diese Personen die hier in diesem
Saal sind wer sind die anderen 450 wir
werden deshalb jetzt mal in diesen Saal
blicken und meine Kollegin Julia Grimm
ist zwischen den engen Reihen und hat
vielleicht jemanden an ihrer Seite um da
ein bisschen Licht ins Dunkle zu bringen
ja das ist zumindest das was ich jetzt
hier versuchen werde wir haben uns mal
gewagt hier unten rein in die engen
Reihen allerdings in die etwas
angenehmeren rein denn hier vorne gibt
es Tische hinten ist das dann noch mal
deutlich enger denn es ist ja ein
relativ kleiner Raum für 450 Menschen
und ich frage jetzt einfach mal hier wir
sind in NRW sage ich mal in anderen
Fällen würde man ja sagen beim
Landesverband NRW aber den gibt es ja
noch gar nicht sie frage ich gleich
jetzt frage ich zuerst sie sagen Sie mir
doch mal was treibt sie zum Bündnis
um sind sie hier und wollen Mitglied
werden oder sind es schon ich möchte
Mitglied ich bin schon Mitglied geworden
ja Hoffnung ist dass was zurzeit die
etablierte Partei nicht schaffen ich
hoffe dass wir eine vernünftige und
gerechte Sozialpolitik wieder herstellen
dass ein vernünftige Friedenspolitik
wieder bekommen das ist in dieser Partei
setzich große Hoffnung darf ich sie so
offen Fragen waren sie vorher
linkenmglied oder gar nicht politisch
aktiv bin immer politisch aktiv gewesen
bis 2003 war ich in SPD Mitglied mit dem
damal WS sind wir dann rüber gewechselt
ich bin Gewerkschafter gleichzeitig mit
dem arenta
2010 hab bin habe ich die SPD verlassen
sind rüber gegangen mit linke Partei
gegründet und seitdem die Linke auch die
Konsequenz die Friedenspolitik nicht
mereibt bin ich auch aus der linke auch
raus was kann denn ihrer Meinung nach
Sara Wagenknecht was die anderen vorher
nicht konnten also was erwarten Sie ganz
konkret welche Hoffnung haben sie da es
geht ja nicht allein SAR warkch ein
gesellschaftlicher Umdenken dass die
Menschen hinter dieser Politik
Friedenspolitik stehen also Sarah allein
wird ja auch ja nicht schaffen es geht
ja darum dass man diese Idee diese
Konsequenz Friedenspolitik
entrüstungspolitik betreibt dafür stehe
ich das Friedenspolitik heißt für sie
z.B mit Blick auf Ukraine Russland was
heißt das für sie nein nicht nur Ukraine
Russland weltweit sind ja sich
verschieden und Jemen in Libanon in
Syrien in Türkisch Kurdistan also ist
weltweit wir müssen nicht nur überall
konflikte sind eigentlich Konsequenz
keine Rüstung Zen zu liefern also keine
Rüstung auch in solche Länder sagen sie
und das würde zu mehr Frieden füen das
ist das was sie in der jetzigen
Regierung vermisst definitiv definitiv
also mehr Rüstung führt auch dazu dass
die Menschen Häuser Fluchtursachen sind
durch die
mehrrüstung
also S ist ja dies konquz nicht nur
flieggebiete sondern insgesamt rüung
zurückzufahren dafür stehe ich auch
danke schön soweit ich gehe mal eins
weiter nach links Rutsche etwas über den
Boden und frage mal hier sagen Sie mir
doch mal was treibt sie zum Bündnis Sara
Wagenknecht was haben sie für Hoffnung
also ich bin ja ein politischer Mensch
ich komme ursprünglich auch aus der SPD
also sozial dememokratische Partei
Deutschland ich war bei den ususus
unterwegs war im Vorstand bin 13 Jahre
Bürgermeister
in duburg gewesen bin Gewerkschafter
seit über 30 Jahren betreue tausende von
Menschen im Stahlbereich bin in der
Tarifkommission bin politischer Mensch
und mich hat überzeugt
dass die konsequente Haltung auch die
Überschrift also Vernunft in Industrie
Vernunft in Wirtschaft soziale
Gerechtigkeit hat für mich ganz wichtige
Bedeutung weil ja die Beschäftigten sich
ja insgesamt jetzt zurzeit unsicher
fühlen gerade in der
Transformationsphase gibt keine
Alternative woür viele Beschäftigte sich
sicher fühlen dass die die die
Transformationsphase für Unternehmen
auch
auch mit bestimmten Staats Hilfen und
industriestrompreise und so weiter da
spielt eine ganz große Rolle dass man
hier das Thema Vernunft
in Wirtschaft und in in Industrie für
ernst nimmt auch soziale Gerechtigkeit
und Frieden spielt eine ganz große Rolle
ich als Gewerkschafter Kommunalpolitiker
habe mich hier bei Bündnis Sara
wenknecht jetzt ab Januar gesehen und
ich finde heute die Reden von unserer
Parteivorsitzenden Amira Mohammed Ali
hat auch Zeichen gegeben dass wir es
ernst meinen ich bin eigentlich so ein
Stück sprechroh für die viel vielen
Beschäftigten in die in die ind in den
sag mal Energie intensiven
Unternehmen wie
Stahl und alle anderen Bereiche die
davon betroffen sind ich bin mir sicher
dass wir eine Alternative sind und dass
wir sehr viel Druck machen können mit
diese Überschrift konsequent Vernunft in
soziale Gerechtigkeit Vernunft in
Wirtschaft und auch aber auch in
Industrie Europa spielt da eine ganz
große Rolle viele Dinge wir national
hier in Deutschland Regeln m sich Europa
noch ein gerade
Arbeitsplatzsicherung raus aus Europa
nee europa muss stark aufgestellt
werden stärker aufgestellt werden mit
den Themen soziale Gerechtigkeit
bestimmte Standards für
Arbeitsplatzsicherung Ausbau der
Industrie Zuschüsse nicht die
Schuldenbremse sondern andersrum
bestimmte Möglichkeiten zu geben dass
auch Industrie in Europa weiter stabil
bleibt die Infrastruktur der kommun
Spiel eine ganz große Rolle ich muss
jetzt noch mal fragen weil ich das so
spannend finde was sie gerade am Anfang
gesagt
haben sie sind aus der SPD raus weil
weil sie was haben Sie in der SPD nicht
mehr gesehen wir haben damals ja dieses
dieses müssen kurz machen damit wir dem
Generalsekretär zuhören aber sagen Sie
bitte was sie sagen Agenda 2010 hat mich
da aus der SPD
rausgerissen das war sehr kurz und sehr
konkret ich danke ihn ganz herzlich und
wir gehen direkt in die Rede des
Generalsekretärs danke Größe dieser
Aufgabe und wir wissen auch um unsere
Verantwortung in nur Z Jahren eine
Partei aus dem Boden zu stampfen die von
Tag 1 an politisch handlungsfähig ist
und das in der aktuellen gemengenlage
und unter den Augen der Öffentlichkeit
das ist eine Herkules Aufgabe aber aus
ganz
Deutschland aus ganz Deutschland sitzen
heute dietigsten und die
entschlossensten hier im Saal und ich
sage euch mit niemandem anderen würde
ich diesen Weg lieber starten als mit
euch vielen Dank an
[Applaus]
Euch wir kommen aus unterschiedlichen
Parteien wir kommen mit
unterschiedlichen Geschichten aber wir
kommen aus gemeinsamer Verantwortung
zusammen denn unser Land steckt in der
Krise ein Krieg in Europa der nicht
enden will eine Inflation unter der die
Menschen leiden ein System in dem die
armen verzweifeln und die Reichen sich
die Taschen voll stopfen und ein
politisches Chaos in dem die Rechten
gewinnen und deswegen jetzt eine Partei
die den Rücken gerade macht und sagt es
reicht liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde und wenn man sich fragt wo die
Wut im Land denn eigentlich herkommt
dann muss man nicht lange suchen das
Tanken die Butter die Miete das Heizen
alles wird immer teurer so viel kann
manch einer gar nicht mehr arbeiten um
da noch hinterher zu kommen und
eigentlich bräuchte es doch jetzt eine
Regierung die sich schützend vor die
Menschen stellt und die Ihnen hilft aber
wir haben die
Ampel statt zu
statt zu helfen macht sie es noch
schlimmer die erhöht in dieser Lage doch
ernsthaft wieder die Steuern auf Energie
und dann hilft die Regierung nicht mehr
meid den Netz Entgelten was den Strom
noch teurer macht und dann erhöhen sie
den CO2 Preis um die Leute mitten in der
Inflation über höhere Preise zu besseren
Menschen zu erzielen ja was ist das denn
was für eine Arroganz der Macht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Erziehung statt
Hilfe das ist die
Ampel und dann erzählt uns die Regierung
dass sie leider bei uns allen sparen
muss für nichts ist mehr Geld da außer
für den Krieg und für Waffen da haben
sie Milliarden übrig ansonsten aber
sagen sie sie haben kein Geld
mehr ich aber sage nur 3% des Steuer
Aufkommens kommen aus Abgaben von
Vermögen und ich sage auch die fünf
reichsten Menschen in Deutschland sind
in den letzten 3 Jahren um unglaubliche
75% reicher geworden auf ihr eh schon
astronomisches Vermögen kamen
dreiviviertel oben noch mal drauf es
gibt in unserer Gesellschaft an der
Spitze Geld wie Heu es ist nur die Ampel
die das Geld der der ums verrecken nicht
haben will die greift lieber der
Bevölkerung in die Tasche und deswegen
sitzen wir heute hier und machen das
nicht
[Applaus]
mit die sparen lieber an unseren Schulen
die sparen lieber an unseren
Krankenhäusern die sparen lieber an den
Bauern die wurden doch von der
Bevölkerung gewählt aber Politik machen
sie für Banken und für Konzerne und für
deren Besitzer Liebe Kolleg
ist die
Wahheit aber es ist nicht nur die
Regierung die ausfällt es ist auch ein
Versagen der Opposition dass wir erleben
und ich rede jetzt nicht über die CDU
die an vielen Problemen die wir heute
Abend haben mit schuld ist und ich rede
auch nicht über die Linken ich rede über
die AFD die sich von der zweiflung der
Menschen ernährt was aber hat diese
Partei denn als Alternative zu bieten
was die Verzweiflung reduzieren
würde eine wissenschaftliche
Untersuchung des AFD Programms zeigt am
meisten profitieren Menschen mit einem
Jahreseinkommen von 300.000 € oder mehr
von der AFD Programmatik
300000 € pro Jahr oder mehr das ist die
Ziel Gruppe der AFD es gibt keine
einzige Partei im Deutschen Bundestag
von deren
steuerprogrammatik die Milliardäre mehr
profitieren würden als von der AFD das
ist doch keine
anti-establishment Partei liebe Freundin
und Freunde das ist eine Partei für die
Reichen und Mächtigen hinter der
Fassade
die
AFD will die Bauern unterstützen wenn
die wegen
subventionsstreichungen demonstrieren
aber im Parteiprogramm der AFD ist das
Kapitel Landwirtschaft überschrieben mit
weniger Subvention Liebe Bäuerinnen und
Bauern da draußen bitte lest euch das
Programm der AFD durch die wollen euch
einen Bären
aufbinden
Alis Weidel redet im Bundestag über
Zitat bürgerfeindliche
Verarmungspolitik aber als im Bundestag
über die Erhöhung des Mindestlohnes
abgestimmt wurde da haben die nicht
zugestimmt die hätten nur den Arm heben
müssen das haben sie aber nicht getan
für die hart arbeitenden Menschen da
draußen mit Bullshit Löhnen die gerade
am Fernseher sitzen die AFD kümmert sich
ein feuchten kehicht um sie und ihre
Probleme und das ist die
Wahrheit
immer immer wenn es ums Geld geht immer
wenn es ernst wird dann steht die AFD
fest an der Seite dieser Regierung und
aller Regierungen davor das ist doch
keine antisystempartei die sind das
System aber in undemokratisch und gemein
liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde
und das ist die Situation es versagt die
Regierung und es versagt die Opposition
und deswegen kommen wir heute hier
zusammen wir wollen eine Partei die sich
wieder für die Gemeinschaft einsetzt
eine Partei die in einer gespaltenen
Gesellschaft Brücken baut eine Partei
die zuhört anstatt zu belehren wir
wollen eine Partei die sich mit den mäch
anlegt anstatt sich wegzuducken die
wollen uns den Mund verbieten wenn wir
über Frieden reden ich sage euch
Freundinnen und Freunde nicht mit uns
und deswegen wollen wir eine Partei mit
mutigen Mitgliedern die fest
zusammenstehen auch dann wenn der Sturm
kommt wir wollen eine Partei in der der
Dienst an der politischen Sache wieder
wichtiger ist als der Dienst an den
eigenen politischen Interessen wir
wollen eine Partei in der das wir
wichtiger ist als dass ich wir wollen
Politik machen mit Ecken und mit Kanten
und mit klaren Worten aber mit einem
klaren Kompass auf Frieden und auf
Vernunft und auf Gerechtigkeit und auf
Freiheit und damit beginnen wir heute
danke
schön es ist ja nicht nur der erste
Bundesparteitag des BSW es ist auch ein
ganz großer ich nenne ihn jetzt mal
einigkeitsparteitag das sehen wir jetzt
wieder nach der Rede von Christian lei
der der Generalsekretär dieser neuen
Partei ist der bekommt natürlich auch
seinen stehenden Applaus wie alle
anderen Redner vor ihm auch was ich mich
jetzt bei einigen Rednern schon gefragt
habe im Laufe dieses Vormittags wer
eigentlich dem BSW bislang den Mund
verbieten wollte ich mir fällt keiner
ein es wird aber wiederholt hier
angesprochen als dürfe die Partei ihre
Meinung nicht sagen sie tut es jetzt
hier live bei uns auf dem Sender sie tut
es bei anderen Gelegenheiten sie hat
schon zwei Pressekonferenz
der Bundespressekonferenz also sie wir
sehr wahrgenommen und sehr viel gesendet
insofern ist mir dieses Argument das
hier immer wieder angeführt wird etwas
schleierhaft wir hören rein wie es hier
weitergeht denn es geht weiter mit den
Wahlen zum Parteivorstand Patrick Wahl
erläutert das Prozedere jetzt mit Fabio
dei
der nächste auf der Liste John Lukas
Dietrich danach Thomas
Geisel Reinhard
[Applaus]
Kaiser Hartmut
liebs
Dr Michael
lüdas jacel
nastit Alexander Rela
Linda Stefan
rot
steefen
Schumann manfredd
se Alexander
Ulrich Alexander
Troll
Sabine
Zimmermann danke
Sabine und ich stelle jetzt hier die
Frage gibt es weitere
Kandidaturen für den erweiterten
Parteivorstand dann bitte jetzt
melden das sehe ich
nicht es melden sich keine weiteren
Kandidaturen dann würde ich vorschlagen
dass wir die für die Beisitzer jetzt
schließen und bitte denjenigen der damit
einverstanden ist dass wir diese Liste
schließen um das
Kartenzeichen danke schön ist jemand
dagegen
Enthaltungen das sehe ich nicht dann ist
es so beschlossen auch
hier auch hier wäre der Vorschlag dass
wir ein verbunden Einzelwahl wählen das
heißt es wird wieder so sein dass ihr
einen Wahlzettel bekommt diesmal mit 14
Namen drauf ihr habt insgesamt also
könnt insgesamt bis zu 14 Stimmen
abgeben jeweils verteilt auf die
einzelnen
Kandidaten und ich bitte jetzt euch wenn
ihr damit einverstanden seid um das
Kartenzeichen so damit ist der Wahlgang
so gut wie eingeleitet bzw es wird ja
noch mal ganz kurz abgestimmt über das
Verfahren 14
Beisitzer ja und dann kann man
tatsächlich mal das maskuline
die maskuline Variante wählen denn es
sind wenn wir uns nicht komplett
verzählt haben von den 14 die hier
kandidieren tatsächlich nur zwei Frauen
dabei nämlich jlin nastic früher mal
Bundestagsabgeordnete für die Linke
jetzt natürlich fürs
BSW das übrigens in der kommenden Woche
den gruppenstatus bekommen wird im
Deutschen Bundestag ebenso wie die
Linke die noch im Bundestag ist und
Sabine Zimmermann ist die andere die war
auch mal im Bundestag für die Linke in
dieser
Legislaturperiode nicht wieder
eingezogen in den Deutschen Bundestag
also das ist das Tableau der Beisitzer
Rinnen um ganz korrekt zu sein Fabio
deasi dabei und auch Thomas Geisel die
beiden Spitzenkandidaten für die
Europawahl wir haben ein Interview Mark
Steinhäuser bitte vielen Dank Erhard
scherfer ja mit einem weiteren
Bundestagsabgeordneten dieses Bündnisses
mit cllaus Ernst auch Vorsitzender des
Bundestagsausschusses für Klimaschutz
und Energie Herr ernst mal wieder muss
man ja sagen in ihrem Leben eine
Parteigründung was ist diesmal anders
muss ich erst korrigieren sonst kriege
ich ärger ich bin nicht mehr
Vorsitzender des Ausschusses für
Klimaschutz und Energie das war ich als
ich noch bei der Linken war mit dem
Verlust der Fraktion bin ich noch nicht
mehr drin danke für die Korrektur sie
waren es bis vor kurzem sie sind im
Bundestag auf jeden Fall noch was ist
jetzt bei dieser Parteigründung hier für
Sie anders als bei den vorherigen das
erste ist wir beschäftigen uns nicht mit
Formalien sehen sie ja sondern wir gehen
zielgerichtet auf die inhal los wir
haben hervorragende reden gehört und
jetzt stellen wir gerade unsere
Kandidaten vor und auch daran sieht man
dass wenn man das Spektrum betrachtet
das natürlich ein bei weiBen breiteres
Spektrum ist als die Linke des
verkörpert hat und ist auch richtig und
gut wir haben eine breite Gesellschaft
und in allen gesellschaftlichen
Geschichten sind die Themen die
aktuellen die wir ansprechen ist das
Thema Frieden das ist das Thema weniger
Rüstung das ist das Thema soziale
Gerechtigkeit aber auch das Thema
Freiheit Freiheit
der Meinung die man äußern muss und
äußern können muss ohne dass man
dafür geächtet oder deformiert wird das
ist wo werden sie geächtet wo werden sie
deformiert sie können ja seit Jahren
ihre Meinung frei äußern ja das fel sich
noch nicht immer also wenn man z.B heute
die Auffassung vertritt dass man diesen
Krieg möglichst schnell beenden muss
auch durch Verhandlungen dann wird man
schon sehr oft als Putin Knecht dieiert
und das ist eine Verengung des
meinungsspektrums gegen die wir auch mit
der Gründung dieser Partei angehen
wollen fragen wir da doch dann mal nach
man kann ja dann doch die Nachfrage
stellen haben Sie denn den Eindruck dass
Putin verhandeln will also wenn sie die
Geschichte wissen wie sie abgelaufen ist
wissen sie dass schon kurz nach Beginn
des Krieges Verhandlungen geführt wurden
übrigens unter Leitung des damaligen
israelischen Ministerpräsidenten war von
Anfang an Verhandlungslösung möglich die
vom Westen auch behindert und verhindert
wden jetzt ist ja so dass danach auch
die Massaker in butscha öffentlich
geworden sind und diese Verhandlungen
dann auch so nicht mehr stattfinden
konnten für die ukrainische Seite also
die sind ja dann sozusagen auch
abgebrochen worden noch mal auf die
Situation jetzt haben sie den Eindruck
dass man mit Putin jetzt verhandeln kann
es gibt nun in der Ukraine ja sozusagen
das Verbot von Verhandlungen durch ein
die Krit und das ist der Grund warum
keine Verhandlungen
stattfinden mehrmals hat die russische
Seite gesagt das verhandelt werden
sollte und ist auch dringend notwendig
denn je länger dieser Krieg dauert desto
mehr Tote gibt es und je länger dies er
Krieg dauert desto mehr Leid wird über
die Bevölkerung gebracht und die
Waffenlieferungen die wir gemacht haben
haben ja nicht dazu geführt was uns
versprochen wurde dass der Krieg beendet
wird im Gegenteil er geht immer weiter
immer heftiger weiter es geht um neue
Waffensysteme die den Krieg weiter
eskalieren werden wie z.B der frühere
general Kujat der oberste Befehls der
NATO war deutlich sagt also das ist ein
Weg dien den wir nicht beschreiten
sollten ist ein ihrweg und ich hoffe
dass unsere Partei dazu beiträgt dass
wir diesen irweg verlassen sie sagen
irweg wenn man ihnen zugehört hätte und
danach gehandelt hätte im vergangenen
Jahr wä die Ukraine jetzt wahrscheinlich
auf der Landkarte nicht mehr existent
den da drauf na ja man hat ja die
Verteidigung der Ukraine gestärkt auch
mit deutschen Waffenlieferung sie lehnen
Waffenlieferung ab auch jetzt mit ihrem
neuen Bündnis ja Moment wenn wir die
Verhandlungslösungen die schon gehabt
hätten realisiert hätten dann hätte es
nach wie vor eine Ukraine gegeben
insofern ist Behauptung insofern ist die
Behauptung erstmal falsch die RA hätte
weiter wir standanden es hätte viel
weniger Tote viel weniger Verletzte viel
weniger Leid gegeben und deshalb glauben
wir schon dass dieser Weg den wir da
beschreiten richtig ist übrigens
inzwischen ja auch große Teile in den
Vereinigten Staaten durch erkennen dass
er zu einer Verhandlungslösung kommen
muss wenn man diesen Krieg beenden will
und nicht durch mehr Waffen welche Teile
der Ukraine wollen Sie Herrn Putin
schenken ich will Putin gar nichts
schenken sondern ich sage ich trete für
Verhandlungen ein in diesen
Verhandlungen müssen zwei Dinge g in für
Sicherheitsinteressen auch die der
Ukraine aber eben auch die Russlands und
stellen Sie sich mal vor wir hätten die
Situation dass Mexiko irgendwie mit den
Chinesen sich verbandelt und in Mexiko
Waffen aufstellen die sich gegen die USA
richten würden ich glaube da würde da
würde die USA nicht lange zuschauen und
genauso hat natürlich auch die haben die
Russen aufgrund ihrer Geschichte
übrigens die man leicht ignoriert das
Interesse dass ihr die Sicherheit
gewahrt wird und haben deshal auch
Interesse das war immer ein ein
Vorschlag auch von Putin dass die
Ukraine NATO frei bleibt also nicht in
den NATO kommt machen wir an der Stelle
dann ein Punkt bei ihren Thesen zum
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine sie
haben ja gerade auch gesagt sie waren
lange Ausschussvorsitzender im Bundestag
für Klimaschutz und Energie nun sagt
jetzt dieses Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht
man wolle im Klimaschutz weniger
Verbote was wollen Sie denn sozusagen
erlauben was bisher verboten ist im
Klimaschutz also geht nicht n das was
schon verboten ist sondern das was
verboten werden soll also wenn ich höre
dass meine alte Partei auch andere
politische Akteure inlandsfliege
verbieten wollen dann sage ich das ist
ein Quatsch warum ist ger nicht warum
ist ein Quatsch aber das ist ja nun
Programmatik wenn man das
will macht man einen Unfug deshalb weil
man die Bevölkerung ersten gegen sich
aufbringt und zweiten weil man es nicht
muss man muss die Bahn attraktiver
machen wenn ich heute von Berlin nach
München muss nehme ich die Bahn und
nicht mit den Flieger ob ich will oder
nicht ist einfach besser also die die
parallelangebote die müssen besser sein
dann brauche ich keine Verbote und ich
brauche auch keine Verbote was ich wie
ich heizen darf oder wie ich nicht
heizen darf sondern ich brauche
vernünftige Angebote die sich die Bürger
kaufen können und die einen Sinn machen
es macht z.B keinen Sinn dass ich
bestimmte Regeln mache wieeder Bürger
ihre Wohnung Beizen W die gleichzeitig
die Gewährleistung hab dass das auch
eingebaut werden kann dass die Technik
funktioniert dass ich es anwenden kN
dass ich genügend Arbeiter finde die das
einbauen und all dieses ist ja momentan
in der jetzigen Debatte ein riesen
Problem gewesen und beim heizungsgzz war
ich ja nun durchaus noch involviert da
kann ich Ihnen sagen dass die Regierung
die Opposition vollkommen missachtet hat
an diesem Teil und dass deshalb auch ein
abgeör der der CDU dagegen geklagt hat
und auch Recht bekommen hat von
verfassungsg und insofern glau ging ja
um das Verfahren wie das Gesetz in das
Parlament eingebracht wird nicht so sehr
um die Inhalte ja doch es ging natürlich
auch um die Inhalte weil selbst der FDP
die Inhalte die die Ampel eingebracht
hat irgendwie dann nicht mehr ganz Koser
waren und sie selbst innerhalb der Ampel
die Probleme hatten das Gesetz
vernünftig hinzukriegen und momentan ist
es überflüssig wie ein Kropf um es mal
deutlich zu sagen ist jetzt sehr
abgeändert worden weil wir gerade bei
der Ampel sind wir hören auch heute hier
massive Kritik an der Ampel am
Establishment an den Regierenden
auch mit einer Rhetorik die hier und da
auch an Rechtspopulisten erinnert ähm
ist das sozusagen der Ansatz von diesem
Bündnis ist das der Ansatz ähm auch
gegen die Regierung so massiv auch
verbal auszuteilen weil eigentlich haben
sie sich ja die Vernunft in den
Parteinamen geschrieben ist das
vernünftig Schü sich ja nicht aus also
ich schließ nicht aus dass man deutliche
Worte gegen die Regierung findet wenn
sie angebracht sind und die
Zustimmungswerte bei der Bevölkerung die
diese Regierung noch hat sind die
schlechtesten an die ich mich überhaupt
je erinnern kann also das bedeutet schon
äh dass dann dann den Bürgern ein
Angebot machen muss wo ihre Interessen
wieder zur Geltung gebracht werden ich
nehme das Beispiel Sozialpolitik jetzt
Geld für die Rüstung auszugeben und
gleichzeitig bei den Bürgern zu kürzen
z.B im Rentensystem z.B auch bei
notwendigen Investitionen um die
Transformation der Wirtschaft
hinzukriegen all das ist ein Weg gegen
die Bürger und das muss man auch
deutlich benennen momentan gibt's leider
nur eine Partei die da ab und zu mal
auch was richtiges sagt das ist die AFD
deswegen hat sie auch ein Zulauf wir
wollen ein chen K loben die AFD ne das
Lob ich nicht sie hätten genau zuhören
müssen D würden Sie feststellen ich habe
gesagt die macht ein Angebot das zum
Teil dass die Bürger dann annehmen
deshalb kriegt i auch mehr stimmen wir
wollen ein Angebot machen das
tatsächlich Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit
beinhaltet und das bedeutet dass wir
natürlich auch der AFD Wähler abnehmen
würden dann schauen wir mal was das
Angebot sich heute hier noch wie das
sich noch verhält und präsentiert besten
Dank für das Interview bei phöniix Klaus
Ernst nch dan ja und mit diesen
inhaltlichen Eindrücken und ja auch
diesen programmatischen
Ideen wollen wir jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen reinhören in die anderen
Stimmen die hier sich versammelt haben
es gibt ja 450 Mitglieder und wir haben
uns auch bei uns bei phöniix gefragt wer
ist das eigentlich wer sind diese
Menschen die sich jetzt hinter Sarah
Wagenknecht versammeln und meine
Kollegin Julia Grimm hat heute so ein
bisschen den Auftrag sich auf
Spurensuche zu machen hier in diesem
Saal Julia ganz genau das mache ich und
habe jetzt mal hier räumlich sage ich
mal die Seiten gewechselt bin auf der
Seite wo hier in diesem Fall
SachsenAnhalt ist alles was ich weiß
kein Landesverband den gibt es
wahrscheinlich ja noch nicht bin mir
jetzt gerade nicht sicher das sagen mir
die Kollegen jetzt hier gerade gleich
bestimmt ich frage einfach mal hier
junge Menschen wenn man sich hier
umguckt durch also sie senken den
Altersdurchschnitt auf jeden Fall was
treibt sie zum Bündnis Sara
Wagen ja wir haben uns ja schon auch
persönlich privat längere Zeit
beschäftig und haben da uns auch
letztendlich mit den inhaltlichen
Punkten auch sehr wiedergefunden und ich
finde auch dass wir besonders halt auch
als denke ich mal das spreche ich auch
für uns beide auch als junge Menschen da
auch optimistisch in Richtung unserer
parteizukunft auch blicken können darf
ich fragen wie alt Sie sind ich bin 19
Jahre alt und ich bin 18 und sie kommen
aus Sachsen anhall genau aus Sachsen
sind sie schon Parteimitglieder jetzt
geworden oder wollen sie
werden Mitglieder deswegen sind wir ja
auf dem Parteitag es gibt hier auch ein
paar die noch nicht Mitglieder sind und
das dann jetzt hier werden aber genau um
das einmal gecheckt zu haben was mich
interessiert was wünschen Sie sich von
dem Bündnis SAR Wagenknecht was sind
ihre Hoffnungen
ganz also ich bin seit 2016 gut mit John
Lukas Dietrich befreundet der sich ja
gerade vorgestellt hat für die
europawahlliste genau muss man dazu
sagen einmal genau das nicht richtig für
die Beisitzer hier genau Parteivorstand
genau und habe mich deswegen auch oder
wir in der Gruppe haben uns häufiger
über politische Themen unterhalten und
ich persönlich komme aus einer aus einem
deutlich anderen Hintergrund als John
also ich komme aus einem akademischen
Haushalt und habe zusammen mit ihm jetzt
auch mein Abitur im letzten Sommer
gemacht und mir ist erst jetzt danach so
klar geworden im Austausch mit anderen
Leuten in meinem Alter
wie dankbar ich eigentlich sein kann für
dieses Privileg dass ich da hatte und
das hat bei mir den Wunsch ausgelöst das
auch irgendwie zurückzugeben und dafür
zu sorgen oder mich dafür einzusetzen
dass mehr Leute die Möglichkeit haben zu
diesem
Bildungsweg und das verbinden sie mit
dem bündnisara Wagenknecht also sowas
wie eine Bildungsgerechtigkeit mehr Geld
für Bildung wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe waren sie vorher schon
politisch aktiv persönlich tatsächlich
noch nicht also wie das ja gerade
erwähnt wurde wir waren ja auch gut und
aktiv im Kontakt mit John lasrich und
haben uns da auch immer gerne
ausgetauscht und da finde ich das auch
als letztendlich auch wichtige
Angelegenheit hier auch hier dabei sein
zu SachsenAnhalt die ostdeutschen Länder
stehen ja auch immer für ein sehr großes
Erstarken der AFD auch des
Rechtsextremismus mit wem könnten sie
sich denn vorstellen könnte ein
bündnisagerwagenknecht eine Regierung
führen animiert
hab für so eine Aussage reicht unsere
Expertise noch nicht aus also wie gesagt
wir wir sind beide noch politisch bisher
nicht sehr
erfahren das können wir jetzt glaube ich
nicht beantworten ja aber ganz vielen
Dank für Ihre Eindrücke danke schön ich
stehe mal auf und rutsche ein bisschen
weiter das ist bildlich jetzt vielleicht
nicht ganz so schick was wir machen aber
das verzeihen Sie uns und frage mal hier
weiter jetzt bin ich in rheinlandfalz
gelandet ein gefragt ob ich mit der
Kamera kommen darf gehört sie sind der
der am besten reden kann was treibt sie
zum Bündnis SAR Wagenknecht was haben
sie für Hoffnungen Wünsche mit dieser
neuen Partei na ja ich bin
Kommunalpolitiker in der Pfalz und ich
stelle immer mehr fest dass die Menschen
da auch an Hoffnung verlieren und sie an
die Dinge die ihnen von oben aus der
aktuellen ampelregierung erzählt werden
einfach nicht mehr glauben und sie
brauchen Hal etwas an das sie glauben
können man glaubt genau wenn
sieenenen wenn Sie s Stig überalla ist
die Frau die Hoffnung gesetzt wir und
die Leute die mit ihr zusammen streiten
sind die Leute die am Ende des Tages den
Menschen ein besseren Weg bringen werden
könen Sie das mir erklären was ist das
für Hoffnung die die Menschen mit SAR
wagenkne Verben Wagenknecht ist
grundsätzlich ehrlich wenn man sich die
aktuelle Politik anguckt wir haben ein
Bundeskanzler der die Hälfte von denen
was mal gemacht hat nicht mehr weiß wir
haben kriegspolitiker die lieber Geld in
Waffen and Länder investieren als die
Schulen zu
renierenele angegangen werden müssen und
die Menschen glauben das was SAR sagt
weil sie schon immer für eine ehrliche
Politik
stehen sie sagen sie sind
Kommunalpolitiker darf ich Fragen waren
sie vorher in einer Partei auch in
anderen Partei ich war vorher Mitglied
der PDL
ja und was wünschen Sie sich konkret an
politischen Inhalten die jetzt hier
diese neue Partei bringen muss das Thema
Frieden muss wieder auf die Agenda wir
müssen zurück Z Diplomatie aber
natürlich auch das Geld was wir
erwirtschaften was die Leute die alle
hier auch erwitschaften in die richtigen
Wege geleitet wird also in die Kommunen
zurück und dafür gesorgt wir dass die
Menschen wieder vernünftig ordentlich
bezahlt wden entlich zu Hause leben
können ich danke jetzt erstmal an dieser
Stelle ich würde gerne mal eine das sage
ich jetzt auch an meine Kollegen eine
Frau interviewen aber das ist in dieser
Reihe nicht so ganz einfach ich
verspreche ih Liebe Zuschauerin und
Zuschauer das nächste was wir machen ist
wir suchen uns mal eine Frau die hier
Mitglied wird und hören D da mal
bisscheninurü
cht uns nicht nicht einf ist mit den
Frauen da unten in den rein denn wir
sind hier gerade in der
Vorstellungsrunde der Kandidatinnen und
Kandidaten für den erweiterten
Parteivorstand also die sogenannten
Beisitzer und Beisitzerinnen und auch
bei diesen 14
Kandidierenden sind tatsächlich auch nur
zwei Frauen dabei die stellen sich hier
gerade vor seit geraumer Zeit schon eben
hat unter anderem gesprochen Michael
Lüders der
Publizist der sich auch viel mit dem
themenkplex nah Osten beschäftigt hat da
zul nicht GZ unumstritten gewesen ist
auch er hat sich dem BSW angeschlossen
und kandidiert jetzt für den erweiterten
Parteivorstand und im Moment ist am Pult
Alexander Rela Linder hören wir rein in
seine Schlüsselindustrien investiert um
vor allem e Beschäftigung und Wohlstand
in diesem Land zu
erhalten und deshalb liebe Kolleginen
Kollegen braucht es meiner Meinung nach
wieder mehr made in Germany es braucht
eine Regierung die erkennt dass sie eben
selbst mit einer klugen Wirtschaft einer
klugen Energiepolitik die weichen die
Weichenstellung stellt und Grundstein
dafür legt um die Transformation hin zu
einer ressourceneffizienten Industrie
hinzubekommen meine Expertise auf diesem
Gebiet möchte ich gerne einbringen und
bitte euch um euer Vertrauen vielen
Dank lieber Alexander vielen Dank ich
bitte jetzt auf die Bühne um sich
vorzustellen Stefan rot Stefan
bitttechön hallo danke Patrick ich weiß
nicht wie es euch geht ich hatte heute
schon ein paar Mal Gänsehaut und Liebe
Parteifreunde es ist bewegend und toll
mit euch hier heute auf diesem Parteitag
zu sein und auf diesen Parteitag zu
blicken denn natürlich schreiben wir
Geschichte und ich möchte dazu beitragen
dass die Geschichte der Partei eine
Erfolgsgeschichte wird auch ich
möchte auch ich möchte mich kurz fassen
die Zeit ist knapp mein Name ist Stefan
rot ich bin 36 Jahre alt ich habe 10
Jahre Erfahrung in der Brandenburger
kommunal und Landespolitik 10 Jahre
Erfahrung in der Bundespolitik unter
anderem in den letzten Jahren auch als
Mitarbeiterin pardon als Mitarbeiter im
Team von Sara
Wagenknecht wenn ihr SAR wagenknechts
Wochenschau regelmäßig guckt dann kennt
ihr ein Stück weit auch meine ar auch
wenn ihr mich noch nicht persönlich
kennt und ich bin außerdem
Landesbeauftragter für den
Strukturaufbau in Brandenburg und ich
finde es wichtig dass diese Perspektive
in den Bundesvorstand einfließt ich
möchte dass diese Partei ein Erfolg wird
denn sie wird dringend gebraucht sehr
dringend gebraucht der Frust im Land ist
groß das spürt man insbesondere im Osten
und ich möchte unser Land nicht in
harbex und bbox und strck Zimmermanns
überlassen weil
sie
weil sie unsere Wirtschaft gegen die
Wand fahren weil sie unser Land gegen
die Wand fahren und weil ihn oft die
Interessen der Waffenlobby näher sind
als die Interessen der einfachen Leute
und deshalb lass uns ein klares Zeichen
von diesem Parteitag setzen mit uns ist
zu rechnen sowohl bei der Europawahl
natürlich auch bei der Bundestagswahl
und auch bei den Wahlen im Osten auf
geht's
Stefan rot war das für das BSW ist er
Landesbeauftragter für Brandenburg sie
wissen sicherlich dass ich eine ganze
Reihe von Landesverbänden noch Gründen
muss und hier in Arbeit sind und jetzt
kommt Steffen Schumann auch ein
ehemaliger linker und es kann sich schon
mal bereit machen manfri se ja liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde ich bin Steffen
Schumann 26 Jahre alt und und lebe in
Oldenburg in Niedersachsen ich
kandidiere für den Parteivorstand weil
ich mich weiter in die
Organisationsarbeit und Aufbauarbeit
sowie die Strukturplanung der Partei
einsetzen möchte unser gemeinsames Ziel
ist ja wir wollen unsere Inhalte unser
Spitzenpersonal unsere Mitglieder nach
außen gut für die Bürger sichtbar machen
und bei Wahlen so gut wie möglich
abschneiden dafür gibt's aber eine
Voraussetzung diese Voraussetzung ist
dass wir im Hintergrund also im
sogenannten Maschinenraum der Partei
dass da alle Räder ineinander greifen
und dafür möchte ich mich einsetzen ich
bringe als fast vijähriger Referent im
Deutschen Bundestag ich war
forstchandsreferent dort genau
Kompetenzen in diesen Bereichen mit die
Organisation nach innen die politische
Kommunikation nach außen ich glaube
genau das ist das was wir brauchen aus
meinem Studium bringe ich auch ein
bisschen was mit ich habe
Organisationssoziologie als teilstudium
gehabt kurz formuliert was macht
Organisation erfolgreich und was nicht
bisher machen wir sehr viel richtig bin
sehr stolz und ich will das wir weiter
viel richtig machen und da möchte ich
meine Kompetenzen einbringen vielen
Dank
lieber Steffen vielen Dank ich bitte
jetzt manfrid se auf die Bühne um sich
vorzustellen und bereit machen kann sich
schon mal Alexander
Ulrich ja liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde mein Name
Manfred se bin verheiratet eine Tochter
komme aus dem bayerischen Schwaben aus
Landkreis Donau
Ries bin selbständiger
energieunternehmer mit C Mitarbeiterinen
und Mitarbeiter und habe tagtäglich mit
überzogener Staatsbürokratie aber auch
mit einem Kampf gegen die Ölkonzerne zu
tun ich trat wegen Gerhard Schröders
Agenda 2010 aus der SPD als amtierender
kreisvorsitzer aus und ging in die
WASG klaus war hier der
Initiator und war seit 2005 bis Dezember
letzten Jahres kreisvorsitzend der
linken und habe am 8.1 meinen Austritt
erklärt und meinen Eintritt in unsere
Partei politisch ist eigentlich schon
viel um nicht zu sagen alles gesagt es
muss sich meiner Meinung nach vieles
drastisch ändern ich persönlich will
mich einsetzen für eine Politik für den
Artenschutz um die Klimakrise zu
überwinden ich möchte mich einsetzen für
eine andere Steuerpolitik und
Wirtschaftspolitik vor allem die
Stärkung des Mittelstandes ich weiß von
was ich rede der Mittelstand stellt
nicht die Industrie stellt die
Arbeitsplätze der Mittelstand stellt
mehr als zwei Drittel der
Arbeitsplätze eine Wirtschaftspolitik
die so gut sein soll dass man gute Löhne
bezahlen kann um wieder die soziale
Gerechtigkeit in unserem Lande
herzustellen
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde ein ganz
wichtiges Thema auch schon angesprochen
vor allem eine wirkliche Friedenspolitik
ala Willi Brand denn jeder Krieg ist
falsch wir wollen Friedensverhandlungen
statt Waffenlieferung und dafür möchte
ich arbeiten dafür möchte ich meine
Erfahrung einbringen würd mich freuen
herzlichen
Dank lieber man vielen Dank ich bitte
jetzt auf die Bühne zur
vorstellunger bit das Wort und bereit
machen kann sich schon mal Alexander
Troll ja liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen mein Name
ist Alexander Ulrich bin 53 Jahre alt
verheiratet zwei Kinder zwei
engkelkinder komme aus dem wunderschönen
rheinandpfalz in der Nähe von Kaisers
Lautern FCK hat gest Abend gewonnen
gegen schalge und
äh bin Zeit meines Lebens eigentlich als
Gewerkschafter unterwegs auch im
politischen Leben ich bin B vollmächtig
D noch der IG Metall in Kaisers Lautern
bin seit 2005 Mitglied im Deutschen
Bundestag und ich möchte dass von diesem
Parteitag und auch von dem was wir in
Zukunft machen ein klares Signal ausgeht
das BSW ist die Partei der guten Arbeit
der guten Löhne der guten Renten für
Umverteilung für starke Gewerkschaften
für mehr Mitbestimmung wir sind die
Partei für die Arbeitnehmer in diesem
Land der zweite Punkt der zweite Punkt
der wichtig ist nah zuu alle Parteien
hier in Berlin machen Politik aus demck
Berlin Mitte nichts gegen die Menschen
aus Berlin Mitte aber ich komme aus
einem kleinen Ort mit 1400 Einwohner da
ist heizungsgesetz ÖPNV ärztliche
Versorgung schwimmbäer eine andere
Situation wie hier in Berlin wir müssen
endlich wieder Politik machen für die
Menschen auch auf dem flachen Land und
nicht nur in den großen
Städten
und und der dritte Punkt ich bin auch
Aufbauhelfer für reinand Falz viele
haben sich an uns gewandt auch wegen den
Erfahrungen der coronazeit ich möchte
dass wir ein Expertenrat einsetzen im
neuen Vorstand um die coronazeit
aufzuarbeiten Millionen Menschen leiden
unter dieser Zeit Millionen Menschen
sind damals an den Rand getedrängt
worden Millionen Menschen sind
ausgegrenzt worden wir dürfen dann nicht
zur Tagesordnung zurückkehren denn ich
glaube die nächste Pandemie kann kommen
und da brauchen wir andere Antworten als
die ambel uns jeden Tag gibt vielen
Dank alexander ulr war das
einer der zehn ich s sie jetzt mal
Überläufer aus der ehemaligen
Linksfraktion im Deutschen Bundestag
jetzt BSW und jetzt müsste Alexander
Troll kommen mein Name ist Alexander
Troll ich bin Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
und arbeite seit über 12 Jahren als
persönlicher Referent für Sara ich bin
froh heute mit euch hier zu sein es ist
großartig dass wir die Partei gegründet
haben und heute unseren Parteitag
begehnen können aber es ist auch eine
große Verantwortung und Verpflichtung
den vielen Menschen gegenüber die große
Hoffnungen in uns setzen die genug haben
von der jahrzehntelang Ignoranz der
Regierung gegenüber ihren Sorgen Nöten
und Problemen die zurecht nicht mehr
glauben dass eine Regierung aus Ampel
oder Unionsparteien ihre
Lebensverhältnisse verbessern wird viele
von ihnen warten schon lange auf ein
vernünftiges und glaubwürdiges
Politikangebot und das ist jetzt da wir
haben die klaffende klaffende Lücke im
Parteiensystem geschlossen eine zentrale
Grundlage für das weitere gelingen wird
der erfolgreiche Aufbau der Partei sein
und zwar aus dem Nichts wären parallel
schon Wahlkämpfe bestritten und für
alles auch noch erfolgreich Geld
eingesammelt werden muss für das
Gelingen dieser Herkules Aufgabe habe
ich bereits viel Zeit und Kraft
investiert jetzt möchte ich dies aus dem
Parteivorstand weiter
unterstützen und vorantreiben dafür
bitte ich euch um euer Vertrauen vielen
Dank Alexander Troll der 13 Kandidat
für den Kreis der Beisitzerinnen und
Beisitzer und jetzt müsste Sabine
Zimmermann eigentlich schon vorne sein
bahnt sich jetzt ihren Weg in auf das
auf die kleine Bühne hier im Kosmos
Center das zieht sich noch ein wenig war
im Deutschen Bundestag in der letzten
Legislaturperiode noch dies für die
Linken natürlich da ist sie ausgetreten
jetzt auch BS Mitkämpferinnen und Liebe
Mitkämpfer ich bin Sabine Zimmermann bin
30 Jahre beim Deutschen
Gewerkschaftsbund gewesen und ihr könnt
euch vorstellen ich kenne ich weiß wie
die Menschen in Deutschland leben und
deshalb will ich meine Redezeit hier
nutzen nicht für eine Vorstellung die
ihr alle in dem kandidatenheft habt
sondern ich möchte um Solidarität bitten
für die Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei
Knor bei dem knorrwerk in Auerbach im
Vogtland denn der
Konzern der Konzern unileva es gehört zu
den drittgrößten Konzernen
Lebensmittelkonzernen auf der Welt will
die Belegschaft dort halbieren und den
Standort zurücknehmen zurück erbauen und
das nehmen wir nicht hin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde
auf einer Mitarbeiterversammlung haben
Sie das letzte Woche erfahren für die
Familien ist das ein Schock gewesen und
deshalb werden wir gemeinsam mit den
Beschäftigten kämpfen für den Erhalt
dieser Arbeitsplätze und deshalb bitte
ich um euch um
Solidarität bis Ende diesen Jahres soll
die Hälfte der Belegschaft gekündigt
werden und es sollen drei
Produktionslinien abgebaut werden die
Beschäftigten haben seit Jahrzehnten den
Rücken krumm gemacht für das Unternehmen
haben zu coronazeiten Höchstbelastung
unter Höchstbelastung gearbeitet und
jetzt will das Unternehmen aus
renditegründen scheibchenweise die
Belegschaft ausstellen vor die Tür und
das liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
werden es nicht akzeptieren dass wir
diese Schließung auf Raten hinnehmen
müssen und deshalb kämpfen wir vor Ort
für den Erhalt der
Arbeitsplätze
und ganz zum Schluss möchte ich
sagen ich werde nächste Woche auf der
Betriebsversammlung dort sprechen und
ich möchte die Grüße von diesem
Parteitag von unserem ersten Parteitag
dort übermitteln und deshalb bitte ich
euch
um die
Solidarität in diesem Sinne kämpfen wir
für eine bessere Politik und ich wünsche
euch allen ein herzliches Glück
auf vielen
dank vielen Dank
Sabine
jetzt
m bevor wir gleich zu einer
Unterbrechung kommen für die Rede von
Sara würden wir vorher noch die
Fragerunde
machen ich frage jetzt gibt es Fragen zu
den Kandidatinnen und
Kandidaten das sehe ich nicht dann nur
von mir die prozedurale Frage ist jemand
von euch ist jemand unter euch der für
den Fall dass er nicht in seinem
Wahlgang gewählt ist gerne in einem
anderen Wahlgang noch mal antreten
möchte oder ist es so dass ihr alle
verzichten wollt also ich sehe jetzt nur
dass die die genau also dass ihr nicht
noch mal also ich interpretiere euer
Kopfschüttel so dass ihr nicht noch mal
antreten wollt okay alles klar dann
würden wir jetzt in eine kurze
Unterbrechung gehen und dann mit dem
Wahlgang beginnen und ich übergebe jetzt
an das tagungspräsidium an Jessica
tatti ja jetzt ist es soweit jetzt kommt
der Moment auf den hier glaube ich alle
im Saal gewartet
haben liebe Sarah es ist maßgeblich
deine Mut deiner Entschlossenheit und
deiner Standhaftigkeit zu verdanken dass
wir heute alle gemeinsam hier sind wir
freuen uns alle sehr auf deine Rede komm
bitte ans
Rednerpult
danke ja
liebe liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde etwas Neues zu beginnen das
Gesicht ganz vorne in den Wind zu halten
das erfordert Mut und ich denke wir
kennen sie alle die Zweifel vor dem
richtigen Weg die Frage wir werden
Freunde Bekannte auf diesen Schritt
reagieren und auch die Sorge ob wir die
riesige Aufgabe die jetzt vor uns steht
ob wir die wirklich bewältigen oder ob
sie uns vielleicht auch
überfordert ihr habt die Entscheidung
getroffen deshalb seid ihr heute hier
als erstmitglieder des Bündnisses Sarah
Wagenknecht dass es ohne euch nicht
geben würde und darüber freue ich mich
und ich danke euch dass ihr den Mut da
aufgebracht
hab wir machen uns
jetzt wir machen uns jetzt gemeinsam auf
den Weg die Politik in Deutschland zu
verändern und wir tun das weil wir
spüren da ist etwas am kippen in unserer
Gesellschaft es gibt so viele Probleme
so viel Unsicherheit aber auch so viel
ung und Wut die Politik des Aussitzens
und wegmoderierens der kleinen
Kompromisse und der großen Ignoranz die
wird wahrscheinlich so nicht weitergehen
aber die Frage ist was kommt dann mündet
der Umbruch in einen Aufbruch oder in
die Katastrophe alles ist möglich und
wir starten auch jetzt deshalb weil wir
nicht nur zuschauen sondern weil wir
eingreifen und handeln wollen weil ab
jetzt hängt es auchon von uns ab wie
Deutschland in 5 oder 10 Jahren aussehen
wird und ich denke das ist ganz wichtig
und es ist toll dass ihr dabei
seid
liebe liebe Freundinnen und Freunde uns
ein die gemeinsame Sorge um die Zukunft
uns einen die programmatischen Ziele die
in unserem Programm formuliert sind aber
wir sind auch sehr verschied
viele von uns haben sich über viele
Jahre in der Linken engagiert andere
kommen aus anderen Parteien und wieder
andere haben sich zum ersten Mal in
ihrem Leben entschieden politisch aktiv
zu werden unter uns sind Gewerkschafter
Betriebsräte und erfolgreiche
Unternehmer Krankenpfleger und
Polizisten Theologen und Atheisten
Großstädter und Dorfbewohner in einem
Land das sich immer mehr in Lager tet
indem die einzelnen milies sich immer
seltener begegnen ist das keine
Selbstverständlichkeit sondern etwas
ganz besonderes und wertvolles und wir
werden auch nur erfolgreich sein wenn
wir diese unsere Unterschiedlichkeit als
Gewinn begreifen wenn wir Toleranz und
Respekt nicht nur in der Gesellschaft
einfordern sondern auch hier in unserer
Partei Leben das muss un Menschen auf
uns setzen die täglich erleben wenn uns
Menschen ansprechen auf der Straße im
Supermarkt lasst uns diese Hoffnungen
diese Erwartungen nicht enttäuschen das
ist unsere große Verantwortung die wir
alle gemeinsam jetzt tragen müssen und
unser Land es braucht unbedingt einen
politischen Neubeginn für
wirtschaftliche Vernunft statt
Klientelpolitik für soziale
Gerechtigkeit statt einer immer
wachsenden Ungerechtigkeit und
Ungleichheit für Frieden für für
Entspannung statt neuer
hochrüungswettläuferüungswettläufe und
immer mehr Krieg und ja auch für
Meinungsfreiheit und Respekt gegenüber
dem Andersdenkenden statt kcel culture
und einem übergriffigen politischen
Autoritarismus den wir in der coronazeit
in seiner krassesten Form erlebt haben
aber der ja heute auch nicht weg ist
sondern der das Meinungsspektrum immer
weiter verengt und das machen wir nicht
mit das wollen wir verändern und es ist
wichtig dass das
ändert immer mehr Menschen immer mehr
Menschen in unserem Land sind politisch
heimatlos geworden weil sie statt
vernünftiger Entscheidungen eine Politik
erleben die keinen Plan und keine
Antworten hat eine Politik die sich nur
noch in ihrer Blase bewegt und die
Probleme die die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
in unserem Land jeden Tag erleben die
diese Probleme nicht nur nicht löst
sondern offenkundig zum Teil noch nicht
einmal kennt Amira hat ja das Beispiel
vorhin genannt der V von Ricarda lang
immerhin Vorsitzender einer
Regierungspartei bei der Abschätzung der
deutschen durchschnittsrenten das ist
doch das Sinnbild dieser Abgehobenheit
wie soll jemand eine vernünftige
Rentenpolitik machen der noch nicht
einmal weiß welche Probleme die
Millionen Rentnerinnen und Rentner in
unserem Land überhaupt haben das ist
doch
absurd und vermutlich vermutlich denkt
Robert habck auch alle Menschen in
Deutschland leben in modernen
Niedrigenergiehäusern oder in den
schönen topsanierten altbulofts wie
seine grünen Freunde in den
hochpreisigen großstadtquartieren und
deshalb hielt das für eine geniale Idee
ganz Deutschland eine Wärmepumpe für den
Heizungskeller zu verordnen so läuft
Politik heute aber genau deswegen wenden
sich eben immer mehr Menschen ab oder
der frühere Blackrock Lobbyist Friedrich
merärz der im Privatflieger durch die
Welt düst und ernsthaft glaubt so lebt
die deutsche Mittelschicht was ist daran
noch irgendwie bürgernah oder geerdet
das ist doch völlig absurd was diese
Leute
machen
und und vom höfeesterben hat die ganze
ampelriegel Riege offenbar auch noch nie
irgendwas gehört davon dass allein in
den letzten 10 Jahren 40.000
Landwirtschaftsbetriebe in Deutschland
aufgeben mussten weil sie dem
droppeldruck nicht mehr standhalten
konnten der auf der einen Seite von
mächtigen Supermarktketten und großen
Lebensmittelkonzern ausgeübt wird und
auf der anderen Seite von billig
Importen die die Politik organisiert hat
und mit immer neuen Freihandelsabkommen
wie mit dem merkosur immer weiter
organisiert offenbar haben die das
überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm was die
Landwirte in Deutschland für Probleme
haben und deswegen frage ich mich in
welchem Paralleluniversum müssen
Politiker leben die ausgerechnet dieser
Branche jetzt die Stopfen ihrer
Haushaltslöcher auferlegt das ist eine
völlig f
und wir sagen ganz klar nein diese
Belastungen die müssen komplett
zurückgenommen werden die Belastungen
für die Landwirte die müssen komplett
zurückgenommen werden weil so kann es
auf keinen Fall weitergehen und wenn
dann den
Bauern wenn dann den Bauern die
Hutschnur platzt und sie ihren Protest
unüberhörbar auf die Straße tragen ja
dann heißt es plötzlich
uhui das ist ja von rechts über
unterwandert weil man irgendwo neben ein
einem Traktor oder hinter einem
Misthaufen doch im Ernst einen
rechtsradikalen gesichtet hat es ist
tatsächlich das gleiche wie letztes Jahr
Amira hat es schon gesagt als 50.000
Menschen vor dem Brandenburger Tor für
Frieden in der Ukraine demonstriert
haben und von Medien und Politik als
Putin nah aber eben auch als rechtsoffen
und AFD nah defamiert wurden so darf es
doch nicht weitergehen mit den Debatten
in unserem
Land
weil ein Ergebnis ein Ergebnis dieser
irren Debatte ist ja tatsächlich dass
die AFD heute als Friedenspartei gilt
eine Partei die den aktuellen
rekordrüstungsetat von 85 Milliarden
Euro eher noch zu klein findet und deren
verteidigungspolitischer Sprecher das
wissen leider die wenigsten mit der
Rüstungsindustrie wirtschaftlich
verbandelt ist und deswegen um keinen
Deut besser ist als die
rüstungslobbyistin Marie Agnes Strack
reheinmetall das ist doch alles eine
Suppe das ist doch alles völlig
falsch aber das sind die
Diskussionen das sind die verrückten
Diskussionen die wir in unserem Land
teilweise führen das Werben für Frieden
rechts die Verteidigung der Bauernhöfe
rechts die Kritik an Schulschließungen
und Konformitätsdruck in der coronazeit
rechts die Forderung nach Begrenzung der
Zuwanderung und die Sorge vor
islamistischen Parallelgesellschaften
rechts und nachdem man den Leuten
jahrelang eingehämmert hat dass alles
vernünftige Recht sei ja dann wundert
man sich wenn am Ende eine tatsächlich
rechte Partei eine Partei die
Rechtsextremisten und Nazis in ihren
Reihen hat wenn die am Ende aus so einer
Debatte als Sieger hervorgeht jetzt bei
über 20% steht und im Osten auf die
absolute Mehrheit hofft ja das ist doch
nicht erstaunlich aber es ist nicht das
Ergebnis einer besonders genialen
Politik in der AFD zentrale sondern es
ist das Ergebnis der falschen Politik im
Berliner Regierungsbezirk das muss man
no immer wieder ganz deutlich
sagen und Frederik Frederik hat es
vorhin schon angesprochen jetzt gehen
also die ampelpolitiker selbst auf die
Straße und demonstrieren heldenhaft
gegen die Ergebnisse ihrer eigenen
Politik was ist das für eine Heuchelei
und
Scheinheiligkeit und man muss man muss
ganz klar sagen wenn Sie die AFD
wirklich Schwächen wollen ja bittte
schön da müssen sie nicht demonstrieren
da müssen sie endlich mal ihre miserable
Politik verändern sie haben es doch in
der Hand dann machen sie es doch endlich
mal so kann es doch nicht weitergehen
wie es jetzt
läuft
und
ja ja natürlich ja natürlich beteiligen
sich auch viele viele Menschen an den
Demonstrationen weil sie ehrlich Angst
haben vor dem erstärken der AFD und sie
haben auch recht damit diese Angst habe
ich auch und ich glaube wir alle hier
die wir hier im Saal sitzen aber man
muss natürlich auch sagen wer die AFD
wirklich Schwächen will der sollte auch
für politische Forderungen demonstrieren
er sollte auch z.B für einen höheren
Mindestlohn von wenigstens 14 €
demonstrieren weil der überfällig ist in
unserem Land er sollte für bessere
Renten demonstrieren für ein
Rentensystem wie in Österreich wo die
Durchschnittsrente ja tatsächlich bei
2000 € liegt Liebe rarder lang das
könnten wir hier haben da müssen Sie
sich nur mal in Österreich das abgucken
was man dafür machen
muss
und wer die AFD Schwächen will ja er
sollte auch für bezahlbare Energie
demonstrieren und gegen
Wirtschaftssanktionen die nicht Russland
sondern die deutsche Wirtschaft
ruinieren er sollte demonstrieren für
ein mietendeckel und für Krankenhäuser
ohne Renditedruck er sollte
demonstrieren für Frieden für ein Ende
der Hochrüstung und am besten gleich für
Neuwahlen und ein Ende der unsäglichen
Ampel das alles fordert das BSW dafür
sind wir angetreten und dafür bräuchten
wir eigentlich
Massendemonstrationen denn wir dürfen
natürlich auch nicht vergessen auch wenn
die Ampel sich ihren Titel als dümmste
Regierung Europas jeden Tag aufs Neue
verdient weil sie unser Land in die
Krise und schlimmstenfalls sogar in
einen Krieg führt es geht um mehr als um
die Ablösung einer unfähigen Regierung
ein Friedrich märz im Kanzleramt der die
Rente noch weiter kürzen und
taurusraketen an die Ukraine liefern
will damit selenski demnächst mit
deutschen Waffen sogar Moskau angreifen
kann ein solcher Friedrich märz im
Kanzleramt wäre ganz sicher nicht das
kleinere
Übel und
viele und viele Fehlentwicklungen denn
folgen wir heute spüren die haben ja
auch lange begonnen bevor das Trio
infernal aus Habig berburg und Lindner
unter einem sprachlosen Kanzler mit
lediertem Erinnerungsvermögen die
Geschäfte in Deutschland übernommen hat
das geht doch viel viel weiter zurück ja
es läuft nicht gut in unserem Land das
spüren die Menschen und Veränderung
beginnt auch damit dass die wichtigen
Fragen endlich einmal wieder ins Zentrum
der Aufmerksamkeit Rücken auch dafür
haben wir uns gegründet denn die Politik
und auch das debattenklima in unserem
Land sind roh geworden voller Verachtung
gegen über denen die ganz unten stehen
und da sind sich wieder alle von der
Ampel bis zur AFD erschreckend
einig natürlich verstehe ich dass
diejenigen die jeden Morgen aufstehen
und hart arbeiten oder auch diejenigen
die für ihren Handwerksbetrieb ihr
Kaffee oder Ihre Bäckerei Händeringen
Personal suchen und keines finden dass
sie empört sind wenn andere sich im
Modell Bürgergeld plus Schwarzarbeit
eingerichtet haben das ist ein Problem
aber ein Problem haben wir auch wenn in
einem Land in dem die einzige noch
richtig schnell wachsende Branche die
Tafeln sind die mittlerweile über z
Millionen Bedürftige versorgen wenn in
einem solchen Land nur noch über
Sozialmissbrauch und nicht mehr über
Armut geredet wird das ist doch ein
wirklich gravierendes
Problem
wenn wenn nicht mehr geredet wird über
den 61jährigen gerü Bauer der sich seine
Knochen kaputt gearbeitet hat und
einfach in seinem Job nicht mehr
arbeiten kann und dann gnadenlos nach
zwe Jahren Arbeitslosigkeit in die Armut
stürzt wenn nicht mehr geredet wird über
die alleinerziehende Mutter die schon
deshalb kein Jobangebot annehmen kann
weil die Politik bis heute es nicht
geschafft hat flächendecken für
ganztagskiterplätze zu sorgen und wir
alle kennen ja die Debatte wir alle
kennen die Debatte über die angeblich
mangelnde Bereitschaft jüngerer sich
anzustrengen und die Debatte über mehr
Druck der da nötig wäre aber vielleicht
sollten wir auch mal über Motivation
reden die Bundesrepublik ist eins mit
dem slogen Wohlstand für alle gestartet
jeder der sich anstrengt sollte
Aufstiegschancen und die Aussicht auf
ein gutes Leben haben diese
Aufstiegschancen die gibt es doch fast
gar nicht mehr wer arm geboren ist der
bleibt fast immer Arm das ist die
Realität und dann wundert man sich wenn
junge Menschen die schon in ihrer
Kindheit immer nur verzichten mussten
die in maroden runtergekommenen Schulen
lernen mussten und die ein
Bildungssystem erlebt haben das noch
nicht mal in der Lage war ihnen halbwegs
korrekt Lesen Schreiben und Rechnen
beizubringen wenn diese jungen men mit
wenig oder gar keiner Motivation ins
Leben starten ja das ist doch gar nicht
verwunderlich das liegt doch in dieser
Ausgangslage begründet und deswegen muss
man diese Ausgangslage verändern und
verbessern und auch dafür treten wir
an und was gar nicht geht was gar nicht
geht bewöhnte Jungpolitiker kommen die
trotz besserer staatschancen es oft auch
nicht geschafft haben wenigstens einen
soliden Abschluss zu machen und die
jetzt schon
wieder und die jetzt schon wieder und
das finde ich besonders perfide das Geld
für die Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung
von Arbeitslosen kürzen wenn diese
Jungpolitiker uns dann den Wert von
Fleiß und Anstrengung erklären also das
ist doch wirklich ein Hohn auch
gegenüber den Betroffenen aber auch
gegenüber uns
allen
dieselben dieselben Politiker übrigens
die sich als hochmoralische Gutmenschen
inszenieren die angeblich mit jedem im
Käfig gehaltenen Huhn und mit jeder
Kröte am Straßenrand leiden aber die ist
wenn es darauf ankommt die nicht davor
zurückschrecken fri Familien schon
wieder die Heizkosten zu erhöhen oder
den schon seit der coronazeit
strauchelnden gastwrd in die Pleite zu
stürzen das ist doch die Doppelmoral die
wir überall erleben und das geht so
nicht weiter
Politiker Politiker den es sowas von
egal ist wenn auf dem Land kein Bus mehr
fährt oder auch noch die letzte
Arztpraxis schließt aber die sich dann
hochmoralisch über alte weiße Männer
mckieren mit überholten Autos und
überholten
Ernährungsgewohnheiten das ist doch die
disrepanz zwischen dem aufgeblasenen
Moralismus dieser angeblichen
fortschrittskoalition und einer in der
Realität zu tiefst amoralischen und
reaktionären Politik das treibt die
Leute um und das treibt sie den falschen
in die Arme das wollen wir dringend
verändern
und ja wir brauchen Anstrengungen für
eine umweltverträgliche und
klimaneutrale Wirtschaft aber wir
brauchen durchdachte Lösungen und
deswegen freue ich mich auch dass wir so
viel Kompetenz in unseren rein haben
auch bei dieser Frage wir brauchen
durchdachte Lösungen und nicht eine
Regierung die Milliarden dafür
investiert von dem relativ
umweltfreundlichen und klimafreundlichen
Pipeline Gas auf das extrem und
umweltfeindliche freckingas umzusteigen
dass dann noch mit Schiffen über die
halbe Welt transportiert wird und die
gleichzeitig es für eine gute Idee hält
russisches Öl in Zukunft möglichst CO2
intensiv und teuer über Indien zu
importieren weil wir ja die guten sind
was ist das für eine verrückte Politik
das ist keine Klimapolitik das ist das
Gegenteil
eine Regierung die mit höheren CO2
preisen ihre Haushaltslöcher stopft und
gleichzeitig alles dafür tut dass die
barode Bahn bloß keine gute und
irgendwie akzeptable Alternative wird
eine Regierung die zuschaut wie
Zukunftstechnologien die wir für die
Klimawende dringend brauchen wie die aus
unserem Land abwandern während sie
gleichzeitig den Aktionären eines
amerikanischen Halbleiter Konzerns der
seine innovativste Zeit längst hinter
sich hat 10 Milliarden in den Rachen
wirft wer soll so eine Regierung noch
irgendetwas
glauben und
ja wir müssen wieder reden wir müssen
wieder reden über gesellschaftliche
Ungleichheit weil das tut keiner über
uns über die Enteignung der fleißigen
seit dre Jahren sinken die Kaufkraft der
Löhne in Deutschland und in vielen
Branchen sinkt sie schon wesentlich
länger es gibt immer mehr Berufe die
früher einen bescheidenen Wohlstand
ermöglicht haben und in denen die
Einkommen heute so sind dass man mit
ihnen nie die Chance auf ein halbwegs
gutes Leben hat auf ein Mindestmaß an
sozialer Sicherheit auf eine solide
Familienplanung oder gar auf ein eigenes
Häuschen oder eine eigene Wohnung und
das muss sich doch wieder ändern in
unserem Land und wir müssen reden über
eine gespaltene Wirtschaft wo der
melstand immer mehr unter Druck gerät
aber gleichzeitig auch das gehört ja
dazu die 40 größten Unternehmen in
Deutschland in diesem Jahr mitten in der
Krise mehr Dividenden ausschütten als je
zuvor das ist doch völlig absurd eine
solche
Entwicklung und
deshalb deshalb fordern wir deshalb
fordern wir schärfere kartellgesetze
auch gegen die Macht der Daten Kraken
aus Übersee und den Abbau der ganzen
aberwitzigen Vorschriften und Auflagen
die eine ständig wachsende
beraterindustrie nähren und in den
kleinen und mittleren Betrieben völlig
sinnlos Kapazitäten binden auch das muss
ich ändern und wir müssen darüber reden
dass es kein Zufall ist dass der Mix aus
Steuersenkungen und Steuererhöhungen den
die Ampel den Bürgern in diesem Jahr zu
Beginn des Jahres offeriert hat dass der
wieder mal die ärmeren und die untere
Mitte massiv belastet während die die
richtig viel verdienen am Ende sogar
noch mehr Geld in Ihrem Geldbeutel haben
es müsste doch gerade umgekehrt sein
dafür setzen wir uns
ein und
ja ich denke wir müssen wirklich auch
noch einmal neu nachdenken und auch
darüber reden öffentlich auch in unserem
Land wie wir unser gesellschaftliches
Miteinander und in unsere Wirtschaft
gestalten wollen Märkte und Wettbewerb
die sind ein gutes Instrument um
Unternehmen zur Innovation Effizienz und
Kundenorientierung anzuhalten aber das
gilt nur da wo Wettbewerb wirklich fair
funktioniert wo einzelne Unternehmen so
groß sind dass sie Zulieferern und
Kunden ihre Preise diktieren können da
funktioniert es eben nicht oder da wo es
natürliche Monopole gibt wie bei den
Strom Energie und auch bei den bei den
Kommunikationsnetzen bei den gasnetzen
da funktioniert es nicht und wo es um
existenzielle Bedürfnisse geht wie
wohnen Gesundheit oder Bildung da
setzten Kommerz und Renditedenken doch
völlig falsche Anreize und das sehen wir
am krassesten in unserem
Gesundheitssystem wir haben das zweit
teuerste Gesundheitswesen der Welt und
trotzdem wartet ein Kassenpatient Monate
auf ein Facharzttermin während es kein
anderes europäisches Land gibt wo so
viele Menschen an der Hüfte und am Knie
operiert werden das ist aber nicht so
weil wir ein Volk von hüftlahmen sind
sondern das ist so weil wir den
Krankenhäusern eingetrimmt haben nicht
zuerst zu fragen was braucht der Kranke
sondern was bringt das meiste Geld ein
Gesundheitssystem was so funktioniert
ist krank liebe Freundin und
Freunde
und wollen
wir wollen wir wirklich in einer
Gesellschaft leben wo sich alles nur
noch darum dreht aus Geld mehr Geld zu
machen in der wenigen enorme Macht
eingeräumt wird sich zu lassen aller
anderen zu bereichern in der der
ehrliche immer häufiger der Dumme ist
hat der Mensch nicht etwas Besseres
verdient und ja auch Krieg Krieg ist für
die die über Kriege entscheiden anders
als für die die unter ihren Schrecken
leiden vor allem ein Geschäft da geht es
um Rohstoffe da geht es um
einflussphären und da geht es immer auch
um
Waffenverkäufe und ja auch hier sind wir
ja angeblich die guten wenn unsere
Außenministerin mit erhobenem
Zeigefinger durch die Welt reist und mal
eben beiläufig vielleicht auch Russland
den Krieg erklärt da tut sie das ja
immer im Namen einer Werte geleiteten
feministischen
Außenpolitik so wie einst am Hindukusch
wird ja heute in der Ukraine unsere
Freiheit verteidigt und für unsere
Freiheit sollen die Ukrainer weiter
leiden und sterben und wir liefern Ihnen
die Waffen bis zum Sieg an den nur
leider selbst die ukrainischen Generäle
nicht mehr glauben ich finde das ist
eine so so
unverantwortliche
menschenverachtende Politik dieser Krieg
muss beendet werden und war ganz schnell
auf dem Verhandlungsweg und das wäre
möglich wenn man es wirklich
wollte und ganz nebenbei also das in dem
Land das da heute angeblich so tapfer
unsere Freiheit und unsere Werte
verteidigt das in diesem Land ein NAZ
Kollaborateur wie Stepan bandera des
Milizen am Holocaust beteiligt waren der
für die Morde an tausenden Juden Russen
und Polen verantwortlich ist dass in
diesem Land ein solcher Mann als
Nationalheld verteidigt verehrt wird
nach demem Straßen und Plätze benannt
werden ich finde es schon seltsam dass
diese wirkliche rechtsoffenheit unsere
grünen Moralapostel überhaupt nicht
stört auch das zeigt die Doppelmoral und
Heuchelei ihrer
Politik aber
offenbar offenbar werden unsere Werte ja
inzwischen sogar in Saudi-Arabien
verteidigt immerhin will unsere
feministische
außenpolitikerin jetzt diesem Regime das
Frauen zu Tode steinigt das Opposition
köpft und in dem auch mal eben ein
kritischer Journalist zersägt wird Iris
Raketen und Eurofighter liefern klar
Raketen tragen immerhin den weiblichen
Namen Iris also so viel Feminismus muss
im Hause bärburg offenbar
sein und wen
dann sogar noch gegendert wird dann ist
die grüne Welt offenbar wieder in
Ordnung aber unsere Welt ist nicht in
Ordnung und deswegen sagen wir Nein zu
Krieg und Nein zu Waffenexporten in
Kriegsgebiete das muss gestoppt
werden und ich
denke ich denke schon um diesen Wahnsinn
zu stoppen dass das kriegstüchtige
Deutschland in einer weltvoller kriege
jetzt auch militärisch wieder ganz vorn
mitmischen will schon und das zu stoppen
war es so wichtig dass wir uns auf den
Weg gemacht haben und dass wir uns
weiter auf den Weg machen und dass ihr
alle dabei seid weil auch das ist unsere
Aufgabe dass diese Kriegspolitik aufhört
und das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt für
unsere neue Partei wo wir weiter uns
engagieren werden liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
wir haben Großes vor für unser Land und
für die Menschen die große Erwartungen
in uns setzen wir sind es ihnen schuldig
unsere Sache gut zu machen danke
schön
[Applaus]
die stim auf dem vorläufigen Höhepunkt
beim ersten
Bundesparteitag des Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht nach der Rede von Sarah
Wagenknecht 31 Minuten und jetzt wird es
hier die eine und andere Minute Applaus
natürlich noch geben natürlich stehend
wie für viele ihrer Vorrednerinnen und
Vorredner auch wenn die vorrner hier
eindeutig in der Mehrheit waren ja lass
uns pleglich miteinander umgehen hat sie
in Richtung ihrer neuen Partei gesagt
lasst uns eine Partei des mit anders
werden wir sind keine linke 2.0 als sei
sie an den Debatten innerhalb der linken
Partei nie beteiligt gewesen und auch an
den Streitigkeiten die es da gegeben hat
was den pfleglichen Umgang angeht ist
sie mit den anderen Parteien etwas
weniger pfleglich hier vorgegangen hat
die ampelregierung die dümmste Regierung
Europas genannt hat von einem Trio in
Finale gesprochen von dem
Parteivorsitzenden den Bundeskanzler da
eben noch mit
einbezogen hat die anderen
politikerennen auch die anderen Parteien
als unfähig arrogant und im agieren
unsäglich genannt das wollen wir hier
nicht unterschlagen hat i natürlich auch
prächtig gegen die Medien
ausgeteilt wir senden trotzdem weiter
hier noch eine ganze Weile und sie hat
sich wieder für Frieden und Abrüstung
stark gemacht Krieg se immer ein
Geschäft sagt sie und es bedürfe eines
Neins zu Krieg und Waffenexporten das
kann ich Ihnen alles ganz entspannt
sagen weil der stehende Applaus hier
weiterhin anfängt anhält ich vermute nur
dass wir einen Satz heute hier im Laufe
dieses Tages im Zusammenhang mit Krieg
Frieden und Abrüstung nicht zu hören
bekommen werden und das wird der Satz
sein wir fordern Russland auf den Krieg
gegen die Ukraine zu beenden dieser Satz
wird hier heute sicherlich nicht
vorkommen nach all den Rednerinnen und
Rednern die ich bislang hier gehört habe
wir gehen mal rein in den Saal den Julia
grim steht schon bereit sehe ich auf
meinem Vorschaumonitor also in den
stehenden Applaus Julia steht auch wie
praktisch also bitte ganz genau danke
schön Erhard und ich frage einfach mal
das ist ein bisschen schwierig weil es
natürlich wahnsinnig laut ist aber ich
muss jetzt noch mal ganz kurz ganz genau
jetzt sind sie bei mir sie dürfen sich
gerne wieder hinsetzen wenn Sie mögen
ich komme zu Ihnen dann runter das ist
deutlich bequemer und dann stehen wir
nicht als einzige hier geht das
ja
so sagen sie mir noch
einmal wer sind sie wo kommen sie her
wir sind
die genau machen sie ren ich rede jetzt
erstmal mit gut ich binowan aus München
wir haben ja immerhin eine weibliche
Vorsitzende das ist wunderbar Frauen
haben halt vielleicht ein bisschen
weniger Zeit wei Kinderbetreuung noch
nicht so stimmt und vielleicht auch
nicht ganz so risikofreudig sind aber
das wird sich schon noch ändern sie
haben gerade der rede natürlich von SAR
Wagenknecht zugehört was war für Sie der
wichtigste Punkt den sie angesprochen
alles totaltig total aus der Seele
deswegen sind wir gerne so weit
hergekommen was hat denn Sarah
Wagenknecht was bringt diese Partei in
ihrer Idee mit was die anderen Parteien
nicht haben die absolute Liebe zum
Frieden das soziale das schon in den in
hintertriff gekommen ist und natürlich
auch die Gefühle die sie vermitteln kann
die in anderen Parteien oft sehr
runtergebügelt wird super ganz vielen
Dank ich gehe mal hier ein weiter wenn
Sie mögen sagen sie mir auch einmal wer
Sie sind und wo kommen sie her ja mein
Name ist irgt freihoffer und ich komme
aus Regensburg und was was treibt sie
dazu zum bündnisara Wagenknecht zu gehen
das sind ganz viele Dinge aber ich will
ein paar wichtige Dinge hervorheben das
ist zum einen was Sara wagn nicht auch
gesagt hat und was hier eigentlich
Konsens ist die immer weitere Einengung
des meinungskorridors und es ist ja auch
erwähnt worden dass beispielsweise
friedensdem mus mittlerweile als
rechtsoffen diskreditiert werden und
zurecht hat jetzt Frau Wagen nicht auch
erwähnt dass
friedensdem mus als rechtsoffen
diskreditiert werden aber gleichzeitig
nichts gesagt wird gegen den banderakult
beispielsweise in der Ukraine also sie
haben das Gefühl dass sie in Deutschland
nicht mehr sagen dürfen was sie möchten
dann in eine rechte Ecke gestellter dar
ich darf das schon noch sagen aber man
wird natürlich diskreditiert und
diffformiert und das ist im volollem
Gang ich erinnere auch daran dass
beispielsweise Bundeskanzler Scholz auf
eine SPD wahlveranstalt im letzten
Sommer in München
friedensdemonstrierende als gefallende
Engel aus der Hölle bezeichnet hat
beispielsweise kann ich mich nicht dran
erinnern müssen wir jetzt einfach mal so
stehen lassen was welche Hoffnungen
erwarten sie denn also was was wünschen
sich erwarten Sie sich von dieser neuen
Partei also eine der wichtigsten Fragen
ist sicherlich die Friedensfrage weil
man ja nicht weiß wie sich so ein Krieg
ausweiten kann es ist ja nicht so dass
man dem wie mit dem Joystick auf dem
Computer Plan kann in einem asseptischen
Raum sondern das kann natürlich
jederzeit eine Entwicklung annehmen die
für uns gefährlich ist also es gab ja
immer wieder Beispiele als eine
ukrainische Rakete in Polen gelandet ist
und dort ich weiß nicht zwei drei oder
vier Leute getötet hat wo sofort dann
der Ruf kam jetzt muss der Westen
eingreifen und so also allein aufgrund
von technischen Missverständnissen kann
natürlich als so ein Krieg sich
ausweiten und natürlich für die Menschen
in der Ukraine ist es wichtig dass der
Krieg so schnell wie möglich beendet
wird denn die Waffenlieferungen haben
das nicht gebracht was man sich erhofft
hat dass die Ukraine in eine bessere
Verhandlungssituation kommt keine
Waffenlieferungen mit einem Aggressor
wie Russland der dann ja nicht sagen
wird fantastisch wir sind jetzt einfach
mal zu allen Friedensverhandlungen
bereit ist natürlich auch nicht leicht
wie stellen Sie sich das vor das ist
richtig aber man könnte beispielsweise
das mit auch als Druckmittel verwenden
gegenüber Russland also natürlich beide
Seiten müssen sich bewegen auch Russland
dass man jetzt nicht einfach nur sagen
kann ab morgen gibt's gibt's gar nichts
gar keine Waffenlieferungen mehr für die
Ukraine das kann mag auch nicht
funktionieren man muss halt hier
ausloten man muss Druck auch auf
Russland ausüben aber auch auf die
Ukraine denn in der Ukraine gab's vor
über einem Jahr ein Dekret dass
Verhandlungen mit Russland verbietet sol
lang Russland sich nicht nur aus der
Ostukraine zurückgezogen hat sondern
auch von der grim ein komplizi
entschuldigung das sind natürlich
Maximalforderungen muss ich einmal kurz
unterbrechen weil es ein Ergebnis gibt
auf der Bühne dass wir verkünden müssen
gleich wieder bei Aufmerksamkeit zur
Verkündung des Ergebnisses der Wahl für
die beiden noch offenen Posten als
stellvertretende
Parteivorsitzende ich beginne
alphabetisch mit Friederike
Bender für Friederike Bender abgegeben
wurden
Stimmen davon gültig 377
ungültig ull
mit ja abgestimmt haben
362 stimmen mit Nein gestimmt haben
Enthaltungen Enthaltungen gab es vier
Friederike Bender ist damit gewählt mit
96% der
Stimmen
Liebe friederik Bender ich frage dich
nimmst du die Wahl
an ich stelle damit fest Frederike
Bender ist als stellvertretende
Parteivorsitzende gewählt kommen wir nun
zu amid rabie für amid Rab abgegeben
wurden
378 Stimmen davon gültig
ungültig Null mit Ja gestimmt haben
insgesamt
355 mit Nein gestimmt haben 11
Enthaltungen gab es 12 amidrabie ist
demnach gewählt mit 94% herzlichen
Glückwunsch so da haben wir die beiden
ersten Ergebnisse hier der ersten Wahlen
die stattgefunden haben es wurde ja der
Parteivorstand erweitert um zwei weitere
Stellvertreter
bzw eine Stellvertreterin ein
stellvertretär Friederike Bender ist
gewählt mit 96% der abgegebenen Stimmen
und amid rabie mit 94% der abgegebenen
Stimmen das sind schon ganz stolze
Ergebnisse aber das passt auch zu dem
was wir hier beobachten bei diesem
Gründungsparteitag bei diesem ersten
Bundesparteitag muss man korrekterweise
sagen das Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht und
denn hier ist große Einigkeit unter
denen die hier im Saal im in der Event
Location Kosmos dem ehemaligen DDR Kino
sind Mark steinhuser hat eine nicht ganz
unprominente Gesprächspartnerin also wir
das ist ganz korrekt formuliert er hat
schärfer bei uns hier bei Phönix ist
jetzt die parteichfin Sarah Wagenknecht
die Namensgeberin Sarah Wagenknecht die
gerade die Rede gehalten hier Frau
Wagenknecht willkommen bei phöniix sie
haben hier ja einen Rundumschlag gemacht
sie haben auf der einen Seite gesagt der
Ton wird rauer haben sich darüber
beklagt auf der anderen Seite haben Sie
die Ampel als dümmste Regierung Europas
bezeichnet wie passt denn das zusammen
ja ich habe den rauen Ton beklagt
gegenüber Bürgerinnen und Bürgern vor
allem auch solchen denen es nicht gut
geht ich finde Politiker das gilt für
mich auch können durchaus was aushalten
aber das schlimme ist ja dass es stimmt
also ich würde mir ja wünschen wir
hätten die beste Regierung Europas und
ich würde sie liebenend gerne loben aber
es ist ja kein Zufall dass unser Land in
Europa dasjenige ist wo die Wirtschaft
sich am schlechtesten entwickelt wir
haben im letzten Jahr eine schumpfung
der Wirtschaft die Prognosen für dieses
Jahr sind nicht gut das ist in keinem
anderen Land so deswegen kann man auch
nicht sagen die Welt ist verantwortlich
die Krisen die Kriege das ist alles
schlimm aber warum ist es bei uns
schlimmer als woanders das liegt schon
an dieser Regierung und an ihren
Fehlentscheidungen sie noch mal
vielleicht nachgefragt sie wollen die
Demokratie ja irgendwie erhalten und
retten so formulieren Sie das ja
teilweise
dennoch greifen Sie die Ampel scharf an
das Establishment scharf an sie
versuchen etwas zu retten was sie
gleichzeitig diskrediti ktioniert wie
soll das funktionieren also ich
diskreditiere nicht die Demokratie das
läge mir fern sondern ich wünschte sie
würde wieder funktionieren also
demokratie heißt doch dass sich die
Interessen die Wünsche der Mehrheit
durchsetzen wir haben eine Regierung die
an den an der Bevölkerung an den
bürgeren und Bürgern vorbei regiert man
kann doch nicht im Ernst sagen dass die
Entscheidungen die in den letzten Jahren
getroffen wurden im Sinne der Menschen
vor allem auch der Mitte der
Gesellschaft oder der ärmeren waren
sondern hier setzen sich starke Lobbys
durch hier setzen sich Ideologien durch
ein
abgehobenes milie macht hier Politik für
sich und die Menschen gucken in die in
ins lehere und viele sind wütend am Ende
profitiert davon zur Zeit vor allem die
AFD aber das ist nicht weil es mehr
Menschen gibt die rechtsradikal sind
sondern weil sich hier einfach sehr viel
Unmut aufstaut und ich wünsche mir eine
Politik die diesen Unmut abbaut indem
sie vernünftige Entscheidung trifft
dafür treten wir an sie heizen den Unmut
ja teilweise dennoch an sie haben die
bauernproteste hier ja auch ausführlich
erwähnt gleichzeitig wird etwa auch
vermeldet von Agrar heute dass die
Landwirte im Wirtschaftsjahr 22 23 ein
Ausnahmejahr hatten in allen
Betriebsformen wurden spitzengewinne
erzielt sie sagen die Ampel zieht den
Landwirten das Geld aus der Tasche auch
da wie passt das zusammen na wir haben
einen ganz kurzen aufschung gehabt in
der Landwirtschaft oder aufschung also
einen Gewinn plus das hatte mit den sehr
hohen Lebensmittelpreisen also vor allen
auch Getreidepreisen zu tun am Beginn
des ukrainekriegs aber man muss ja immer
die Relation sehen also in den Jahren
davor haben die Betriebe oft nicht gut
verdient vor allem haben wir auch eine
große Diskrepanz zwischen sehr großen
Landwirtschaftsbetrieben die das noch
einigermaßen alles schultern können und
sehr sehr vielen familiengeführten Höfen
die ja immer mehr aufgeben müssen also
dass 40.000 Höfe 40.000 Familien im
Landwirtschaftsbereich aufgeben mussten
in den letzten 10 Jahren das sind ja
statistisch belegte zahlen hier ist ein
großer Druck ich selber wohne auf dem
Dorf ich habe mit Landwirten gesprochen
die haben mir geschildert wie ihre
Situation ist und sie sagen das ist
einfach unerträglich sie kriegen immer
neue Auflagen immer neuen Druck
gleichzeitig werden die Tore aufgemacht
für billig Importe aus dem Ausland die
all diese Auflagen nicht haben und da
sollen sie sich dann irgendwie
durchfinden und jetzt kriegen sie noch
dieses zusätzliche diese zusätzlichen
Belastungen ich finde das ist eine
arrogante Politik sie wollen den
Landwirten alle Kürzungen wieder
zurücknehmen sie wollen dass die
agrarsubvenstion im vollem Umfang
bleiben das heißt also die Landwirte aus
ihrer Sicht die sollen auch weiterhin
Gewinne machen in Deutschland
ja ein Unternehmen muss ja irgendwo auch
Gewinne machen wenn es investieren soll
also Gewinn ist ja nichts Schlechtes die
Frage ist ob Gewinne überworden sind ob
man Gewinne dafür nutzt da sind sie oft
sehr kritisch dann wenn es hohe Gewinne
sind na dann wenn die Gewinne nicht
genutzt werden für Forschung für
Entwicklung für Investitionen sondern
wenn Sie weitergegeben werden an
Aktionäre die ja oft dann irgendwo auf
der Welt sitzen und eigentlich an diesem
Gewinn den haben sie nicht erarbeitet
dafür haben sie keine Leistung erbracht
das ist ja z.B auch ein Unterschied g
über Unternehmen die von ihren Inhabern
geführt werden wo der Unternehmer selbst
und das ist ja auch bei den Bauern in
der Regel der Fall selbst im Unternehmen
arbeitet sehr viel auch Herzblut
reinbringt also da muss man etwas
differenzieren und wir haben ja wirklich
eine zweigespaltene Wirtschaft wir haben
einerseits sehr große börsennotierte
Konzerne die ihr großes Geschäft
weitgehend außerhalb Deutschlands machen
deswegen geht's den auch ganz gut und
wir haben einen starken Mittelstand
immer noch der aber immer mehr von der
Politik geschwächt wird dem immer mehr
Knüppel zwischen die Beine geworfen
werden und das ist etwas was unserem
Land und auch den Menschen ja auch den
Beschäftigten natürlich massiv schadet
nun haben sie jetzt auch wieder
wortreich erklärt warum sie die Ampel
ganz und gar nicht unterstützen wollen
gleichzeitig haben Sie gesagt Sie wollen
eigentlich jetzt bei den Wahlen dann
auch in diesem Jahr antreten und auch
möglicherweise mitregieren da bleibt ja
natürlich die Frage wenn sie so gegen
die Grünen wettern wenn sie so gegen
Friedrich März wettern wenn sie mit der
SPD unzufrieden sind und mit der FDP
ohnehin und die AFD die
überzeugt sie ja auch nicht mit wem
wollen Sie dann regieren ja wir werden
auf jeden Fall nicht regieren wenn es um
ein weiter so geht aber ich bin
überzeugt wenn wir stark werden wenn
sehr viele Menschen uns wählen dann
verändert das natürlich die politische
Debatte in Deutschland ich meine die SPD
z.B war nicht immer so wie sie heute ist
ich meine hatte auch mal andere
öffentliche Werte sie hatte war mal eine
Partei von über 30 Mal sogar von über
40% heute steht sie bei jämmerlichen 15
das hat sie sich redlich verdient mit
ihrer Politik aber ich würde mir
natürlich wünschen dass ich da mal
wieder was ändert ich meine auch die CDU
war mal eine Partei die durchaus auch
einen starken sozialen Flügel hatte wenn
ich so an Norbert Blüm denke da gab es
ja durchaus Anknüpfungspunkte das ist
etwas anderes als die Blackrock
Ideologie die heute auch von Friedrich
märz vertreten und verkörpert wird also
auch da Parteien ändern sich und es h
auch ein bisschend und CDU müssen sich
quasi nach ihnen richten dann würden sie
mit denen auch zusammenarbeiten sie
sollen sich vor allem nach den Bürger
und Bürgern richten nicht nach uns das
wäre anmaßend aber ich wünsche mir dass
im Land eine Stimmung steht auch in den
einzelnen Parteien dass es so nicht
weitergehen kann und dass sie sich
selbstkritisch auch mal fragen wie ihre
Verantwortung dafür ist dass die AFD
jetzt im Osten teilweise bei weit über
30% steht und bundesweit bei über 20 das
ist doch Ergebnis ihrer Politik das ist
ihre Position dazu gleichzeitig haben
sie ja die Demonstrationen gegen die AFD
die auch ja jetzt massiv in vielen
Städten stattfinden ja nur am Rande
erwähnt in ihrer Rede das kam nur ganz
kurz vor die die bauernproteste etwas
mehr
wie bewerten Sie dass dass jetzt so
viele Menschen in Deutschland gegen
Rechtsextremismus auf die Straße gehen
auch nach diesem Treffen was bekannt
geworden ist in portsdam wo es ja um die
massenausweisung von Menschen mit
deutscher Staatsangehörigkeit ging ich
ich verstehe und ich teile das Anliegen
der Menschen die dort ehrlich auf der
Straße sind weil sie Angst haben davor
dass eine rechte Partei eine Partei in
der es ja wirklich auch Extremisten
Rechtsextremisten Nazis gibt wie Herrn
höcke wenn die immer stärker wird dass
Menschen dagegen etwas tun wollen dass
Sie dafür auf die Straße gehen das ist
wunderbar und das spricht für unser Land
dass es so viele sind aber was ich eben
auch angesprochen habe ist die Heuchelei
der ampelpolitiker die dann glauben sie
können da in der ersten Reihe mitlaufen
obwohl sie damit faktisch gegen die
Ergebnisse ihrer eigenen Politik
demonstrieren weil sie haben die AFD
stark gemacht und was ich nicht glaube
ist dass die Demonstration die AFD
Schwächen werden sondern was die AFD
schwächen kann ist eine vernünftige
Politik ist sind andere
Weichenstellungen dass die Menschen das
Gefühl haben Politiker hören Ihnen
wieder mehr zu sie machen das was für
Sie wichtig ist was ihren Alltag
erleichtert statt ihnen immer mehr auch
wirklich Belastungen überzuhelfen sie
haben ja in dem Verhältnis zur AFD
bisher gesagt ein Wechsel von AFD
Mitgliedern in ihr neues Bündnis in ihre
Partei einen direkten Wechsel ich
zitiere sie da wird es nicht geben was
ist denn ein indirekter
Wechsel also natürlich muss jemand der
bei uns Mitglied ist unsere Programmatik
teilen und wer jetzt in der AFD ist
teilt die Programmatik der AFD wenn Sie
das Vergleichen in der
Wirtschaftspolitik in der Sozialpolitik
in ganz vielen auch in der
Friedenspolitik also die AFD ist zwar
eine Partei die schon bei der Ukraine
Frage für Verhandlungen wirbt aber wo
der verteidigungspolitische Sprecher
engstens mit der Rüstungsindustrie
verwandelt ist sie ist nicht für weniger
Rüstung sie ist sogar für noch mehr
Aufrüstung also das ist einfach nicht
kompatibel für uns wenn Menschen also
können Mitglieder aus der AFD bei ihnen
Mitglied werden wenn sie dann ein halbes
Jahr warten oder wie muss ich mir das
vorstellen also auch die AFD ist eine
Partei die sie verändert hat und ich
kann mir durchaus vorstellen dass
Bürgerin und Bürger 2013 aus Sorge dass
der Euro nicht funktioniert dass sie
dort ein andere Schwerpunkte haben
wollen vielleicht damals eingetreten
sind längst mit Grausen wieder draußen
sind deswegen sagen wir jetzt nicht
prinzipiell und für alle Zeit aber
völlig klar ist Rechtsextremisten Nazis
ja selbstverständlich werden die nicht
in unser ma machen Sie bei jedem eine
Prüfung eine Einzelfallprüfung für
ehemalige AFD Mitglieder bei ihrem
Bündnis wir schauen uns jede jeden an
wir müssen das auch der in unsere Partei
möchte weil wir schon wollen dass wir
auch bei unserem Programm bleiben und
die AFD ist ein Beispiel dafür dass man
eine Partei gründen kann die nach
mehreren Jahren in eine völlig andere
Richtung geht wir möchten dass
diejenigen die bei uns als Mitglied dann
auch die Partei mitgestalten wirklich
hinter dem stehen wofür wir antreten ich
finde das sind wir auch unseren
Wählerinnen und Wählern schuldig weil
sie sollen immer wissen was sie wählen
und das ist bei anderen Parteien ja
nicht automatisch so auch die Linke hat
sich über die Jahre sehr stark verändert
und deswegen werben wir dafür dass
Menschen uns zunächst einmal als
Unterstützer unterstützen also dass sie
das brauchen wir auch und da sind wir
sehr froh dass das sehr viele machen
wollen die uns in die Wahlkämpfen
unterstützen die bei uns mittun und dann
werden wir die Menschen kennenlernen und
alle die sich konstruktiv einbringen
wollen alle die wirklich auch unsere
Programmatik unsere Ziele teilen die
werden natürlich auch die Chance haben
dann als Parteimitglied in unserer
Partei mitzuwirken ich frag das auch
deshalb noch mal weil man ihnen ja auch
vorwirft dass sie sich da nicht genug
abgrenzen
dieser Organisator dieses rechtsextremen
Treffens da in Potzdam mit dem haben
sich über Jahre auch ausgetauscht Herr
möing der hat mit ihnen hin und her
gemailt sie sagen jetzt sie wussten gar
nicht dass das ein rechter ist haben sie
den denn nie gegoogelt mal vorher also
ich habe mir inzwischen sagen lassen ich
habe ihn natürlich nicht gegoogelt weil
er mir damals ein sehr interessantes
Abendessen mit einem wirklich
unzweifelhaften
linken Kabarettisten vermittelt hat wenn
wenn jemand sich so einführt rechnet man
wirklich nicht damit dass es ein rechter
ist es gab aber wohl bis 2018 auch gar
keine Einträge hat man mir im Nachhinein
gesagt über ihn das heißt das ist erst
in den letzten Jahren oder ich glaube
sein wikipediaintrag ist von
2023 also ich kann nicht in jede jeden
Kopf hineinschauen das ist ja ein Grund
mehr warum wir bei den Mitgliedern jetzt
genau hinschauen wollen damit genau
solche Fälle nicht auftreten dass solche
Leute plötzlich bei uns Mitglied werden
und dann sind wir zutiefst erschrocken
und sta wer sich da eingeschlichen hat
der hat früher mal einen völkischen
jugendratgeber veröffentlicht und war
auch beim rechtsextremen Bund Deutscher
heimatjugend das sind alles Sachen die
haben sie einfach nicht gecheckt als sie
sich mit dem ausgetaus hab kon man
damals nicht checken also die waren
nicht im Internet abrufbar und ich habe
jetzt ja auch keine intensiven Kontakte
und austausche gepflegt sondern ich habe
dieses eine Abendessen das ist das
einzige Mal wo ich direkt also auch mit
ihm ein Gespräch hatte oder vor allem
eigentlich mit dem Kabarettisten und
danach hat er mir ab und an mal eine
Mail geschickt also es war jetzt auch
nicht so dass wir ja eine herzliche
Brieffreundschaft unterhalten haben
sondern ich habe von ganz vielen Bürgern
und Bürgern immer wieder Mails bekommen
wo sie mir Rückmeldung geben auf
Auftritte und in etwa das war das auch
was der Mann gemacht hat sagt Sara
Wagenknecht die Bundesvorsitzende des
Bündnisses Sarah Wagenknecht die heute
hier ja die erste Partei
bundesparteiversammlung durchgeführt hat
wir werden beobachten wer bei ihnen noch
so Mitglied wird besten Dank für das
Gespräch sehr
gerne und mit diesen Antworten der
Namensgeberin dieses Bündnisses werden
wir jetzt noch mal ein bisschen auf
Spurensuche gehen wer denn sonst so hier
mitmacht wer sich Sarah Wagenknecht
angeschlossen hat wir haben ja gehört es
gibt da eine sehr explizite Vorauswahl
wer im Moment nur Mitglied werden darf
und sie will sich das auch in Zukunft
offensichtlich sehr genau anschauen
deshalb Julia Grimm wer ist denn sonst
noch hier so im Saal dabei ja genau die
Frage gebe ich einfach mal direkt weiter
ich bin immer noch in Bayern sozusagen
beheimatet vielleicht sagen Sie uns
einmal wer sie sind wo sie genau
herkommen und weil das gerade ein großes
Thema war sind sie schon geprüft worden
ob sie vorher in der AFD waren also mein
Name ist Simone Ketterl ich komme gerne
mich anschauen ich komme aus dem
bayerischen Oberland war dort bis 7
Januar Kreissprecherin der linken und
nein man offensichtlich nicht AFD ich
war offensichtlich nicht in der AFD nein
also geprüft also diese Idee des
kontrollierten Wachstums ist natürlich
sehr wichtig weil so ein neuer ST und so
eine neue Bewegung natürlich viele
Menschen anzieht die sich davon was
erwarten was erhoffen die ihr kleines
steckenpferdthema platzieren wollen und
für uns ist es natürlich ganz wichtig
dass wir uns ganz klar abgrenzen von am
allen faschistischen narzisstischen
fremden feindlichen Menschen die können
wir in unserer Mitte in unseren Reihen
nicht gebrauchen und deswegen ist diese
Idee des kontrollierten Wachstums für
uns so wichtig ich habe das gerade ein
bisschen flapsig gesagt aber genau frage
ich noch noch mal ernst nach wie groß
ist denn da die Sorge auch dass eben
viele kräftig jetzt ja jenseits davon ob
sie vorher AFD Mitglied waren oder nicht
aber eben dass man nicht so richtig weiß
welche politische Heimat hat man wenn
man in diese Partei eintritt weil ja
schon auch viel besprochen worden ist
was ist das denn jetzt eigentlich ist
das links ist das rechts was genau ist
das also ich kann ein bisschen schildern
wie es bei uns vor Ort ist wir sind als
Vorstand komplett gewechselt also ein
ein ehemalige Genosse nicht aber das
heißt wir haben sozusagen eine Struktur
auf der wir aufbauen können und das sind
Leute die wir seit 10 Jahren kennen das
heißt da haben wir erstmal keine Sorge
wenn neue Leute zu uns kommen die kommen
ja aus ganz unterschiedlichen Gründen
und ganz unterschiedlichen Ecken haben
eine ganz unterschiedliche Vita und
wollen ganz verschiedene Dinge erreichen
und erhoffen sich vieles weil es ja auch
so eine Projektionsfläche erstmal ist so
ein neues Projekt und da werden wir uns
Zeit lassen also es geht uns nicht drum
dass wir sofort jetzt hier 100 Leute in
ein Ortsverband haben von denen wir
niemanden kennen und dann ist es völlig
kontrolliert was was passiert und dann
ist vielleicht auch nicht geklärt ob das
eben tatsächlich zu uns passt und
deswegen finde ich das als Strategie gut
und dann muss man sich eben erstmal drei
Monate kennenlernen oder vier und gucken
aber überrascht es Sie eigentlich dass
auch rechtsorientierte Menschen sich von
dieser Partei angesprochen fühlen weil
ja schließlich auch Position vertreten
werden die zum Teil den der AFD nicht
unählich sind na ja also wir haben keine
Position die irgendwie eine
Übereinstimmung mit der AFD haben es ist
halt so dass man bestimmte Themen wie
jetzt
Migrationspolitik hier offener
diskutiert also bei in der Linken war es
immer sehr klar Begrenzung der Migration
z.B gibt's ja auch die Forderung bei der
AFD die gibt es aber es wird ja hier
ganz anders gearbeitet also es geht hier
um eine lösungsorientierte
Herangehensweise es geht nicht um
Polemik ich verstehe jeden der aus
welchem Grund auch immer und sei es
wirtschaftliche Gründe hierherkmt das
finde ich absolut absolut
nachvollziehbar und ich würde niemals
gegen diese Menschen hetzen und ich
würde immer sagen wir müssen versuchen
allen zu helfen ja aber Fakt ist auch
dass man nicht alle aufnehmen kann oder
zumindest nicht in der aktuellen
infrastrukturellen Lage also die
Kommunen sind überlastet wenn man
schafft das auszugleichen dann ist es
wunderbar und also ich bin auch absolut
für eine Willkommenskultur ich bin für
eine offene und tolerante Gesellschaft
aber man muss dieses Problem rational
bespre und das wollen wir hier leisten
das hat mit AFD Position nichts zu tun
was mich noch interessiert ist SAR
Wagenknecht hat eben in ihrer Rede auch
gesagt dass es eigentlich aus ihrer
Sicht bei all der Kritik die sie an der
ampelregierung hat Neuwahlen geben
müsste da schwingt ja auch die Hoffnung
mit dass dieses neue Bündnis diese neue
Partei auch in irgendeiner Weise mit
Verantwortung übernehmen könnte mit wem
kann sich denn das Bündnis SAR
Wagenknecht aus ihrer Sicht vorstellen
eine Koalition zu gründen also ich sehe
anknüpfungspk und ich sag bewusst
Anknüpfungspunkte weil momentan ist die
SPD auf einem völlig neoliberalen Kurs
aber im Grundsatz habe ich eine Hoffnung
dass man mit der SPD koalieren könnte
und auch mit der Linken se ich immer
noch große Überschneidungen ich danke
Ihnen ganz herzlich und unbedingt müssen
wir noch den Kollegen neben ihnen
befragen also nicht mein Kollege sondern
ihr Kollege damit er nicht den Eindruck
hat er sitzt hier nur dekorativ rum auch
sie wahrscheinlich waren vorher bei den
Linken wenn Sie jetzt hier so sitzen
dann frage ich sie jetzt einfach mal was
was hat Ihnen denn bei den Linken
gefehlt dass sie jetzt sagen sie müssen
ins Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht genau ich
war mein ganzes Erwachsenenleben also
ich bin mit 18 in die Linkspartei
eingetreten
und das der Punkt ist ich glaube wo auch
ich gesagt habe jetzt ist diese Partei
nicht mehr meine ist als die
Friedensdemonstration im Februar so
niedergemacht wurden ist als uns da
unterstellt worden ist dass wir rechts
offen wären wir haben für wir haben für
Frieden demonstriert das kann nicht
rechts offen sein und dann muss muss man
sagen die Linkspartei ist leider in in
den letzten Jahren eine immer
akademischere Partei geworden immer mehr
eine
studentenptei geworden ich bin Jugend
und Auszubildenden Vertreter bei mir im
Betrieb und wir haben in der Linkspartei
kaum mehr Menschen die eine Ausbildung
machen eine Ausbildung gemacht haben das
es wird immer weniger man wird und als
Gewerkschafter hat man es der Leute
vertritt die eine Ausbildung gemacht
haben hat man es einfach mit diesem
Parteivorstand den die Linkspartei hatte
schwierig gehabt noch noch und deutlich
seinen Kollegen vermitteln zu können
warum die Linkspartei die eigenen
Interessen vertritt die Partei hat sich
immer mehr in kulturpolitischen Sachen
verstrickt und ich denke wichtig ist
dass man eine klare friedenspolitische
Haltung hat und eine klare ökonomische
Haltung hat dass man für die Millionen
und aber Millionen arbeitenden Menschen
in diesem Land steht sie haben das
Gefühl also dass Sara Wagenknecht es
schafft Arbeiterinnen
Arbeiter Menschen die womöglich im
Niedriglohnsektor arbeiten
dass das die neue Heimat sozusagen
dieser Menschen werden kann das hoffe
ich sehr dafür möchte ich kämpfen und
ich denke ich denke Sarah Wagenknecht
ist eine Person die ganz viele Menschen
anspricht ganz viele Menschen hören ihr
zu auch Menschen die früher der
Linksparteien nicht nahe gestanden haben
und wenn wir diese Menschen schaffen es
abzuholen ihn eine politische Heimat zu
geben dann denke ich ist viel gewonnen
und wenn wir es schaffen diese Menschen
mitzunehmen und mit diesen Menschen
gemeinsam für ein soziales Land zu
streiten für ein Land in dem nicht mehr
die Tafeln eine boomende Branche sind
sondern für ein Land in dem sich jeder
den Einkauf bis zum Ende des Monats
leisten kann ich habe eine kurze Frage
noch an sie bevor ich zurückgebe zu uns
ans Set in Bayern sind gerade Wahlen
erst gewesen jetzt stehen große
Landtagswahlen an in Ostdeutschland wo
die AFD sehr sehr stark ist glauben Sie
dass es dieser Partei gelingen kann
tatsächlich Wähler von der AFD
wegzuholen oder ist das für sie eher so
klingt es jetzt gerade ein
Alternativangebot zu den linken nein ich
denke es spricht alle Menschen an die
Arbeiten alle Menschen die
ihr Geld von der Arbeit mit nach Hause
bringen und die gut leben wollen in
diesem Lande und das sind auch die
meisten Wähler der AFD gehen natürlich
wählen und ich denke wir geben allen
arbeitenden Menschen in diesem Land ein
klares Angebot für Frieden und dafür
dass am Ende auch für Sie ein gutes
Leben in diesem Land möglich ist ich
danke Ihnen ganz herzlich ihnen beiden
und gehe dann gebe zurück an erh schffer
danke Julia ja wir sind hier im Kosmos
im ehemaligen Kosmos Filmtheater
ehemaliges großraumkino an der karlmx
allelee in friedrichshin Kreuzberg seit
2005 ist das hier eine sogenannte
Eventlocation aber an ein paar
dekorativen Einrichtungen
kann man noch erkennen oder zumindest
ahnen dass es sich hier mal um ein Kino
gehandelt hat es war eins der
wichtigsten übrigens zu DDR Zeiten mit
Ehrenplätzen für Walter Ulbricht oder
Erich Honnecker und da vorne sehen wir
Oscar lafontain wo ich gerade den
saaränder Honnecker erwähnt habe der
saaränder la fontain im Gespräch mit
Kollegen da wo er schon ein Interview
gibt er wird am späten am frühen Abend
hier auch eine Rede halten ist ja vor
kurzem auch in das BSW eingetreten hat
zwischenzeitlich wir haben es ein wenig
beobachten können im Laufe des
Vormittags seiner Frau Sarah wagenkn
nicht den einen oder andere Tipp mal
gegeben z.B als sie angesprochen wurde
von der Bühne vom Pult jetzt musst Du
aufstehen haben wir ihm von den Lippen
quasi abgelesen und ja jetzt gibt also
Oscar lafonin selber noch Interviews ja
hat auch eine bewegte Parteigeschichte
und Karriere hinter sich die einmal bei
der SPD angefangen hat und jetzt hier
mutmaßlich beim bsw endet wir sie sehen
im Hintergrund Mittagspause ist hier bis
13:45 das hat uns ja zum einen die
schöne Gelegenheit gegeben auch noch mal
mit Parteimitgliedern die nicht ganz so
prominent sind zu sprechen und von denen
zu hören warum sie Mitglied dieses
Bündnis geworden sind wir wollen ihn
aber auch wir wollen aber auch die
Gelegenheit nutzen in die eine und
andere Rede noch mal zuzuspielen die
hier im Laufe des Vormittags schon
gehalten worden ist beispielsweise von
Shervin hakin dem bis vor kurzem einzig
stellvertretenden Parteivorsitzenden er
hat ja zwei weitere an seine Seite
bekommen an Stellvertretern nämlich
Friederike Bender und
mit rabie das muss man auch richtig
aussprechen wenn man das schon sagt also
Shervin hakinov war bislang der einzige
Stellvertreter jetzt sind sie zu dritt
ein Quereinsteiger die große
Überraschung ist ja gewesen am 8 Januar
bei der Pressekonferenz in der
Bundespressekonferenz
Universitätsprofessor am karlsroher
Institut für Technologie
geschäftsführender direkt des Instituts
für Technologie und Management im
Baubetrieb davor Unternehmer in einem
Baukonzern also auch eine hoch
interteressante und bewegte Biografie
Politiker ist er bis zum Eintritt ins
BSW allerdings nicht gewesen und hier
ist seine Rede noch
mal wenn sich die Politik der letzten
Jahre in Deutschland und in Europa nicht
gravierend verändert steht unsere
Demokratie für die Millionen von
Menschen über Generationen hinweg
gekämpft haben auf dem
Spiel es haben sich einfach zu viele
Menschen
abgewandt zu viele haben sich
zurückgezogen zu viele haben
resigniert und wer will es diesen
Menschen
verübeln eine Politik die die soziale
Frage und die der Gerechtigkeit nicht
mehr in den Fokus stellt wo die hart
arbeitenden Menschen immer mehr belastet
werden wo Lebensleistung von Rentnern
Eltern und Alleinerziehenden nicht
anerkannt wird wo Unterstützung für die
Schwachen und schwächsten gekürzt wird
und wo Bildung immer mehr zu einer Frage
der Herkunft wird eine solche Politik
zerstört den sozialen Zusammenhalt und
das Vertrauen in Demokratie und
Staat eine Politik die grob
fahrlässig manchmal denkt man auch
mutwillig die Bedingungen für unsere
Wirtschaft verschlechtert wo Bürokratie
und Regeln ungehemmt wachsen und
Innovation und Risiko Bereitschaft
ersticken wo in Behörden oft
absicherungsmentalität vorherrscht statt
Serviceorientierung für Bürger und
Unternehmen wo Energie für Industrie und
Mittelstand sinnlos verteuert wird und
wo notwendige Investitionen in Bildung
und Infrastruktur ausbleiben eine solche
Politik führt nicht nur dazu dass unser
Wohlstand sinkt sondern damit dazu dass
soziale Spannungen immer größer
werden und Politiker und Politiker die
die Bürger immer dann mögen wenn Sie von
ihnen gewählt werden dieselben Menschen
aber verachten wenn sie sich
herausnehmen Regierungshandeln in Frage
zu stellen wo Menschen mit
abweichenden wo Menschen mit
abweichenden Meinungen als rückständig
oder extrem ethtikettiert werden wo
Entscheidungen als alternativlos oder
Transformation verkauft werden um
letztlich über Ideologien
hinwegzutäuschen oder von
lobbyeinflüssen abzulenken und wo
Menschen die andere Auffassung vertreten
öffentlich diskreditiert und
herabgesetzt werden solche Politiker
erreichen dass sich immer mehr
zurückziehen weil sie an an den Rand
gedrängt
werden kurzum wenn regierende entkoppelt
von der Realität völlig
schwerelos nicht mehr die Interessen der
Bürger im Blick haben wenn ein Kanzler
Respekt verspricht aber selbst dieses so
großartige Wort zu einer holen Phrase
verkommen lässt dann sind wir als
Gesellschaft auf einem gefährlichen Weg
und es sind sicher nicht die Menschen
daran schuld die sich abwenden liebe
Freundinnen und
Freunde das alles hat mich in den
letzten Jahren sehr bewegt und für mich
und viele andere ist es ein großes Glück
dass es mit unserer Partei wieder eine
politische Heimat gibt eine Partei die
Menschen Hoffnung und Zuversicht gibt
mit einer einzigartigen Kombination an
Programmatik und die einzige relevante
Partei Daniela dan hat es gesagt die
eine konsequente Friedenspolitik
verfolgen wird liebe Freundinnen und
[Applaus]
Freunde ja ESB präsentationslücke und ja
es ist gut dass wir sie füllen und
zugleich bin ich davon überzeugt dass
ich die Menschen neben anderen Inhalten
auch nach einer anderen politischen
Kultur Sehnen viele wenden sich ja
deswegen von Politik ab sind geradezu
abgeturnt von davon die Politiker sich
verhalten mit unserem Neuanfang haben
wir nun auch die Chance zu einer neuen
politischen Kultur beizutragen eine
Kultur bei der Politiker zuerst an
diejenigen denken für die sie Politik
machen sollen und nicht anen eigenen
Vorteil oder an Lobbyinteressen bei der
in der Sache hart und kontrovers
gestritten wird es aber im Dialog
respektvoll zugeht gerade auch mit
politischen Wettbewerbern bei der
politischer Streit so geführt wird dass
man sich nicht als Feind begegnet
sondern in der Lage ist anschließend
zusammen Lösungen zu finden und dabei
glaubwürdig zu bleiben bei
[Applaus]
der
bei der Politiker mit den Ressourcen
über die sie verfügen sorgsam umgehen
und über Verschwendung nicht
achselzuckend hinwegblicken und bei der
Kompetenz und Fähigkeiten wieder zu
Kriterien werden nach denen Menschen
politische Verantwortung übertragen
wird und ich bin sicher wenn uns das
gelingt eine solche Kultur in der Partei
und im politischen Wettbewerb vorzuleben
werden viele Menschen Politik und
staatlichen Institutionen wieder
Vertrauen
schenken liebe Freundin und Freunde
viele aus meinem Umfeld haben mir in den
letzten Wochen für den Schritt in die
Politik Respekt
gezollt dennoch empfinde ich es
zuallererst als Vorrecht und auch als
Verpflichtung diesem Land dem ich so
viel zu verdanken habe durch meine
politische Arbeit etwas zurückzugeben
und in diesem Sinne freue ich mich sehr
darauf mit euch zusammen ein neues
politisches Kapitel in Deutschland
aufzuschlagen und danke euch allen sehr
für euer Vertrauen lasst uns gemeinsam
daran arbeiten vielen
[Applaus]
Dank Shervin hin war das noch mal bis zu
Beginn dieses Bundesparteitages muss man
ja korrekterweise sagen der einzige
Stellvertreter von Sarah Wagenknecht
undira Mohammed Ali jetzt hat er
mit und
zwei weitere Stellvertreter dazu
bekommen in diesem Kreis es sind
inzwischen auch es wird inzwischen
ausgezählt ein Wahlgang zu den 12
Beisitzern und zwei Beisitzerinnen also
es geht hier um den erweiterten Vorstand
und bei dieser Gelegenheit und während
dieser auszählungsphase hat sich der
Parteitag eine kleine Mittagspause
gegönnt die geht jetzt noch so 12 13
Minuten sie sehen auch die Reihen sind
noch relativ leer weil sich alles
außerhalb dieses Saales tummelt um ein
wenig zu essen und zu trinken und vor
allem auch zu schwatzen und sich
auszutauschen über das was man hier
bislang gehört und gesehen hat es ist
alles in allem von großer Einigkeit
geprägt unter denen die hier sind für
das Bündnis Sarah wagenknechttis
Abstimmungsergebnisse für die beiden
neuen Stellvertreter 96% 94% das ist
schon relativ eindeutig und es gab im
Grunde fast nach jeder einzelrede hier
stehenden Applaus auch
für die äh jeweiligen Rednerin bzw den
jeweiligen Redner also da steht man
schon sehr geschlossen und es wäre auch
in der Tat etwas kurios wenn man sich
gleich am ersten Bundesparteitag
zerstreiten würde vielleicht auch noch
mal zu diesem Punkt der erste
Bundesparteitag ist das hier es hat
einen gründungs sogenannten
Gründungsparteitag gegeben ja am 8
Januar als sich eine kleine Gruppe von
knapp 40 Mitgliedern des BSW
zusammengefunden hat zusammengeschlossen
hat für diese neue Partei und bei dieser
Gelegenheit sind dann auch die beiden
Parteivorsitz gewählt worden der
Generalsekretär und eben auch eine der
Stellvertreter Schatzmeister und
Bundesgeschäftsführer das sind die
Positionen die aberim 8 Januar schon
vergeben worden sind diese Positionen
werden hier bei diesem ersten
Bundesparteitag nicht bestätigt sondern
man betrachtet das als gesetetzt bzw
auch dem parteigesetz nach als
hinreichend begründet und die
Delegierten die hier sind bei diesem
Bundesparteitag die haben das auch
akzeptiert es wird also hier von einem
eine Bestätigung vor einem größeren
Quorum noch einmal gefordert so dass es
dann in die nächsten ich glaube Z
nächsten in zwei Jahren wird dann wieder
eine Bestätigung dieser Posten fällig
nach dem parteigesetz wie ich hatte
schon gesagt und bzw eben angesprochen
Amira Mohamed Ali kovorsitzende des
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht Vernunft und
Gerechtigkeit und Amira Mohammed Ali
wollen wir jetzt auch noch mal hören mit
ihrer Rede von heute
Vormittag ich begrüße euch alle herzlich
die ihr heute hier seid ich grüße auch
all die vielen Menschen die diesen
parteit von zu Hause od unterwegs übers
Internet oder Fernsehen verfolgen und
die große Hoffnung in unsere neue Partei
setzen viele von ihnen haben sich sicher
bereits als Unterstützer oder Förderer
unserer Partei registriert und ich
möchte jeder und jedem einzelnen von
ihnen ganz herzlich danken die
Unterstützung durch Spenden und der
große Zuspruch in den ersten Monaten
nach der Vereinsgründung und besonders
die Unterstützung seit der
Parteigründung am 8 Januar war und ist
überwältigend liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde mein Dank gilt natürlich auch
allen hier im Saal ihr seid bereit für
unsere Partei Gesicht zu zeigen ihr
macht in diesen stürmischen Zeiten den
Rücken gerade für eine Politik der
wirtschaftlichen Vernunft sozialer
Gerechtigkeit des Friedens und der
Freiheit und es ist schön heute in so
viele mutige und entschlossene Gesichter
zu
blicken
aber einer Person einer Person möchte
ich natürlich ganz besonders danken die
Frau ohne die wir alle heute nicht hier
wären vielen Dank liebe Sarah
Wagenknecht ohne ohne deinen Mut deine
Standhaftigkeit deine meinungsstärke und
deine Fachkompetenz wären wir heute
nicht hier und viele haben im Vorfeld ge
du würdest dich nicht trauen ich glaube
diese Leute haben vor allem Angst gehabt
dass du dich traust weil sie geahnt
haben weil sie geahnt haben was das für
die Parteienlandschaft und für die
eigenen umfrageewwerte bedeuten wird und
ich kann schon verstehen dass die
anderen Parteien besonders die Parteien
der ampelregierung dass die jetzt
langsam richtig nervös werden wenn sie
sehen was wir vorhaben und was für tolle
Leute wir neben dir liebe SAR in unseren
Reihen haben unter uns sind Handwerker
Pflegekräfte Betriebsschlosser Theologen
engagierte Rentnerinnen und Rentner
Musiker Regisseure Schauspieler Ärzte
Hochschulprofessoren Lehrer Unternehmer
Gewerkschafter Polizisten Rechtsanwälte
Profisportler Autoren Wissenschaftler
profilierte kommunal Landes und
Bundespolitiker Menschen aus allen
Bereichen viele waren schon vorher in
einer Partei aktiv in einer anderen
andere sind jetzt zum ersten Mal
Mitglied einer Partei geworden ja liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde
wir sind breit aufgestellt wir kommen
aus der ganzen Breite der Gesellschaft
und wir machen Politik für all
diejenigen deren Interessen in der
herrschenden Politik immer weniger
vorkommen und das ist leider die Breite
der
Gesellschaft
wir wir die wir hier im Kosmos in Berlin
zusammengekommen sind wir tragen eine
große Verantwortung aus den zahlreichen
Zuschriften die mich täglich von
Menschen aus ganz Deutschland erreichen
weiß ich wie hoch die Erwartungen
unserer Partei sind ich weiß auch wie
groß die Sorgen bei vielen sind vor dem
wirtschaftlichen Abstieg und davor dass
Deutschland immer tiefer in
internationale Konflikte und Kriege
hineingezogen wird es ist an uns all
diesen Menschen wieder Hoffnung zu geben
wir sind das Bündnis wir sind die Partei
auf die so viele Menschen in unserem
Land so lange gewartet
haben
und wir wollen wir wollen und wir werden
kein Teil der abgehobenen
selbstgerechten politblase sein in der
man sich über alles Mögliche die Finger
wund twittert und dabei viel zu oft aus
dem Blick verliert wie schlecht es
vielen Menschen in Deutschland
inzwischen
geht die herrschende Politik die
herrschende Politik ist arrogant
geworden und das muss endlich ein Ende
haben und eines ist klar wir werden
unsere Politik nicht nach den Vorgaben
der mächtigsten Konzerne und Lobbys
ausrichten wir werden auch nicht bei
Gegenwind aus den Medien oder sogar aus
den sogenannten sozialen Medien
einknicken wir werden unser Programm
nicht von Stimmungen und meinungsmachen
diktieren lassen als einzige Partei
setzen wir einen Expertenrat ein den wir
bei unserer programmfindung zu Rate
ziehen denn dieses Land braucht nicht
noch mehr ahnungslose von Stimmung
getriebene Politiker ihre Meinung in die
nächste Kamera stammeln nein wir setzen
auf die Menschen die wirklich Ahnung
haben wir setzen auf echte
Fachkompetenz soziale Gerechtigkeit
wirtschaftliche Vernunft Frieden und
Freiheit das sind die Kernthemen unserer
Partei und es sind auch die Bereiche in
denen die Regierung grandios versagt hat
die deutsche Wirtschaft ist im
vergangenen Jahr um 0,3% gestumpft
geschrumpft die Ampel Regierungen
ampelregierung die zuckt die Schultern
und schiebt das auf die vielen Krisen
der vergangenen Jahre aber warum warum
wächst die Wirtschaft in dann in den
meisten anderen Industrieländern diese
Länder müssen n doch mit den gleichen
globalen Krisen umgehen wie Deutschland
aber Deutschland ist schlusslich warum
ist das so na ja Deutschland hat das SAR
hat das in einer bundestagsrede einmal
sehr treffend gesagt weil wir die
dümmste Regierung Europas haben diese
Inkompetenz die Sucht wirklich ihres
gich B ihr bei der Politik dieser Ampel
muss ich immer an das Lied Major Tom von
peter Schilling denken völlig losgelöst
von der Erde fliegt die Bundesregierung
ihrem Raumschiff völlig
schwerelos man sieht das man sieht das
an großen Dingen wie z.B den kopflosen
wirtschaftssanktion man sieht es aber
auch in detail fragen wie z.B dass die
Parteivorsitzende der Grünen tatsächlich
annimmt dass ein Rentner in Deutschland
im Schnitt 2000 € im Monat hat ich meine
wie ahnungslos kann man eigentlich sein
wie weit entfernt vom Alltag der
Menschen eigentlich ich finde es
unglaublich und dann statt sich um die
wirtschaftlichen Probleme um die
sozialen Probleme der Menschen in
Deutschland zu kümmern bringt diese
Bundesregierung eine Zumutung nach der
anderen für die Bevölkerung auf den Weg
das idiotische heizungsgesetz der CO2
Preis die Streichung des agrardiesels
der Erhöhung der Mehrwertsteuer in der
Gastronomie Kürzungen bei der
Rentenkasse im Gesundheitsbereich im
Verbraucherschutz im Bevölkerungsschutz
die Liste der Fehlentscheidungen der
Bundesregierung ist fast so groß wie die
Erinnerungslücken des Bundeskanzlers
beim Steuerskandal um seinen guten
Bekannten bei der
warburgbank und all diese Dinge all
diese Dinge geh werden gegen den wählen
der Bevölkerung einfach durchgeprügelt
kein Wunder dass immer mehr Menschen
ihren Unmut auch auf die Straße tragen
zuletzt die Landwirte Lkw-Fahrer
Gastronomen Handwerker und andere haben
das gemacht viele Menschen sind wütend
und das zurecht die Antwort der
Regierungsparteien auf diesem Protest
ist leider so unbeholfen wie die
Regierungspolitik selbst so oft heißt es
oh der Protest sei rechts unter wandert
und da sein doch auch Rechte mitgelaufen
ich erinnere mich da wirklich an die
große Friedenskundgebung beim
brandenburgour ist heute schon erwähnt
worden es war vor gut einem Jahr oder
vor knapp einem Jahr als diejenigen die
für Frieden und Diplomatie aufgestanden
sind damals als putinnechte und
rechtsoffen beschimpft wurden ich war
auch auf der Kundgebung und ich muss
sagen es empört mich immer wieder wenn
kritische Meinung um sie klein zu machen
einfach mal als rechtsradikal oder
rechtsoffen diearmiert werden und alle
die das tun alle die das tun die müssen
wissen dass sie genau damit den
Rechtsextremisten helfen und die
Gesellschaft weiterpalten ist
unverantwortlich und das ist die
Wahrheit
eine eine offene Debatte ist in diesem
Klima der angeblichen politischen
Korrektheit oft nicht mehr möglich und W
angestellt oder g im öffentlichen Dienst
beschäftigt ist der muss auch immer
öfter mit ernsthaften Konsequenzen
rechnen wenn er eine abweichende Meinung
hat und die auch kund tut und dagegen
stehen wir auf statt kindischchen
dauerbeleidigt sein wollen wir eine
erwachsene politische Kultur in der
Mensch frei miteinander reden und in der
das bessere Argument gewinnt so müsste
es nämlich
sein liebe Freundinnen und Freunde wir
das Bündnis sarer Wagenknecht Vernunft
und Gerechtigkeit sind die seriöser
Adresse für alle Menschen die sich
schlecht regiert fühlen wir sind die
Partei die sich mit Herz und Verstand
für all diejenigen einsetzt die täglich
spüren dass ihre harte Arbeit nicht
vernünftig gewürdigt wird deren Leben
durch politische Fehlentscheidungen
immer härter und schwieriger und teurer
wird wir bringen Sachverstand und
Vernunft in das Chaos der deutschen
Parteienlandschaft und liebe Freundin
und
Freunde es liegt an uns von diesem
Parteitag ein klares Signal der Stärke
und der Einigkeit auszusenden ich freue
mich auf den heutigen Parteitag mit euch
und auf einen kraftvollen europagal
Wahlkampf mit unseren tollen
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten packen wir
es an vielen Dank für die
[Applaus]
Aufmerksamkeit Amira Mohammed Ali war
das noch mal heute Vormittag hat Amira
Mohammed Ali war das noch einmal mit
ihrer Rede von heute Vormittag mit der
sie die Delegierten hier begrüßt hat im
Kosmos in der Kosmos Event Location
ehemaliges Kino die
cooparteivorsitzende des Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht und wir nutzen die
Gelegenheit weil es hier zwar gongt wie
im Kino wie sich das gehört aber eben
noch Pause gewesen ist das haben sie
übrigens gerade gesehen den Kollegen
Köster von der heuteshow am Werk da wird
wieder allerlei schabernackbei
rauskommen am kommenden Freitag dann
sind wir ziemlich sicher und was wollte
ich eigentlich sagen es ist ja
eigentlich noch Mittagspause angezeigt
die jetzt in dieser Minute zu Ende sein
soll aber ich höre von verlässlichen
oder ausverlässlichen Quellen das in den
Gängen rund um diesen Saal hier noch gut
gegessen und getrunken wird das wird
sich sicherlich ein klein wenig
verzögern deswegen zeigen wir Ihnen noch
mal die Rede von für suikat
Bundesschatzmeister ist er ja beim
Bündnis SAR
Wagenknecht
Millionär zu Millionär geworden durch
eine Softwarefirma deren Anteil er aber
verkauft hat und eben dadurch Z
Millionär geworden ist seitdem lebt er
vom eigenen Vermögen und engiert sich
wie er sagt für ein faires und
zukunftsfähiges Wirtschaftssystem das
hat er auch in seiner Rede angesprochen
hier heute Vormittag und diese Rede
zeigen wir Ihnen noch mal und dann geht
es anschließend auch hier garantiert im
Saal weiter
der Mensch ist stark wenn er verbunden
ist das spüren wir heute hier und das
hat vor über 200 Jahren schon Wolfgang
Johann Wolfgang von Goethe gesagt liebe
Freundin und Freunde heute am 27 januar
stehen wir hier im Kosmos Berlin um uns
miteinander zu verbinden um gemeinsam
scherin hat gesagt ein neues Kapitel auf
zu schlagen ein Kapitel das nicht nur
die Geschichte unserer neugegründeten
Partei prägt sondern auch weitreiche
Auswirkungen auf unsere Gesellschaft
haben
wird Kosmos das klingt nicht nur
irgendwie schön es bedeutet auch die uns
umgebende Welt
bezeichnenderweise ist Kosmos aber auch
der Gegenbegriff zum Chaos
woanderst als hier können wir also
beginnen gemeinsam das Chaos aufzuräumen
dass die Ampel und 16 Jahre lang CDU
geführte Regierung hinterlassen
haben wir treten hier und heute an um
gemeinsam das Land zusammenzuführen
auskömmliche Arbeitsverhältnisse zu
schaffen Schuldächer zu reparieren
Bahnstrecken zu
sanieren wenn Spaltung und Konflikt die
Welt beherrschen liegt eine unserer
zentralen Aufgaben darin eine Vision zu
schaffen eine Vision von der Welt in der
wir leben
wollen diese Vision möchten wir
gemeinsam mit euch kreieren und zusammen
mit den Menschen in unserem Land in die
Welt
bringen wir möchten das Gefühl der
Gemeinsamkeit und Verbundenheit wieder
erlebbar machen
Verbundenheit bedeutet sich für die
Rechte und Freiheiten eines jeden
Einzelnen
einzusetzen
Verbundenheit bedeutet aber auch das
Verbindende in den Mittelpunkt zu
stellen nicht das Trennende zu
suchen es bedeutet auch Liebe über den
Hass zu stellen so schwer dass auch in
einer spezifischen Situation ein ums
andere Mal sein
mag der Verbundenheit funktioniert das
Wirtschaftssystem nicht für einige
wenige sondern für
alle liebe Freundinnen und Freunde ich
war ein
ampelwähler heute sind nur noch 8% der
Bevölkerung mit der Regierung zufrieden
das ein absoluter historischer
Tiefstand die M ist klar
lehnen eine ideologiebasierte Politik
ab die Konsequenzen sehen und erleben
wir jeden Tag immer mehr Menschen
verlieren den Glauben an die Politik sie
wenden sich ab sie resignieren sie gehen
gar nicht mehr wählen oder Sie wenden
sich aus Protest einer Partei zu deren
Werte sie eigentlich nicht ansz Weise
vertreten für mich als Unternehmer wurde
es immer unerträglicher der Ampel beim
Regierung zuzuschauen und das nicht nur
wegen der wirtschaftsfeindlichen Inhalte
ich finde insbesondere auch die Art und
Weise wie über die Bürger hinweg regiert
wird mittlerweile
unerträglich
die Ampel hat mich
politisiert das BSW ist zu meiner
persönlichen zu unser aller politischen
Heimat
geworden mir persönlich ist es wichtig
dass das BSW zu einer Anlaufstelle der
Zuversicht wird eine Anlaufstelle die
Menschen in unserem Land die daran
glauben dass ein anderes ein
funktionierendes ein besseres
Deutschland möglich ist aufsuchen
können eine
Anlaufstelle für Menschen die sich eine
Regierung wünschen die ihre Sorgen und
Nöte ernst nimmt eine Anlaufstelle für
Unternehmer die sich in ihrem Kampf
gegen Bürokratie und steigende
Energiepreise Unterstützung
wünschen eine Anlaufstelle vor allem
aber auch für all diejenigen die
gemeinsam mit uns Politik gestalten
wollen wir stehen heute nicht nur als
Mitglieder einer neugegründeten Partei
sondern auch als Gemeinschaft die für
eine bessere Zukunft kämpft eine Zukunft
in der soziale Gerechtigkeit
wirtschaftliche Vernunft Frieden und
Freiheit nicht nur Worte sondern das
solide Fundament un uns Gesellschaft
werden lasst uns die Zuversicht die
heute hier im Raum zu spüren ist
mitnehmen in unsere Familien an unsereer
Arbeitsstellen lasst sie uns ins ganze
Land tragen und lasst uns die Botschaft
aussenden Deutschland kann dank euch
[Applaus]
Geraschel ich hö nur Geraschel da sind
wir wieder live im Kosmos in Berlin
Friedrichs Hein und es wird vom
tagungspräsidium gerade erläutert wie es
weitergeht Patrick Wahl hat das Wort und
sobald wir da ordnungsgemäß reingehört
haben sage ich auch Ihnen wie es
weitergeht für den Vorsitz von Professor
Dr Hans hmeier
vor und ich frage jetzt gibt es weitere
Kandidaturen möchte noch jemand hier für
die für eine der beiden schiedskammern
kandidieren das sehe ich nicht insofern
würde ich vorschlagen dass wir die Liste
jetzt schließen und bitte jeden der
damit einverstanden ist dass wir die
Liste schließen um das entsprechende
Kartenzeichen okay danke schön ich h im
Moment gibt es Gegenstimmen nicht
Enthaltungen das sehe ich
nicht dann
m dann ist die dann ist die Liste
hiermit geschlossen im Vorfeld wurde mir
signalisiert dass alle der eben
genannten Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten
bereits beim tagungspräsidium angezeigt
haben auf eine Bewerbungsrede und einer
Vorstellung zu verzichten da ja alle
Bewerbungen schriftlich vorliegen ich Fr
Frage jetzt noch mal an die
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten bleibt ihr
dabei oder möchtet ihr die Vorstellung
machen also wenn ihr die Vorstellung
machen möchtet dann bitte jetzt das
Handzeichen oder aufstehen damit ich das
sehe und damit ihr dann noch vorkommen
könnt das ist nicht der Fall ich stelle
fest die Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten
verzichten auf eine Vorstellung so meine
Damen und Herren jetzt haben wir das
alles verstanden was hier passiert das
ist hier Brot beim Parteitag so gehört
das bei allen dazu und jetzt sind wir
halten gerade mal m reingeraten in eine
solche Situation es ging um die Liste
für die Schiedskommission die wurde
jetzt vervollständig abgeschlossen man
hat darüber befunden dass sich die
Kandidaten und Kandidaten hier nicht
gesondert vorstellen wollen weil sie
sich ja schon in vorstellungsschreiben
die
den Parteitagsdelegierten hier vorliegen
schon wie gesagt vorliegen das ganze in
Schrift Form da muss man das nicht noch
mal von der Bühne machen zumal der
parteit ein klein wenig in verzuch
geraten ist aber in relativ
übersichtlichen bahnen muss man dazu
sagen für einen Gründungsparteitag wird
ja ein relativ hartes Regiment geführt
so dass es noch nicht aus geufert ist
was die Zeit angeht aber wir wollen
natürlich noch mal kein wenig
analysieren unter anderem die Rede von
SAR Wagenknecht und deshalb geht es
jetzt erstmal mit Mark steinuser weiter
vielen Dank er sch an uns soll nicht
liegen wir behalten natürlich den
Parteitag im Blick mit Julia ruschenbach
von der Freien Universität Berlin
Politikwissenschaftlerin schauen wir
noch mal ein bisschen auf die
Redebeiträge vor allen Dingen auf die
Rede von Sarah Wagenknecht die Ampel
abgehoben die Ampel die dümmste
Regierung Europas die Wortwahl von Sara
Wagenknecht heftig wie ist ihre
Wahrnehmung was hier diese Sprache auch
betrifft die wir heute hören von der
Parteivorsitzenden na ja grundsätzlich
ist nicht wird sich daran messen lassen
müssen dass sie einerseits sozusagen die
anderen zu einem guten Miteinander zu
einer Versachlichung der Debatte zu mehr
Vernunft ja auffordert auch im Namen des
bündnises wohl gemerkt und andererseits
dann auch stark ausgeteilt hat mir macht
weniger Sorge wenn ich ehrlich bin das
ausgeteilt wird das gehört bei
Parteitagen dazu das erleben wir auch
bei anderen Parteien das sind ja reden
die auch einen Effekt haben sollen nach
innen sie sollen die eigenen Mitglieder
in diesem Fall die auch noch ne sind im
einschwören sie sollen Zusammenhalt und
Gemeinschaft Bekunden ein bisschen nach
außen Akzente setzen was mir deutlich
mehr sorgemcht ist die Frage wie viel
Populismus steckt denn eigentlich in
diesen Aussagen wenn sie sozusagen diese
Idee formuliert von dem Establishment
von den abgehobenen das hat sie etwa
über Ricarda lang gesagt sie hat im
Zusammenhang mit Robert habbeck von
grünen Großstadt Lofts gesprochen also
auch so typische Bilder bedient man muss
dazu sagen rarderang wusste nicht wie
hoch die Durchschnittsrente ist genaun
man sagen das ist nicht gut das würde
ich auch so sehen
diese Fehler sind auch anderen
Politikern in Jahrzehnten Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik schon passiert auch das
war nicht gut aber die spannende Frage
ist ja dann ein Stück weit auch wenn man
sich Sarah Wagenknecht anschaut die mit
Nebeneinkünften meines Wissens um die
700 000 € im Jahr
mit ihrem Buch beispielsweise Verdienste
erwirtschaftet hat ob man nicht auch
fragen kann okay inwiefern ist sie denn
selber auch Teil dieser Elite dieses
Establishments und damit sozusagen
dieser Gegensatz auch nicht so stark den
sie t zu konstruieren und dieses wir
gegen die dieses ausspielen und das auch
sozusagen reklamieren dass man selber
jetzt als BSW sozusagen das wahre Volk
die einfachen Leute vertrete sie hat ja
der Politik beispielsweise wirklich
vorgeworfen gegen die Bevölkerung
Politik zu machen also als sei das
wissentlich beabsichtigt das sind eher
die Passagen in der Rede die mir in der
Sprache in der Frage der politischen
Auseinandersetzung Sorge machen und dann
haben wir ja noch gar nicht über die in
halte der Rede gesprochen das wäre
sozusagen dann der zweite Schritt gute
Überleitung vielen Dank für diese
Überleitung muss ich weniger arbeiten
hier wenn wir auf die Inhalte der Rede
schauen fällt ja auf dass hier in diesem
alten Kinosaal der größte Applaus immer
dann kam wenn es um die Friedenspolitik
ging wenn es darum ging auch wie man den
Krieg in der Ukraine beendet sei mal
dahingestellt mit welchen Ideen und
Konzepten auch in den Gesprächen die ja
unsere Kollegin Julia Grimm hier geführt
hat mit den Parteimitgliedern ging es
sehr viel um die Friedenspolitik ist das
der Kit der dieses Bündnis zusammenhält
abseits von der Person Sarah Wagenknecht
na ja es ist zumindest interessant dass
wir da jetzt über den Tag heute wirklich
dass sich wie so ein roter Faden durch
die Redebeiträge zieht und zwar wirklich
vom ersten an jetzt bis zur Rede von
Sara Wagenknecht selbst es ist ein Thema
von dem wir wissen dass es in der
Gesellschaft für viele Kontroversen
gesorgt hat es ist viel darüber
diskutiert worden ob mit alljenen die
insbesondere zu Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine
zögerlich waren mit Blick auf
Waffenlieferung und die Frage inwiefern
sich Deutschland dort engagieren soll ob
diese Stimmen ausreichend zu hören
gewesen sind ich glaube da ist selbst
kritische Reflektion durchaus ein
wichtiger Punkt wir konnten das auch
sehen in Meinungsumfragen beispielsweise
wo das deutlich wurde m aber zur
Wahrheit gehört natürlich auch sie haben
es auch im Gespräch mit Frau Wagenknecht
und Herrn Ernst eben thematisiert die
Frage danach wie glaubwürdig sind denn
diese Forderungen sind diese Ideen die
hier ja jetzt nun programmatisch
formuliert werden und was ich schon
spannend finde wir haben in den letzten
Wochen seitdem klar ist dass es das
bündniswagenknecht geben wird od Sara
Wagenknecht geben wird viel darüber
geredet inwiefern z.B ihre
migrationskritische Haltung inwiefern
diese spannende Kombination aus
wirtschaftspolitisch linken
soziokulturell eher rechten Positionen
spannend sein kann und dabei ist dieses
ganze Thema Frieden Antiamerikanismus
Anti Imperialismus vielleicht ein Stück
weit doch in den Hintergrund geraten und
gerade in Ostdeutschland wo ja jetzt nun
mal im Herbst drei Wahlen anstehen halte
ich es nicht für abwegig dass das ein
Thema sein kann dass am Ende Menschen
dann eher zum Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht
treibt als z.B die migrationskritik die
womöglich eben bei anderen wir haben
schon drüber gesprochen wie der AFD auch
zu finden wäre man muss an dieser Stelle
dazu sagen dass die Unterstützung der
Ukraine auch mit Waffenlieferung ja in
den vergangenen ja zwei Jahren auch
immer Mehrheiten hatte in der deutschen
Bevölkerung auch wenn die hier und da
abgenommen haben aber das war ja schon
auch eine Position die viele Deutsche
geteilt haben wie Deutschland da
vorgegangen ist mit Blick auch auf das
was jetzt hier formuliert worden ist im
Vergleich zur AFD ist es aus ihrer Sicht
zulässig diese Vergleiche zu ziehen es
gibt ja in der Migrationsfrage auch in
diesem antiestablishment in der Rhetorik
gibt es ja durchaus vergleichbare
Momente auf der anderen Seite wird auch
immer gesagt nein nein also die AFD ähm
damit haben wir gar nichts zu tun wie
sehen Sie das also wenn man die Rede von
sarabank nicht zum Maßstab nimmt sie hat
sich da klar positioniert sie hat gesagt
sie halilt die Sorge derer die jetzt in
den letzten Tagen und Wochen gegen
Rechtsextremismus auf den Straßen waren
sie hat Björn höcke als Faschisten als
Nazi bezeichnet ähm ich sehe jetzt
zumindest aktuell keinen Grund ihr
abzusprechen dass sie als Demokratin
hier sozusagen auch gegen
Rechtsextremismus aufgetreten ist aber
was wir auch gesehen haben ist dass sie
natürlich weiß und zumindest erste
Untersuchung deuten das ja auch an dass
in der AFD Wählerschaft für sie ein
durchaus gewichtiges Wählerpotenzial zu
finden ist und da war die Rede dann doch
ein ja auch vielleicht ein rhetorisches
wirklich spannendes analysestück denn
sie hat ja unter anderem auch betont
dass sie sagt die Wählerinnen und Wähler
der AFD sind nicht rechtsextrem sie hat
im Grunde versucht eine Erzählung zu
zeigen dass sie Verständnis hat für
diese Menschen für ihren Protest dass
das im Grunde mehrheitlich Menschen sein
die sich schlecht regiert fühlen also
sie hat es so ein bisschen ich würde
sagen geöffnet an der Stelle ohne dass
sie deshalb
migrationsfeindliche Positionen oder
dergleichen vertreten hätte in ihrer
Rede das war nicht raushörbar
und insofern ist spannend an der Stelle
natürlich überzeugt das kann sie damit
Wählerinnen und Wähler an der Stelle
womöglich gewinnen äh wir wissen dass es
unter der AFD Anhängerschaft tatsächlich
auch Protestwähler gibt Menschen die aus
Unmut der AFD ihre Stimme geben würden
aber wir wissen eben auch dass zunehmend
akzeptiert ist dass die Partei also dass
man sich am Rechtsextremismus innerhalb
der Reihen der AFD nicht stört ähm dass
das
sozusagen einfach mitgenommen wird ja
und ähm ich glaube den Punkt hat sie
sehr galant umschifft in ihrer Rede um
im Grunde da auch wenig Angriffsfläche
zu bieten wenigst wenigst wenig
Angriffsfläche aber viel Angriff muss
man ja sagen äh wenn man jetzt auf die
Wahlen in diesem Jahr schaut da ist die
Europawahl im Juni dann drei
Landtagswahlen in Ostdeutschland im
September wie sehen sie diese Lage es
gibt manche die waren jetzt vor einer
Zersplitterung des Parteiensystems die
sagen sogar
Meinungsforschungsinstitute auch die
sagen das könnte auch dazu führen dass
man Art Weimarer Verhältnisse bekäme das
eine Äußerung von dem Forsa Chef auf der
anderen Seite gibt's andere die sagen na
ja es könnte auch sein dass Frau
Wagenknecht und ihr Bündnis in gewisser
Weise auch mit diesen populistischen
Tönen die Demokratie retten weil sie
Mehrheiten jenseits der AFD im Osten
ermöglichen liegt die Wahrheit in der
Mitte oder wie könnte das in diesem Jahr
zu betrachten sein wenn ich das wüsste
wä ich wahrscheinlich nicht nur bei
Ihnen eine viel gefragte Frau das S Fall
ich glaube wir müssen differenzieren
also bei der Europawahl sehen wir ja
müssen wir noch mal mehr sozusagen im
europäischen Vergleich schauen da gibt
es jetzt zahlen die andeuten es könnte
in vielen Ländern tatsächlich ein starke
ein Erstarken der rechtsextrem und
rechtspopulistischen Kräfte geben wie
wir es übrigens bei der Europawahl auch
2014 schon mal erlebt haben wir wissen
dass die Europawahl so ein bisschen als
nachgeordnete Wahl lange galt für viele
Menschen also dass man sie als weniger
wichtig empfunden hat als nationale
Wahlen wir wissen auch dass sie so eine
Art Denkzettel chararakter hatte dass
Menschen also bei der Europawahl
häufiger auch mal bereit waren den
nationalen Regierungen und den
zugehörigen Parteien eins auszuwischen
auch vielleicht mal kleinere oder
extremere Parteien zu wählen ich würde
mich nicht festlegen wollen ob man schon
sicher sagen kann dass das in diesem
Jahr so eintreten wird aber es gibt auf
jeden Fall die Befürchtung
an dieser Stelle und mit Blick auf das
Bündnis Wagenknecht ist natürlich die
spannende Frage wo würde sich denn ein
solches Bündnis dann einsortieren in den
fraktionsformationen des Europäischen
Parlamentes etwa und wenn wir noch kurz
auf Ostdeutschland schauen dann glaube
ich ist das eine ganz andere Diskussion
weil wir ja da in der Tat auch über die
Frage reden ob überhaupt
parlamentarische Mehrheitsbildung
Regierungsbildung möglich sein wird und
da hängt beim Bündnis Wagenknecht für
mich vor allem die Frage daran ob es
denn überhaupt gelingen wird tatsächlich
drei Landesverbände aufzubauen und dort
antreten zu können bei den Wahlen den
man muss ja auch da dazu sagen Sarah
Wagenknecht wird ja nun vermutlich nicht
in Thüringen zur Landtagswahl antreten
aber das wissen wir zumindest jetzt noch
nicht es ist zu vermuten dass da andere
aufgestellt werden könnten mit diesem
Namen dann sag Wagenknecht das gibt ja
auch bisher so eigentlich nicht in der
deutschen
Parteienlandschaft haben Sie den
Eindruck dass sich da auch was bewegt in
der deutschen Parteienlandschaft
Stichwort Zersplitterung Stichwort auch
Änderung unseres politischen Systems
macht das nicht am Ende sogar
schwieriger wenn es sich noch mehr
zergliedert na ja ich würde schon sagen
grundsätzlich ist ja ein Parteiensystem
ist ein Abbild von Gesellschaft und von
dem was gesellschaftlich bei uns
passiert wen wir sehen haben wir in den
Letten Jahren wir
individualisierungsprozesse erleben dass
wir was vielfach auch von kollegenen und
Kollegen aus der Soziologie beschrieben
wurde dass so große Anker Kirchen
Gewerkschaften Parteien eben nicht mehr
gesellschaftlich sozusagen so so in die
Breite wirken können dann ist natürlich
das neue Entstehen von Parteien aus
meiner Sicht erstmal wenig verwunderlich
und darf ein auch nicht per se besorgen
sondern es ist ein upbild dessen was in
unserer Gesellschaft passiert aber die
Frage die sie damit natürlich auch
adressieren ist eben die ob in Thüringen
beispielsweise überhaupt noch möglich
ist am Ende Mehrheiten zu finden und
wenn ich noch einen Satz auf diese
Personalisierung verwenden darf dann
haben wir ja da momentan ein ganz
spannendes Beispiel wir haben mit Bodo
ramelo von der Linken einen überaus
beliebten Ministerpräsidenten von dem
sich auch viele wünschen dass er als
Person weiter im Amt bliebe wir haben
aber eine Partei die Linke die deutlich
weniger Zuspruch findet und da könnte
die doch vielleicht auch paradoxe
Situation entstehen dass ein Bodo ramelo
um herauszukommen aus dem
minderheitsmodus den er gegenwärtig in
Thüringen erlebt womöglich dann über
eine Zusammenarbeit mit einem Bündnis
Sara Wagenknecht nachdenken müsste die
ja maßgeblich für die Schwierigkeiten
seiner eigenen Partei mit verantwortlich
ist und das sind natürlich schon sehr
komplexe Verhältnisse die man auch
erstmal erklären muss damit gerade jene
die nicht den ganzen Tag über Politik
nachdenken nachvollziehen können worum
es da eigentlich geht sagt Julia
rollchenbach die uns beim Erklären und
beim Verstehen hier sehr hilft vielen
Dank für diese Analysen hier bei Phönix
wir sprechen gleich noch mal werden
jetzt aber noch mal einen Blick in
diesen Saal werfen die Mittagspause die
wir angesprochen haben die ist jetzt
hier vorbei und es wird noch ein
bisschen weiter gewählt wir werden aber
auch noch mal ein bisschen darauf
schauen wer sich hier eigentlich so
umtreibt wer sind diese 450 Mitglieder
die gemeinsam mit Sarah Wagenknecht
diese neue Partei jetzt Formen Julia
Grimm mit einem weiteren gesprächsgast
ganz genau und ich knie mich mal hier
ein bisschen runter bis jetzt weiß ich
nur der Junge her kommt aus Sachsen
vielle vi sagen Sie uns einmal wer sie
sind und was treibt sie ins Bündnis
sarwag ich bin Mike schwarz ich komme
aus dem fugtland und das ist Saen
Sachsen genau Südwestsachsen um genau zu
sein und ich war bis zum Jahreswechsel
auch Mitglied in der Linken habe mich
aber dort seit Jahren nicht mehr so
richtig wohl gefühlt weil einfach der
Abstand zwischen dem Wähler und dem
Bürger und der Partei immer größer
geworden ist man hat eine elfenbeinpitik
gemacht am Ende und ich bin die Linken
oder die Regierung die Linken die
Regierung sowieso aber selbst die le als
hätte sie hätte die Chance gehabt als
Opposition dort dagegen zu halten und
hat diese Chance nicht genutzt und
deswegen war ich froh dass S sich dann
zum 8 Januar hin entschieden hat die
Partei zu gründen mit den anderen
Mitstreitern und für mich stand dann
außer Frage dass ich sofort zu beginnen
gleich mit eintret wenn Sie einen Punkt
nennen müssten der Ihnen besonders
wichtig ist welcher ist das der in
dieser Partei ist der in der anderen
Partei nicht eigentlich sind zwei also
Frieden und soziale Gerechtigkeit sind
für mich aber Dinge die Hand in Hand
gehen also es gibt keinen sozialen
Frieden ohne soziale Gerechtigkeit und
letztendlich wenn der Frieden fehlt ist
am Ende alles nichts ich danke Ihnen mal
und rutsche ein bisschen hier rüber wenn
das geht so jetzt sagen Sie mir einmal
wer sie sind und woher sie herkommen und
seit wann und warum sind sie im
bündnisarwag nicht drei Fragen mein Name
ist Uta Knebel ich komme aus Risa wo man
Mal Weltmeister geworden ist warum bin
ich bei Sara Wagenknecht weil viele
Inhalte eigentlich meine Inhalte schon
lange sind Bildung dieses bundesweite
einheitliche Bildungsprogramm
Kindertagesstätten sollten frei von
Kosten sein weil es ist frühkindliche
Bildung und Bildung steht eigentlich bei
uns im Gesetz ist
kostenfrei und seit wann ich bin seit
dem 8 seit dem 8 Januar logisch und bin
am 8 Dezember letzten Jahres bei der
Linken ausgetreten sie kommen aus
Sachsen da sind in diesem Jahr
Landtagswahlen und wenn man sich
anschaut wie da die bisherigen
Umfrageergebnisse sind dann
interess W Ben eigentlich stimmen
weg also ich denke was ganz wichtig ist
die Nichtwähler zu erreichen weil wir
haben immerhin eine ganz geringe
wbeteilige bei uns in Sachsen bei uns in
der Heimatstadt war z.B so dass wir nur
54% der Wähler erreicht haben und das
muss ich ändern wie vi
AFD wie viele haben AFD gewäht Wien sie
ganz viele weil wir haben von sind s AFD
aber sind auch fün linke darf man auch
nicht vergessen können denn die Menschen
die AFD gewählt haben bündnar
Wagenknecht
wählen ich denke mal es kann jeder die
SAR Wagenknecht wählen also unser
Bündnis wählen ist das ein Angebot das
sozusagen die Frage ne ist das ein
Angebot an die Wähler die vorher
gefrustete vielleicht auch
AFD auf jeden Fall ist es ein Angebot
auch an diese Wähler aber nicht nur an
diese
Wähler ört da geht es auch um die Frage
nach Neuwahlen das wird ja auch spannend
werden Regierungsbündnisse mit wem
könnte denn z.B in
Sachsen jetzt gehen wiron aus dass da
funktioniert mit dem Landesverband und
dass da wirklich Wahlen dann auch
stattfinden bei dem diese Partei
mitmacht gehen wir mal davon aus die
kommen über 5% mit wem könnte denn diese
neue Partei
koalieren also über Koalitionsfragen
möchte ich heute überhaupt nichts sagen
einfach erstmal reinkommen in Landtag zu
sehen wie stark man ist und eigene
Programme vonansetzen und richt auch
nicht gegen Minderheitenregierung wenn
wir so viel Stimme holen würden vielen
Dank und ich rutsche noch einen weiter
wenn das funktioniert genau das ist sehr
sehr nett von ihnen genau kann ich mich
sogar hinsetzen wer sind sie sie kommen
auch aus Sachsen ja ich bin mein Name
ist ich komme ebenso aus Rieser ich bin
mit der uda Knebel zusammen in der
Fraktion die vorher die Linke war jetzt
hatten wir uns Ende letzten Jahres dazu
entschlossen die fraktionben UN zubennen
in Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit ja also
ich bin seit 10 Jahren also 10 Jahre in
der Linken gewesen und hatte eigentlich
den Entschluss gefasst jetzt mit Ende
der Legislatur mit der Politik
aufzuhören weil ich mich eben nicht mehr
richtig repräsentiert gefühlt habe auch
in der Linken also meine Meinung war da
nicht mehr so zu Hause aber jetzt mit
dem mit der Neugründung der BSW muss ich
sagen habe ich wieder eine Chance dass
es wieder weitergeht in Land se ich
wieder eine Chance ich danke ihn sehr
herzlich ich muss jetzt hier Schluss
machen weil mein Kollege Mark
Steinhäuser am Set einen spannenden
Gesprächspartner hat vielen Dank Julia
grim ja wir sprechen mit einem der hier
ein bisschen jetzt in diesem Jahr
organisieren wird müssen was diese
Partei vor sich hat der Generalsekretär
Christian Leier ist bei uns willkommen
bei Phönix Herr lei ein Generalsekretär
muss ja traditionell Wahlkämpfe
organisieren deshalb die Frage treten
sie denn jetzt bei allen Wahlen in
diesem Jahr an na ja klar ist erstmal
dass wir zur Europawahl antreten wir
werden heute hier unsere Europaliste
wählen das europaprogramm beschließen
das ist klar zur Europawahl treten wir
an dann haben wir drei Landtagswahlen im
Osten unser Ziel ist es tatsächlich dort
anzutreten das ist der Wille das der
Wunsch das haben wir auch klar
kommuniziert wir haben aber auch immer
gesagt wir sind eine junge Partei es
gibt uns jetzt seit wenigen Wochen und
wir sind noch im Aufbau das heißt wir
treten dann an wenn wir vorbereitet sind
der will aber ist da und wir machen da
ruhige Schritte vor schnellen ruhige
Schnitte Schritte vor schnellen was
fehlt denn noch fehlt das Geld oder
fehlt das Personal na ja also
klar ist wir sind finanziell die
Underdogs in diesem Wahljahr das ist so
wie es ist da braucht man keine Blumen
dran binden wir haben signifikant
weniger Geld zu Verfügung als andere
Parteien die schon etabliert sind das
ist klar natürlich ist das eine
Engstelle
ein zweiter Punkt ist ein verlässliches
Personal gute Leute da sind wir auf
einem guten Weg ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir da in uns in die
richtige Richtung bewegen aber wir
kommen dann mit unseren Punkten an die
Öffentlichkeit wenn wir uns sortiert
haben dafür ist es noch zu früh okay
dann halten wir zumindest fest ist es
noch nicht klar ob sie bei allen
Landtagswahlen in diesem Jahr antreten
ob wir bei allen Landtagswahlen antreten
ja also wir haben wir haben jetzt inten
jetzt in Thüringen entwickeln sich die
Sachen sehr gut da hatten wir jetzt ja
auch mit Katja Wolf
hatten wir noch mal eine prominente
Persönlichkeit von vort die das ganze
Projekt unterstützt auch weitere gute
Leute sind dabei in Thüringen wächst das
Team gut auch in den anderen
Bundesländern aber die finale
Entscheidung teilen wir mit wenn es
soweit ist wir sind gespannt darauf in
jedem Fall ist es jetzt so dass sie hier
ja heute den ersten Bundesparteitag
machen sie haben ja auch hier eine Rede
gehalten als
Generalsekretär nun stellt man sich ja
dann die Frage wenn Sie das so groß
aufziehen wie das heute hier von statten
geht was ist sozusagen das was sie am
Ende dieses Jahres erreicht haben wollen
manche reden von Regierungsbeteiligung
aber sie lassen ja auch an jedem der in
diesem Land regiert kein gutes Haar
wollen Sie wirklich regieren am Ende des
Jahres
na ja Ende des Jahres bezieht sich dann
ja auf die auf die auf eine mögliche
Regierungsbeteiligung in den
Bundesländern das wäre dann ja die
konkrete Frage ich denke dass wir
grundsätzlich bereit sind auch
Regierungsverantwortung zu übernehmen
das auch müssen aber nicht bereit sind
uns zu verbiegen nur damit wir Leute in
Ministerposten heben dafür sind wir
sicherlich nicht bereit davon gibt's
schon genug andere Parteien sondern wir
wollen eine Politik machen mit klarer
Kante die wieder das aufgreift was viele
Menschen in der Bevölkerung auch spüren
und natürlich wollen wir das auch in
einer Regierung umsetzen aber nicht um
jeden Preis eine Regierung ist nie ein
selbstfg was wärden so die wichtigsten
Punkte wo sie sagen das müsste wirklich
passieren in Thüringen damit wir da
mitmachen also das wären so unsere zwei
drei Punkte ohne die wird es nicht
möglich sein dass man das BSW an den
Kabinettstisch kriegt na ja wir haben
heute erstmal unseren bundesparteit ich
werde jetzt solchen zentralen
Entscheidungen in Thüringen jetzt nicht
vorgreifen das sie haben ja auch Inhalte
genannt also was wären die wichtigsten
für Thüringen für Thüringen tatsächlich
oder für unsere Landes Landtagswahlen
die möglicherweise dann auf uns zuk
kommen da müssen wir ja erstmal
sozusagen mit dem mit dem
Landtagswahlprogramm an die Presse gehen
an die Öffentlichkeit und das diesen
Schritten will ich noch nicht vorgreifen
deswegen sozusagen da jetzt Haltelinien
zu formulieren ist heute zu früh aber
klar gehen wir mit Inhalten rein soziale
Gerechtigkeit Frieden Freiheit Vernunft
das sind die Sachen mit denen wir mit
dem wir ein politisches Angebot
unterbreiten und da sehen wir auch eine
Lücke Parteiensystem die wir schließen
wollen nun kann man in Thüringen in
einer Landesregierung ja nicht die
Renten erhöhen oder Waffenlieferung
stoppen also was würden Sie dann bei
einer Landtagswahl fordern oder wofür
stehen sie dann für die Menschen dort im
Land noch mal ich halte das für
unprofessionell heute heute ein
Landtagswahlprogramm auf dem Weg zu
bringen oder hier in der Presse zu
verkünden bevor das ordentlich mit
unseren eigenen Leuten abgesprochen ist
deswegen wir werden sicherlich unser
kernprofil nämlich Gerechtigkeit Frieden
Freiheit und Vernunft auch in einem
Landtagswahlprogramm wiederfinden also
die die der k unsere Partei wird auch
dort wiederzufinden sein dass es sich
wirklich was verbessert für die Menschen
for aber was ist genauus wo die
Schwerpunkte sind das besprechen wir
dann wenn der Tag soweit ist dann greife
ich das insofern jetzt mal auf dann
blicken wir auf die Europawahl wo sie
auf jeden Fall sagen dass sie antreten
und wo heute das Wahlprogramm besprochen
und dann beschlossen wird das ist ein
Programm was ja schon als Entwurf
vorliegt da kritisieren sie die EU in
vielen Punkten sie wollen aber schon an
den Institutionen der EU an dem
Parlament an der Kommission an dem
Verfahren wie abgestimmt wird in der EU
da wollen sie dran festhalten na ja vor
allen Dingen sagen wir erstmal wir
brauchen eine EU dort wo sie die Sachen
besser macht wo es wirklich Sinn macht
sich überstaatlich zu koordinieren sich
abzusprechen wo es eine europäische
Zusammenarbeit braucht da wollen wir die
natürlich auch aber da wo es eher Sinn
macht Entscheidung auf einer kleineren
Ebene zu treffen auf Ebene des
Nationalstaates oder vielleicht auch auf
Ebene der Bundesländer da möchten wir
die Entscheidung dann auch dort haben
auch weil es demokratischer ist Brüssel
ist für viele Menschen weit weg was dort
passiert kriegen viele Menschen im
alltäglichen Leben nicht mit aber
Entscheidungen werden dort getroffen
deswegen ist es auch kein Wunder dass
dort so viele ja Lobbyisten und
lobbyisttin ihren ihren Platz haben und
dort auch tatsächlich Einfluss nehmen
auf Gesetzesgebung und da sagen wir wir
möchten Sachen dort Regeln wo sie am
besten zu regeln sind auch unter
demokratischen Gesichtspunkt sagt
Christian le der Generalsekretär des
Bündnis besten Dank
Zeit bei uns be
König ja und mit diesen Eindrücken zu
den Wahlkämpfen den sich diese neue
Partei in diesem Jahr stellen wird mit
diesen Eindrücken gebe ich zurück zu
Erhard scherfer der genau weiß wie es
jetzt hier im Saal weitergeht zum
glückult Carsten en von der
Nichtregierungsorganisation human
projects die gibt den Löwenherz
Friedenspreis raus der ist nicht ganz
unumstritten weil auch die Organisation
g stitten in ihrer Haltung zum Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine sebastian
Krumbiegel der Musiker und Sänger hat
den Preis bekommen im vergangenen Jahr
hat ih aber dann doch nicht angenommen
bzw wieder
zurückgegeben weil er der Meinung sei
könne mit der Meinung einiger der
Beteiligten zum ukrainekrieg und dessen
Ursachen nicht übereinstimmen
Preisträgerin war kürzlich übrigens auch
Gabriele kronemalz auf deren Position
Richtung russ nicht unumstritten in der
öffentlichen Debatte aber hören wir rein
was Karsten dies Leute sind will und in
der Lage
dazu eine große Mitverantwortung dafür
dass diese Leute in Umfragen so gut
dastehen trägt die
Bundesregierung Dauerstreit und
teilweise offensichtliche Inkompetenz
zeichnen das Regierungshandeln
aus von der Gesamtgesellschaft getragene
Lösungen der Probleme erwarten nur noch
wenige von dieser
Bundesregierung jedoch es gibt Anlass
zur
Hoffnung die Menschen stehen auf und
gehen gegen rechtsradikales Gedankengut
auf die Straße meine sehr verehrten
Damen und
Herren sie liebe Frau Wagenknecht haben
mit vielen anderen gemeinsam die Partei
BSW
gegründet ihre neue Partei haben sie
gegründet
genau zur richtigen Zeit um den Menschen
den vernünftiges Handel und
Gerechtigkeit am Herzen liegen eine
politische Heimat
anzubieten die meisten dieser Menschen
haben mit rechtsradikalem Gedankengut
nichts am Hut jedoch diese Menschen
hatten bis jetzt keine Alternative an
der
Wahlurne sie haben sich selbst in die
Verantwortung gestellt liebe Frau
wagendncht damit Menschlichkeit den Hass
überwindet sie wollen zu einer gerechten
Welt
beitragen und dafür danken wir Ihnen
liebe Frau wagennecht mit dem
löwenherzfriedenspreis den wir Ihnen im
August in Leipzig verleihen
werden
[Applaus]
danke
schön
gestatten Sie mir abschließend noch ein
letztes
Wort ich habe ihnen den Entwurf einer
neuen grundrechtskarter mitgebracht der
Entwurf stammt von Ferdinand von
Schirach und heißt jeder
Mensch Ferdinand von Schirach hat diesen
Entwurf geschrieben weil die Würde eines
jeden Menschen unantastbar bleiben
muss
niemand darf zu einem Objekt gemacht
werden diese große Idee der Aufklärung
müssen wir auch heute wieder
verteidigen und diese neue
grundrechtskarter geben wir Ihnen mit
auf den Weg in dieser neuen
grundrechtskarter heißt es ich zitiere
abschließend jeder Mensch hat das Recht
in einer gesunden und geschützten Umwelt
zu leben Artikel
1 Artikel
2 jeder Mensch hat das Recht auf
digitale
Selbstbestimmung die Ausforschung und
Manipulation von Menschen ist
verboten Artikel
3 jeder Mensch hat das Recht das ihm
belastende Algorithmen transparent
überprüfbar und fair sind wesentliche
Entscheidungen muss ein Mensch
treffenk
4 jeder Mensch hat das Recht dass
Äußerungen von Amtsträgern der Wahrheit
entsprechen Artikel
5 jeder Mensch hat das Recht dass ihm
nur solche Waren und Dienstleistungen
angeboten werden die unter Wahrung der
universellen Menschenrechte hergestellt
und erbracht
werden
und zuletzt Artikel
6 jeder Mensch kann wegen systematischer
Verletzungen dieser Karter seine
grundlerechte vor europäischen Gerichten
[Applaus]
einklagen heute noch haben wir es in der
Hand meines sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren ob wir die Grundrechte mit Füßen
treten ob wir den Weg von den alten
Nazis zu den neuen
beschreiten oder ob wir unseren Aufbruch
hin zu Frieden Freiheit und
Gerechtigkeit mit Menschen wie Sarah
wagendrecht
beschneiden vielen
Dank Carsten en war das Geschäftsführer
der Organisation human pro menschliche
Projekte wenn man das mal ganz schlicht
üers ein pe und ja auch Nähe zum Bündnis
SAR Wagenknecht und ganz offensichtlich
zur
koparteivorsitzenden die ret hier müsste
es jetzt eigentlich weitergehen mit dem
Tagesordnungspunkt Wahlprogramm EU und
ob das so ist da hören wir jetzt mal
direkt rein in das was zugespielt wird
durch die
Parteitagsregie Tag der das
BSW feiert heute seinen ersten Parteitag
und ich wäre so gerne dabei denn die
Sorge um Zukunft und Frieden treibt mich
wirklich um und es gibt zu wenige die
diese Sorge teilen aber sie sind dabei
und sie sind sogar die ersten die als
politische Partei sich so intensiv um
den Frieden
kümmern ich weiß dass Wagenknecht eine
der intelligentesten und rhetorisch
begabtesten Politikerin ist die wir
überhaupt haben und mit ihr zusammen
zuarbeiten und für den Frieden zu
streiten ist etwas Tolles ich wie gesagt
wäre gerne dabei aber ich bin weit weg
und kümmere mich um die Kunst die Kunst
die so viel für den Frieden ausmachen
kann sie wissen
es Kunst verbindet Menschen bringt
Völker zusammen
wir erkennen die Kunst der anderen und
verneigen uns vor dem Gewicht der
anderen und vor dem Können der anderen
und ich kann nur
sagen Frieden ist nur möglich glaube ich
oder viel leichter möglich in einer
kultivierten
Gesellschaft also liebe
Freunde
ja liebe Freundin und Freunde ich
übergebe und auch herzlich willkommen
noch mal Oscar
[Musik]
lafontain
liebe liebe
fre
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde das war
Justus Franz leider ist ja nicht
angekündigt worden der große Pianist und
Dirigent ein weltbekannter Künstler der
für den Frieden wirbt der angegriffen
wird weil er noch Konzerte in Russland
gibt und eigentlich das macht was Kunst
soll die Völker verbinden vielen Dank
Justus Franz dass du heute zu uns
gesprochen
hast
vielen Dank Oscar wir hatten uns fest
vorgenommen wir stellen ihn auch noch
mal vor aber du hast das hervorragend
gemacht liebe Freundin und Freunde als
Sarah warnknecht im Oktober verkündet
hat einen Verein auf den Weg zu bringen
als Vorstufe dessen was wir heute hier
als neue Partei erleben haben insgesamt
10 Bundestagsabgeordnete mit ihr den
Schritt gewagt gegangen die Bundestag
Fraktion und auch die Partei Die Linke
zu verlassen es war für viele ein
mutiger Schritt man hat viele auch
Anfeindungen dafür erhalten
Freundschaften sind zum Teil auch
dadurch flöten gegangen aber ich glaube
für das was in in der Zukunft kommt hat
auch diese Gruppe im Bundestag BSW eine
ganz ganz wichtige Aufgabe
parlamentarisch für unsere Inhalte zu
streiten und die Bundesregierung die
schlechteste die wir je hat en zu
stellen und deshalb glaube ich ist auch
ganz gut dass diese zehn Personen sich
als Gruppe zusammen gefügt haben wir
haben den gruppenstatus beantragt beim
Bundestag wir haben in der kommenden
Woche die Entscheidung des Bundestags
dass wir auch die Anerkennung bekommen
wir haben auch erste Entscheidung
getroffen dass SAR Wagenknecht unsere
gruppensprecherin ist dass Klaus Ernst
der Stellvertreter ist und Jessica TTI
die parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin
wir alle wollen mit den Möglichkeiten
die wir haben nur Z aber doch tatkräftig
wollen wir die Verhältnisse schon
bisschen auch zum wackeln bringen
deshalb ist auch für uns glaube ich auch
heute ein sehr entscheidender Moment
deshalb bitte ich diese z MdBs alle auf
die Bühne s dadelen chlin nastit Amira
Mohammed Ali Christian le Ali alterlami
Klaus Ernst andre hun
jessicacht und ich dar auch dabei sein
ja meine Damen und Herren das sind die
zehn die die Linksfraktion gesprengt
haben im Deutschen Bundestag durch ihren
Austritt dadurch waren die übrigen nicht
mehr genug um eine eigene Fraktion zu
bilden sie haben ihre Mandate im
Deutschen Bundestag gewonnen über die
linke über die Listen der Linken
überwiegend und sie sind aufgefordert
worden von den die in der Linken noch
sind ihre Mandate zurückgegeben sie
haben das nicht getan sie bilden jetzt
eine Gruppe diese Gruppe da hat
Alexander Ulrich eben zurecht erwähnt
wird in der kommenden Woche als Gruppe
anerkannt werden natürlich mit extrem
eingestränkten na sagen wir mit
eingeschränkten
parlamentsrechten und mit deutlich
geringeren Redezeiten im übrigen
beispielsweise wird die Gruppe Sarah
Wagenknecht bzw die Gruppe des
Bündnisses Sarah Wagenknecht in
der Generaldebatte knapp Z Minuten reden
dürfen hören wir kurz noch ein ganz
herzliches Dankeschön an alle MdBs die
bei uns mitmachen dass es zehn sind dass
wir zehn sind ist jetzt wirklich ganz
wichtig weil wir hoffentlich nächste
Woche eine offizielle Gruppe werden und
dann auch wieder andere Möglichkeiten
haben z.B Anträge im Bundestag
einzubringen und dort unsere
Möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen ich
persönlich freue mich auch weil ich
jetzt endlich wieder im Bundestag reden
kann aber wir alle können jetzt auch
wieder endlich mal mehr
reden
und ich denke mal ich denke mal wir
lernen das jetzt so langsam mit 2
Minuten Redezeit mehr zu sagen als die
anderen die dann da eine halbe Stunde
rumsabbeln und ich denke deswegen Danke
schön an euch alle und wir fangen jetzt
bald richtig auch im Bundestag
an s w noch mal mit Anmerkung zum
zukünftigen gruppenstatus ihrer zehn
Mitstreiterinnen und Mitstreiter im
Deutschen Bund Bundestag kritiker werfen
ihr ja vor dass Sie als Mitglied der
Linksfraktion nicht so häufig da gewesen
ist und auch nicht besonders häufig im
Plenum geredet hat na nun muss sie mit
eingeschränkten Redezeiten umgehen 2
Minuten ich sagte schon wird sie in der
Generaldebatte bekommen am kommenden
Dienstag wir sind gespannt so dann haben
wir vohin Oscar lafontin kurz gesehen da
dachte ich schon seine Rede wird
vorgezogen ist aber nicht so gewesen er
hat einfach nur gesagt dass Justus Franz
Justus franz war und das wussten wir ja
zum Glück auch vorher schon
und deswegen wird seine eigentliche rede
also wahrscheinlich erst wieder am
frühen Abend stattfinden wie schon
einmal angekündigt jetzt sollte es hier
tatsächlich mal um das
europawahlprogramm Gehen ich habe das
Wort im Hintergrund gehört und deswegen
lasse ich jetzt Ihnen und uns allen
weiter erklären wie es weitergeht von
Alexander Ulrich der im Moment die
Leitung des tagungspräsidiums
hattii er war lange Jahre im
Europaparlament im Bundestag wir sind
sehr froh dass er zu uns ges
hast
das jetzt also Fabio deasi wird
Spitzenkandidat bei der Europawahl sein
für das BSW war im Bundestag für die
Linke bis er ausgetreten ist und sich
zurückgezogen hat undter
spricht
und ich wurde hier V ein Vortrag
gebucht diejenigen die mich nicht kennen
und nicht wissen was ich hier jetzt
mache fragt vielleicht mal Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz der hat zwar ein paar
Erinnerungslücken bei kriminellen komex
Geschäften aber ich bin mir sicher er
erinnert meinen Namen noch und das ist
auch gut so liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde wir haben wenig Zeit daher wer
ich später auf eine Vorstellung Meer
Person bei den Kandidierenden verzichten
so viel kann ich sagen ich werde
kandidieren ich möchte dazu nur
folgendes sagen ich freue mich wenn ihr
es mir gestattet mit erfahrenen Leuten
wie dem Ex Oberbürgermeister von
Düsseldorf Thomas geiel mit dem
ehemaligen stellvertretenden un
Generalsekretär Michael von der
Schulenburg mit europakennerin wie Rut
Firmenich und Judit Bender mit dem
Neurochirurgen aus Zwickau Professor
Warnke der die
und Epidemiologen friedrichürner der
einige überzogene Coron Maßnahmen
kritisierte mit Leuten wie demburger
Bürgermeister und stahbetriebsrat bei
tüsen K der weiß wie das reviert so mit
vielen anderen die ich hier nicht nennen
kann unser Bestes zu
geben
ichte vorstellen es steht unter dem
Titel ein unabhängiges Europa souveräner
Demokratien friedlich und gerecht unser
Leitmotiv ist weniger ist mehr wir
wollen ein Europa das seinen Job macht
dazu zählt dass wir endlich das
steuerdamping der großen Konzerne der
Amazons und Googles in Europa
unterbinden müssen mit Strafsteuern auf
Finanzflüsse in
steuerasen nur wenn wir die
Daumenschrauben anziehen diese großen
Multis haben wir eine Chance eine
internationale Mindestbesteuerung
durchzusetzen hier muss die EU endlich
liefern um unsen Mittelstand vor den
bigteag aus Übersee zu schützen liebe
Freundinnen und
Freunde wir wollen das kartellreicht
Schärfen dazu zählt für mich auch die
Abschöpfung von übergewinnen etwa im
Energiesektor oder bei den großen US
bigtech Konzernen es reicht doch nicht
wie Robert habbeck die die Haare schön
zu tragen und ein Video zu machen nein
man muss sich mit den mächtigen anlegen
wenn man etwas für die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung herausholen
will wir streben eine europäische
digitale Infrastruktur an um sveränität
gegen die Mächtigen bigtechs und
Plattformen zu verteidigen denn ihre
Algorithmen sind Gift V unser hören V
unsere Debatten sie entscheiden darüber
was wir lesen den und wie wir bezahlen
wir wollen keine digitale Kolonie der
USA sein liebe Freundin und Freunde und
auch nicht von einer Handvoll Tech
Milliardären wir stehen im 21
Jahrhundert auch vor der Aufgabe die
Demokratie vor der Wirtschafts und
datenmacht einiger weniger Konzerne und
ihrer Oligarchen zu schützen und die
Enteignung unser Gedanken und unser
Privatsphäre zu beenden liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde
wir wollen eine Reform des Beihilfe und
Vergaberechts um eine aktive
Industriepolitik zu machen wir müssen es
endlich ermöglichen in Europa wie in den
USA oder China in Zukunftstechnologien
zu investieren um die Probleme des 21
jahrhunderts zu lösen ob grüner
Wasserstoff oder Speichertechnologien
für regenerative Energien ohne
staatliches Engagement und Forschung
gebe es weder das Internet noch andere
Schlüssel technie und deswegen ist es
doch eine große
Katastrophe dass diese sogenannte
fortschrittskoalition jetzt ausgerechnet
die Mittel für die Forschung
zusammenkürzt dieser Irrsinn muss ein
Ende haben liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde der Bundeskanzler hat nicht nur
Erinnerungslücken er hat auch keinen
Plan für die Zukunft in Deutschland
versprache ein Wirtschaftswunder und
heraus kan eine
wir sind die größte Volkswirtschaft
Europas doch eines der Schlusslichter
bei der Investitionsquote R nichts geht
mehr unsere Bahn fahren kaum noch
pünktlich alle Züge stehen still nicht
weil der weselski sondern weil die Ampel
es so will liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde und auch wenn es einige Menschen
verärgert dass die Lockführer streiken
wo war diese Reg als der Bahnvorstand
sich die Taschen mit Boni vollmchte die
FDP die FDP fordert jetzt allen Ernstes
wegen des Streiks den Ersatz der
Lockführer durch künstliche
Intelligenz liebe Freundin und Freunde
wann ersetzen wir einige Minister auf
der Regierungsbank durch natürliche
Intelligenz
unsere Infrastruktur wird immer mehr
runtergerockt es fehlt an bezahlbaren
Wohnraum und der Wohnungsbau ist
eingebrochen die Mieten fressen die
Löhne auf in keinem anderen G7 Staat
außer Deutschland sind die Reallöhne
seit der coronakrise so stark
eingebrochen wir wollen daher endlich
eine Reform der europäischen
Schuldenbremsen wir müssen zu einer
goldenen Regel zurückfinden die wieder
Kredite für Investitionen
ermöglicht und ich will das hier noch
mal sagen wenn die sich jetzt hier alle
hinstellen und sagen das ist nur der
Lindner der das blockiert ich habe 2019
im Deutschen Bundestag eine Reform der
Schuldenbremse gefordert und wer war
dagegen auch die Grünen sie haben sie
verteidigt und jetzt haben sie eine
große Klappe in diesen Debatten das
glaubwürdigkeits der Defizit der Politik
ist eine der zentralen Ursachen für den
Aufstieg der AFD liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde gleich wohl wir wollen im
Gegenzug nicht dass der Haushalt immer
weiter wächst es ist doch absurd über
den Fiskalpakt die Staatsausgaben vieler
europäischer Staaten abzuschnüren und
dann ein Trostpflaster aus Brüssel zu
verpassen und in jede Kommune hinein zu
regieren denn Brüssel ist für viele
Menschen weiter weg wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass auch im EU-Haushalt die
Agrarsubvention endlich den regionalen
Bauern und nicht den großen
agrarkonzernen oder den aldibrüdern
zugute
kommen und auch eines ist wichtig wir
wollen lohndampping im Binnenmarkt
unterbinden und ortsübliche Tariflöhne
schützen Zustände wie in unseren
Schlacht Höfen dürfen nicht weiter um
sich greifen die Beschäftigten dürfen
nicht weiter gegeneinander ausgespielt
werden im Binnenmarkt und wer hier in
Deutschland sagt das Modell Bürgergeld
plus Schwarzarbeit muss beendet werden
der muss auch für anständige Löhne
sorgen Arbeit darf nicht billig wie
Dreck sein 14 € Mindestlohn wie es die
EU mindestlohnrichtlinie vorsieht Liebe
Freundinen und Freunde das ist
Minimum
und denken wir an die Umwelt und
Energiepolitik die Ampel hat die
Mehrwertsteuern angehoben und auch die
CO2 Preise erhöht sie treibt so nach dem
Preisschock des Wirtschaftskrieges die
Preise wieder an und bricht den Leuten
mit den schmalen Schultern das Kreuz
gleichzeitig wurden tausende von
Bahnkilometern abgebaut das ist nicht
ökologisch liebe Freundin Freunde das
ist bescheuert deswegen müssen wir hier
ein deutliches Stoppschild
[Applaus]
setzen wir wollen mehr Nahverkehr auch
auf dem Land und schnelle Züge zwischen
den europäischen Metropolen wir wollen
eine Alternative zum Emissionshandel der
die Spekulanten reich macht wir wollen
öffentliche Investition und
Ordnungspolitik um die Wirtschaft und
Infrastruktur mit Maß und Verstand
umzubauen dazu braucht es viele hundert
Milliarden in Europa aber das lässt sich
finanzieren wenn wir in den
Mitgliedstaaten wie in Deutschland
endlich die Multimillionäre und die
Milliardäre die Quanz und die klattens
und nicht die Mittelschicht zu Kasse
bitten die verursachen mit ihren
Privatjets viel mehr CO2 Emission als
eine Krankenschwester im Schichtbetrieb
und auch jeder Kampfjet verursacht so
viel Emission wie ein pkwfahrer in 17
Jahren das ist doch der Irrsinn der
herrschenden Politik liebe Freundinnen
und
Freunde
und mit den energiesanktionen Schaden
wir uns selbst viel mehr als Russland
ohne den furchtbaren Krieg in der
Ukraine damit zu beenden jetzt kaufen
wir schmutziges freacking Gas und
russisches Gas auf dem Umweg wieder
teurer ein Putin bezahlt seine Soldaten
und diesen Krieg aber in Rubel und nicht
in unseren Euros und wir sagen auch
nordstream 2 dieser Staat terroristische
Akt der muss endlich aufgeklärt werden
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde wo ist
hier die
[Applaus]
Bundesregierung wir wollen die
sanktionsspirale durchbrechen und
endlich mehr diplomatiew Wagen ja dieser
Krieg Russlands ist ein Verbrechen er
reih sich ein in eine Reihe von
völkerrechtsbrüchen des Westens wie im
Irak aber wenn selbst ukrainische
Unterhändler sagten dass wir im März
2022 in Istanbul kurz vor einer
Verhandlungslösung standen aber
natoaaten darauf drängten den Krieg
vorzuführen und nun der Ukraine noch
mehr Verlust an Menschenleben droht sich
die leichten Berge immer höher stapeln
und Putin in der Vorderhand ist dann ist
das doch eine völlig verrückte Politik
liebe Freundinnen und
[Applaus]
Freunde einreden dass jene die für den
Frieden sind ein putinknecht oder
ähnliches sein ich weiß noch ganz genau
wie ich im Bundestag im Alleingang
während des Wirecard Skandals
oligarchennetzwerke aufdeckte wo waren
die Maulhelden in Deutschland da sie
haben sich alle weggedeckt und
weggeduckt und die Taschen voll gemacht
sie haben das Geld dieser Oligarchen
lange Zeit gerne genommen von den
brauchen wir keine Belehrung liebe
Freundinnen und
Freunde
und wir wollen weg von engen
meinungskorridoren die die Gesellschaft
immer tiefer Spalten egal wie man etwa
zu Impfungen in der coronakrise steht
die Debatten über eine Impfpflicht waren
doch fatal denn es gab überhaupt keinen
fremdschutz dieser Impfung während der
coronakrise gab es keine Talkshow ohne
Herr Lauterbach er gehörte dort quasi
zur
Inneneinrichtung aber jetzt ist der
Minister
und die unhaltbaren Zustände in den auf
Rendite getrankten Krankenhäusern werden
immer schlimmer und auch in der Pflege
wo unsere alten nicht mehr anständig
versorgt werden den Kindern hat man in
der coronakrise iPads in die Hand
gedrückt anstatt ihn vernünftig lesen
und Rechnung beizubringen die
bildungsungleich hat
bildungsungleichheit hat massiv
zugenommen liebe Freundin und Freunde
das ist doch ein großes Staatsversagen
und dagegen müssen wir uns
auflehnen
wir wollen eine EU die nur das erledigt
was sie wirklich besser kann deswegen
müssen wir der EU auch in den Arm fallen
wenn sie etwa in Kommunen hinein regiert
die Tariflöhne auf dem Bau aushebelt die
Mitbestimmung unterläuft und in die
Arbeits undozialverfassung der
Mitgliedstaaten eingreift es geht daher
nicht um mehr oder weniger Europa es
geht um mehr Demokratie und
Gerechtigkeit in Europa liebe
Freundinnen und
[Applaus]
Freunde die Menschen in
Deutschland sprechen mittlerweile abends
Stoßgebete aus dass Olaf Scholz ein
Kurzarbeiter im Kanzleramt werden möge
die Ampelkoalition ist die erntehilferin
der AFD aber beten hilft nicht liebe
Freundin und Freunde man muss auch
wählen und deswegen ist die Europawahl
eine Chance dieser Regierung eine
deutliche Warnung zu senden deshalb
kämpfen wir um jede Stimme für das
Bündnis SAR wenknecht Vernunft und
Gerechtigkeit vielen Dank und Glück
auf natürlich stehender Applaus auch für
Fabio De Masi was sagt die Menschen
stoßen Stoßgebete
aus weiß gar nicht ob das so fürchtbar
viele sind und woher das weiß aber wir
können trotzdem noch mal kurz auf die
rese gucken da hat er nämlich so ein
paar Begriffe drin gehabt auf die sich
zu zeigen oder zu deuten durchaus noch
mal lohnt der sprach von einem
Wirtschaftskrieg und ich denke er meint
die Sanktionen gegen Russland und die
haben ja durchaus einen Grund und er hat
aber gesagt der Krieg Russlands ist ein
Verbrechen diesen Satz haben wir bislang
heute hier noch nicht gehört aber auch
Fabio dei schafft diesen Satz nicht ohne
ein aber und Z war ein ganz besonders
großes jetzt wird gleich aufgerufen
werden vermute ich
mal der kpitzenkandidat für die
Europawahl nämlich der frühere SPD
Oberbürgermeister Thomas Geisel der ist
glaube ich auch schon vor ich muss mE
Monitoren vorbeigucken aber hben ors
Einbringung und Generaldebatte eine
Stunde wir müssen des noch mal trotzdem
eine Abstimmung vollziehen die bedeutet
Einbringung 10 Minuten das waren sie
eben und Wortmeldungen je 3 Minuten wer
dafür ist dass wir so verfahren bitte
ich ums
Kartenzeichen
Gegenprobe
Enthaltungen bei einer Gegenstimme so
beschlossen vielleicht noch ein Hinweis
laut Andras beratungskommission liegen
zum europawahlprogramm keine
Änderungsanträge vor wir weisen aber
darauf hin dass es seit der Verschickung
des europawahlprogramms an die
Mitglieder im Rahmen unserer Online
Veranstaltung letzte Woche am Samstag
zur Vorbereitung einige Veränderungen
oder Präzisierungen gab die aber
redaktionelle Art waren also keine neue
Inhalte waren sondern redaktionelle Art
die sind eingebaut worden und das
europawahlprogramm das heute auf den
Tischen lag oder auf den Stühlen ist
dann diese aktuellste Fassung sind keine
Änderungen an Inhalt sondern nur
redaktionelle Veränderung gewesen
entsprechend unserer Debatte letzte
Woche dann kommen wir zur Generaldebatte
als erstes macht sich bereit Sinan
Öztürk danach bitte Judit Bender und
Andreas harenfelds bereithalten
Sinan er ist unterwegs so kein Thomas
Geisel habe ich ih was falsches erzählt
der kommt wahrscheinlich während der
Debatte dann aber noch mal und wird da
schon seinen Platz haben hier in dieser
Aussprache die es jetzt geben soll zum
Europawahl Programm das bislang
umfangreichste Papier das es
von vom BSW gibt bislang gab es ja nur
ein vierseitiges manest Manifest jetzt
zehn Seiten doppelt bedruckt also da
kann man schon eine Menge nachlesen mich
einbringen mit meinen Kolleginen und
Kollegen aus Bayern ich glaube heute
schon mehrfach angesprochen worden dass
wir in einer Situation sind wo viele
abhängig Beschäftigte trotz
Vollzeitarbeit sozusagen nicht von ihrem
Gehalt auskommen können heute auch schon
wie erwähnt auch ewig warten müssen bis
den fachatztermin bekommen und
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Frage
natürlich nach einer anständigen Rente
auch im Alter ist eine Kernfrage die
viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
abhängig Beschäftigte betrifft und dafür
sollten wir
einstehen bei der Frage bei der Frage in
der Tat während der coronakrise aber
jetzt auch während der ukraineekrise äh
sozusagen wer von diesen Maßnahmen
profitiert hat und wer sich die Taschen
voll gemacht hat ich glaube dass es
richtig ist dass wir sozusagen den
Finger in die Wunde legen und auch
deutlich machen wer von dieser Krise
profitiert und dass die Mehrheit in
dieser Republik sozusagen für diese
Krise bezahlen muss das muss ein Ende
haben Kolleginnen und Kollegen dafür
sollten wir einstehen und dafür sollten
wir auch tatsächlich an den Infoständen
immer wieder drauf hinweisen und wir
sollten uns wir sollten uns und das ist
mein letzter Satz in der Tat auch nicht
von denen verärgern lassen seid ihr denn
jetzt AFD n seid ihr rechts oder links
ich kann uch sagen ich habe 18 Jahre
Parteiarbeit in der Linken gemacht ich
wurde als Kommunist beschimpmpft als
Sozialist beschimpmpft was auch immer
sage auch ganz ehrlich Kolleginen und
Kollegen wer für eine ordentliche Rente
einsteht der darf mich schimpfen wie er
will wer für ordentliche abhängig
Beschäftigte Beschäftigungsverhältnisse
steht der darf m auch beschimpfen wie er
will eins ist klar Kollegin und Kollegen
schon alleine aufgrund meines
Migrationshintergrundes ich bin nicht
recht sondern ich bin links eingeordnet
dafür stehe ich ein in dieser
Partei und das war der erste Redner in
dieser Aussprache jetzt haben wir das
erste kleine Defizit dass wir die Namen
nicht mit einigem Vorlauf bekommen die
hier ans Pult gegangen sind jetzt kann
ich ihn einfach nur sagen dass dieser
Redner eben von der Ukraine Krise
gesprochen hat das finde ich dann doch
ein bisschen tapfer angesichts dessen
was in der Ukraine tatsächlich passiert
und weiter geht's mit der
Aussprache Thomas ge wenn ich mich nicht
ver jeder wird verstehen dass ich nach
dieser fulminanten Rede von Fabio noch
mehr motiviert bin gemeinsam mit ihm und
einer ganz großartigen Liste wie ich
finde hier Europawahlkampf zu machen und
ein großartiges Ergebnis für BSW zu
erzielen liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
ich möchte trotzdem darin erinnern
während wir hier in Berlin unseren
Parteitag abhalten sind in Deutschland
Hunderttausende auf den Straßen allein
in Düsseldorf werden über 50.000
Menschen heute erwartet und ich sage
ehrlich wäre ich nicht hier wäre ich
auch da denn was da Neofaschisten und
Nazis im Umfeld von AFD und Werte Union
planen ist widerwertig ist
verabscheuungswürdig und muss auf den
erbitterten Widerstand aller Demokraten
stoßen liebe
[Applaus]
Freunde in einer Hinsicht müssen wir
allerdings ein bisschen aufpassen es
darf nicht passieren dass durch diese
Demonstrationen diejenigen sich
bestätigt fühlen die dafür
verantwortlich sind dass immer mehr
Menschen enttäuscht sind dass immer mehr
Menschen verärgert sind unzufrieden
wütend und zum Teil verzweifelt über den
Zustand unseres Landes sind denn 15
Jahre merkelregierung und 2i Jahre Ampel
haben dieses Land heruntergewirtschaftet
und die Ursache dafür sind nicht
Schicksalschläge sondern falsche
politische
Entscheidungen
liebe Freunde es hat mit Politik zu tun
dass unser Bildungssystem immer
schlechter ausgestattet immer mehr
unterfinanziert ist und heute kaum mehr
soziale Durchlässigkeit ermöglicht und
es hat mit Politik zu tun dass immer
mehr Unternehmen den Standort
Deutschland verlassen weil sie mit
Bürokratie erschlagen werden und keine
qualifizierten Fachkräfte finden und es
hat mit Politik zu tun dass die Schere
zwischen Arm und Reich immer weiter
aufgeht und die Vermögensverteilung
zwischen oben und unten übrigens auch
zwischen Ost und West immer ungerechter
wird und es hat mit Politik zu tun dass
ich viele Orts Parallelgesellschaften
entwickeln die sich der
gesellschaftlichen Solidarität entziehen
kaum mehr integrierbar sind und auf
Dauer den sozialen Zusammenhalt in
unserem Land geferten und es hat mit
Politik mit gravierenden
ordnungspolitischen Fehlentscheidung zu
tun dass unsere Infrastruktur Straßen
Schienen Energie und
Telekommunikationsnetze marode sind und
nicht vernünftig ausgebaut werden hier
muss ich etwas ändern wenn es darum geht
unsere Demokratie den sozialen
Zusammenhalt und unseren Wohlstand zu
retten dann wird es auf Dauer nicht
reichen auf die Straße zu gehen dann
brauchen wir eine neue Regierung dann
brauchen wir keine Regierung die sich in
erster Linie mit Genderfragen mit Fragen
der sexuellen Identität mit kan mit der
Legalisierung von Cannabis befasst dann
brauchen wir eine Regierung die sich
genau um diese Themen kümmert um die
Brot und Butter Themen um die Themen die
die Menschen wirklich angehen die sich
um diese Themen kümmern und die ganz
oben auf die politische Tagesordnung
setzt
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde ihr könnt
euch wahrscheinlich vorstellen dass ich
viele Reaktion bekommen habe als bekannt
wurde dass ich nach 40 Jahren aus der
SPD ausgetreten bin
natürlich war der Enttäuschung dabei es
gab in wenigen Fällen auch Ablehnung und
Häme aber ganz überwiegend waren die
Reaktionen positiv und zwar quer durch
das ganze Spektrum meines
Freundeskreises der durchaus
unterschiedlich politisch verortet ist
für mich hat dies deutlich gemacht mit
dieser Partei werden große Hoffnungen
verknüpft was viele Menschen ganz
besonders fasziniert ist unser
selbstgesetzter Anspruch Politik mit
Vernunft und für Gerechtigkeit zu machen
manchmal hat man ja den Eindruck
Vernunft und Politik sind zu Gegensätzen
geworden jedenfalls schwer vereinbar und
ich glaube wenn wir uns die gegenwärtige
Politik anschaut gibt es viele Beweise
dafür schauen wir uns die Klimapolitik
der Ampel an es ist offensichtlich
unvernünftig wenn man vorzeitigunk
iierende Kraftwerke abschaltet obwohl
die Gesamtmenge die emittiert werden
kann von vornherein europaweit
festgelegt ist wer so etwas macht der
tut nichts für das Klima schadet aber
unserem Land und es
ist und es ist auch unvernünftig
Verbrennungsmotoren ab dem Jahr
2035 in Europa zu verbieten wenn sie
anderen Orts weiterfahren und übrigens
auch finde ich solange iende fragen was
die Herstellung und Entsorgung der
Batterien angeht nicht geklärt sind
durch so eine Politik setzen wir
100tausende von qualifizierten
Arbeitsplätzen auf Spiel ohne dass es
dem Land irgendetwas nützt und es ist
auch unvernünftig zu beklagen dass
angeblich die Anreize zur Arbeit immer
schwächer sind wenn man zulässt dass der
Mindestlohn wesentlich schwächer steigt
als das Bürgergeld es ist einfach
unehrlich hier das zu sagen und Fabio
hat darauf hingewiesen der Mindestlohn
müsste auf der Grundlage der EU
mindestrichtlinie mindestlohnrichtlinie
bei 14 € liegen er liegt in Deutschland
W weiter runter man wundert sich darüber
üblicherweise ist Deutschland wenn es um
die Umsetzung von EU-Richtlinien geht
immer Musterknabe wieso eigentlich
ausgerechnet nicht beim
Mindestlohn
und es ist offenkundig auch unvernünftig
wenn man sich an anktion beteiligt die
dem eigenen Land viel mehr Schaden
zufügt als dem Land dass man
sanktionieren möchte und last but not
least es ist auch unvernünftig und
widersprüchlich wenn Herr Scholz auf der
einen Seite von Bürokratieabbau
schwatroniert gleichzeitig aber sein
Kanzleramt für 800 Millionen ausbauen
möchte jeder weiß doch Bürokraten ziehen
Bürokratie an liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde bis zu Wahl sind es jetzt gerade
noch vier Monate das ist eine
Herausforderung für eine Partei die sich
eben erst gegründet hat aber ich bin
überzeugt mit dem Programm und mit den
Personen die wir mit denen wir antreten
werden wir viele Menschen in diesem
Lande überzeugen wer will dass Europa
nicht zerrieben wird und
instrumentalisiert wird in einem neuen
Kalten Krieg und in einem
Wirtschaftskrieg zwischen China und
Amerika der muss BSW wählen wer will
dass Europa mit vernehmlicher Stimme
seine Interessen in einer immer
komplizierteren wie man so schön sagt
multipolaren Welt äußern kann der muss
BSW wählen und wer will dass Europa
nicht zu einer übergriffigen Bürokratie
wird sondern für fair Marktbedingungen
in einem gemeinsamen Markt sorgt wer
will dass Europa
steuersenkungswettbewerbe sozial und
umweltdumping verhindert statt
neoliberaler privatisierungs und
kommerzial erungsideologie des Wort zu
reden der muss BSW wählen kurz um wem
Europa am Herzen liegt der wählt am 9
juni bündnissara Wagenknecht Vernunft
und
Gerechtigkeit liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
lasst uns gemeinsam dafür kämpfen dass
am 9 Juni ein klares Signal gesendet
wird für einen neuen Aufbruch in
Deutschland und Europa vielen Dank
Thomas Geisel war mal Oberbürgermeister
in Düsseldorf war 40 Jahre in der SPD
ist im Dezember auch für diese
40-jährige Mitgliedschaft noch geehrt
worden hat dann aber überraschend
gemerkt dass das doch nicht seine Partei
ist und dem BSW beigetreten und er sorgt
sich unter anderem um die Entsorgung von
Batterien von Elektroautos allerdings
nicht um ausgebrannte Kernbrennstäbe in
Atomkraftwerken die er gerne länger
laufen lassen würde aber das wird ja
wohl nichts mehr in diesem Land
und hier geht weiter mit der Debatte um
das Wahlprogramm für die Europawahl
Julia Wender könnte das sein
juditender eine aktive eine starke
engagierte Partei die aber nicht in der
Empörung verhartt sondern weitergeht und
konkrete Angebote für und mit den
Menschen macht wir haben es heute schon
oft gehört in Deutschland und auch in
der EU gibt's doch so viel Grund zur
Empörung gegenüber einer Politik der
sozialen Spaltung und
Aufrüstung diese Woche wurde bekannt
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde dass die
EU fast eine Milliarde Euro für
Militärtransporte an die Ostfront locker
macht ziel sei es die Infrastruktur so
zu ertüchtigen dass Gerät und Soldaten
schneller an die Grenze Russlands
verlegt werden können so würde angeblich
die europäische Sicherheit gestärkt die
EU baut also Straßen für Panzer aus
während Brücken bröseln Gleise brechen
während die Infrastruktur und die
öffentliche Daseinsvorsorge in Europa
brutal unterfinanziert ist das ist aber
keine Sicherheit für die Menschen
sondern immer mehr Eskalation und
dagegen werden wir mobilisieren
[Applaus]
empörend empörend sind auch die
Moralpredigten dieser EU über Werte und
Transparenz die es aber im Brüssler Filz
kaum gibt wo es möglich ist dass eine
Frau vonlein die kommissionspräsidentin
mit piser einen Milliarden schweren
impfstoffdeal mal ebenso per SMS
besiegelt sich dann aber weigert diese
SMS herauszugeben Verträge nur
geschwärzt an die Abgeordneten
rausgegeben werden und sie dennoch mit
einer kommenden Amtszeit rechnen kann
mit mehr als 30 000 € Monatsgehalt eine
Kassiererin muss bei fehlenden
centbeträgen eine fristlose Kündigung
befürchten während diese Menschen in
privilegierten Positionen den Hals nicht
vollkriegen dieses System ist kaputt und
produziert zurecht
Ablehnung wir sind wir sind liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde die neue Kraft
für Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit packen
wir zusammen an ich freue mich drauf
[Applaus]
danke vielen Dank Judi als nächstes
Andreas
hartenfeld dran er ist unser erster
landasabgeordneter des BSW in
rheinandfalz ihr hab vielleicht in
Medien
[Applaus]
mitverfolgt ja liebe Freundin Freunde
lieber Alexander in der Tat Montag vor
einer Woche konnte ich zusammen mit
Sarah Wagenknecht der rheinandfelschen
Presselandschaft dem sogenannten
parlamentarischen Arm in rinandfalz
präsentieren der erste
Landtagsabgeordnete in einem Flächen
Land in Rheinlandpfalz ich war stolz wie
Bolle muss ich sagen und es waren sehr
sehr schönes Gefühl deutlich zu machen
dass wir in Rheinlandpfalz auch an einem
neubeging stehen um ein
parlamentarisches ein politisches und
von politikstitil ein neues Angebot
machen damit die vielen Menschen die
sich von der Politik abgewendet haben
wieder eine Perspektive bekommen und die
Perspektive die sitzt hier vor mir und
ich bin so froh hier heute mit dabei zu
sein ich möchte zwei Themen ansprechen
die mir wichtig sind das ist einmal das
Thema Frieden das hat was mit meiner
Biografie zu tun und das Thema
Corona ich bin vor gut fast 40 Jahren
als 17 18 19-jähriger junger Mensch zu
den grünestoßen wir hatten damals eine
bewegte Zeit es gab die Friedensbewegung
es gab die antiak wehbewegung es gab
damals den NATO doppelbeschluss es gab
persching 2 und groß Missal wir hatten
zwei blocksysteme die sich bis zum
Wahnsinn hochgerüstet hatten und nicht
nur die junge Generation sondern
überhaupt ganz ganz viele Menschen
Deutsch haben gesagt das kann nicht sein
das ist nicht unsere Zukunft ich bin
damals zu den Grünen gestoßen und musste
dann an musste dann einfach und es war
für mich ein schmerzhafter Prozess
anerkennen dass die Grünen keine
Friedenspartei mehr ist sondern eine
Kriegspartei geworden
sind
und das war besonders eindrücklich und
das war dann auch der Zeitpunkt wo ich
ausgetreten bin im Oktober 2022 der
Parteitag der Grünen wo die offizielle
neue Richtung unterstehenden Ovationen
beklatscht worden ist eine Frau Annalena
berbur hat zwei Thesen in Raum gestellt
oder zwei zukünftige Botschaften zum
einen wir müssen Waffen und schwere
Waffen liefern und wir müssen diesen
Krieg gewinnen und dann sind wir zu
diplomatischen Gesprächen bereit das war
die eine Botschaft von Frau berbock und
die andere Botschaft wir müssen mit den
Wirtschaftssanktionen so weit gehen dass
wir auf Jahre hinaus Russland ruinieren
vor dem Hintergrund unserer deutschen
Geschichte eine deutsche Außenministerin
die einen solchen Satz sagt wir müssten
Russland ruinieren die müsste schon
längst zurückgetreten
sein bezeichnen dass das nicht passiert
dass sie nicht zurücktritt das zeigt
auch wie wir inzwischen der
Kriegspropaganda auf den auf den Leim
gegangen sind
eindimensional in eine Richtung die
natürlich ganz fatal ist wenn man sie zu
Ende denkt wenn man tatsächlich noch
schwerere Waffen taurusraketen sind
schon angesprochen worden dann auch
liefert und es war dann bemerkenswert
bei diesem Parteitag zu sehen die weiße
Taube auf blauen Grund wurde vom Tisch
gefegt und nicht nur dass die Grünen die
dieser Bundesregierung sind sie sind die
olivgrünfalken und sie haben vor allen
Dingen die AFD in dem Punkt rechts
überholt und das sagt sehr viel über
unser Parteiensystem inzwischen
aus ich möchte zum zweiten Thema kommen
was mir sehr am Herzen liegt das ist die
coronazeit ich sag Coron zeeit zu diesen
dre Jahren für mich ist es eigentlich
das dunkelste Kapitel seit dem Bestehen
der Bundesrepublik was ich erleben
musste als überzeug der
Demokrat was dort passiert ist das
Grundgesetz eigentlich mit Rechten des
einzelnen Bürgers ausgestattet um uns
vor dem Zugriff des Staates zu schützen
wurde so umgedeutet dass über das
Grundgesetz der Zugriff organisiert
worden ist bis in die Wohnung hinein in
die Bewegungsfreiheit bis hin zu
Berufsverboten das zu erleben war für
mich in der Tat ein Tiefpunkt und ich
glaube dass unsere Gesellschaft immer
noch zum Teil davon traumatisiert ist
und vor allen Dingen die sind
traumatisiert die erleben mussten wie
mit ihnen umgegangen worden ist ich
denke z.B an die montagsd Demonstration
die stattgefunden haben das sind
Menschen friedlich ohne Plakate einfach
mit Kerzenlicht abends von A nach B
durch eine Stadt marschiert was waren
sie für die politische Elite
rechtsradikale von Nazis unterwandert
Idioten schwurbler man hatte keine
Grenzen gekannt um über diese Menschen
herzuziehen und man hat diesen diese
Haltung hinüber getragen in die
nachcoronazeit nehmen wir jetzt mal die
den Bauer die Bauern
ist schon bemerkenswert dass auch den
Bauern versucht wurde das rechte
unterzuschieben eine Tageszeitung hat am
8.1 getitelt der
mährechermob der mährechermob wir müssen
uns das noch mal vergegenwertigen was
das heißt für die Männer und Frauen die
auf diesen Traktoren sitzen oder auf den
mährechern sie sind zu einem Mob für die
politische Elite geworden zum Glück sind
die Bauern so stark dass sie sich davon
nicht haben in Abrede stellen lassen
dass sie zu zurecht demonstrieren und
protestieren aber es zeigt das Niveau
der politischen Elite in Zusammenhang
mit der mächenlandschaft dass wir kein
politisches debattenklima mehr haben das
ist uns verloren
gegangen so Andreas hatenf verlassen wir
jetzt in seiner Rede über den mdrescher
Mob ehemaliger grüner ist er gewesen
hier sind doch viele ehemalige
Sozialdemokraten viele ehemalige linke
und ein ehemaliger linker und ein
ehemaliger Sozialdemokrat ist jetzt bei
Mark Steinhäuser so ist es Erhard
schärfer bei uns ist jemand ja der mal
wieder die Partei gewechselt hat muss
man sagen Herr lafontain sie waren mal
SPD Vorsitzender sie waren mal linken
Vorsitzender jetzt sind sie im Bündnis
Sarah Wagenknecht ist das jetzt dann die
Heimat in der sie bleiben ja ich muss
das immer erklären mit der
parteiwechselung denn ich verstehe unter
Partei einen Verein der sich zu einem
bestimmten
Programm zusammenfindet das Programm ist
entscheidend für mich gewesen und so
gesehen bin ich immer inerselben Partei
geblieben und auch jetzt noch in
derselben Partei das heißt einmal
Friedenspolitik nach der Politik Willi
brandz die keine Partei mehr vertritt
und zum zweiten Sozialpolitik die die
Sozialdemokratie früher zu meinen Zeiten
vertreten hat also bessere Renten
bessere Löhne und bessere soziale
Leistungen es ist bedauerlich dass die
Politik sich so falsch entwickelt hat
das heißt wir sind hier quasi auf einem
Art SPD Parteitag von 195 das kann man
abwerten meinen aber ich nehme an sie
meinen das nicht so der die SPD war
damals tei Deutschland das war die große
Zeit ihrer Außenpolitik der
Bundeskanzler hat dafür den
Friedensnobelpreis erhalten und ich
wünschte mir eine solche Zeit K wieder
jetzt haben wir ein Bundeskanzler der
für Aufrüstung und krieg
ist nun haben sie ja hier in der ersten
Reihe gesessen sie haben das alles sehr
genau verfolgt auch die Gründung dieser
Partei sehr genau verfolgt sie beraten
ja wahrscheinlich Sarah Wagenknecht auch
in vielen Dingen es läuft hier heute
sehr straff sehr organisiert wie viel
Oscar lafontain steckt hier in die
diesem ersten
Bundesparteitag der Parteitag läuft
deshalb straf ab einige kritisieren das
ja auch weil wir nicht genügend Zeit
haben wir müssten sonst Z D Tage hier in
diesem Haus verbringen dafür haben wir
nicht genügend Geld um das zu erklären
also wurden die Debatten vorher geführt
und wie gesagt alle die hier zusammen
sind bekennen sich an diesen zwei Themen
erklärt zu dieser Politik also Frieden
und Abrüstung und ein ordentlicher
Sozialstaat in ofern steckt nicht nur
oson hier in dieser Politik s alle die
hier versammelt sind bei dem
friedensthema gab es hier den größten
Applaus bei allen Rednerinnen und
Rednern die das angesprochen haben nun
ist es ja so dass sich das nicht ganz
einfach lösen lässt die Ukraine ist ein
sveräner Staat die hat ja selbst darüber
zu entscheiden wie Ihre Zukunft aussieht
warum versammeln sie hier auch Menschen
die in Teilen eine Verhandlungslösung
wünschen wo die Ukraine dann
Staatsgebiet verliert die Ukraine ist
entschulden Sie dass ich da
wiederspreche kein suveräne Staat mehr
ohne das Geld und die Waffen der anderen
Staaten könnte sie so nicht weitermachen
oder existieren deshalb entscheidet was
die westliche Seite angeht im
besentlichen die Vereinten Staaten
darüber wie es weitergeht oder eben
nicht weitergeht aber es war ja schon
mal so dass die Ukraine einen Frieden
abschließen wollte das ist mittlerweile
vielfach dokumentiert im Februar vor zwe
Jahren daraufhin wurde sie aber von
Herrn Johnson und von den USA
aufgefordert den Krieg nicht zu beenden
und den Vertrag nicht zu unterschreiben
es ging ja damals nur um die Neutralität
also darum dass die Ukraine nicht
zulässt dass US-Raketen und US
Militäreinrichtungen in der Ukraine an
der russchen Grenze aufgestellt werden
und diese dieser diesem Wunsch wollte
der Westen nicht entsprechen und deshalb
sind wir jetzt immer noch im Krieg also
nach Z Jahren ist jetzt bewiesen dass
die Politik des Westens immer mehr
Waffen zu liiefern völlig falsch ist
nicht ein bisschen völlig falsch ist es
sterben immer mehr Menschen und die
Ukraine wird jeden Tag mehr zerstört
welchen Sinn das machen soll konnte mir
noch niemand erklären das haben wir
heute ja vielfach gehört nun bei ihrer
Erzählung fehlt ja dann der Punkt dass
danach die Massaker in butscha kam
Mariupol dass es auch an der
Zivilbevölkerung unfassbare
Grausamkeiten gab die die Russen den
Ukrainern angetan haben dass da die
Ukrainer zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht
verhandeln wollten das hat ja doch auch
eine gewisse Erklärung noch mal was
würden Sie denn dann empfehlen der
Ukraine abzugeben wenn sie sagen die
sollen jetzt verhandeln die Ukraine muss
jetzt verhandeln wenn sie nicht will
dass die Zerstörung immer weitergeht das
ist ja das überraschende das tägliche
sterben und die ständig zunehmende
Zerstörung ist offensichtlich keine
Veranlassung für diejenigen die immer
mehr Waffen liefern wollen und die immer
mehr den Krieg immer verlängern wollen
um aufzuhören ich verstehe das nicht das
kann mir niemand erklären wer das
versteht ist ja
und sagen wir mal wer das so versteht
wie sie muss man an dieser Stelle sagen
ist offenbar ja Gerhard Schröder mit dem
waren sie 25 Jahre lang zerstritten
nachdem sie ausgetreten sind aus seiner
damaligen Regierung da waren sie ja mal
Finanzminister jetzt hat man vor
Weihnachten gelesen dass es eine Art
Friedenstreffen gegeben hat und sie
haben sich mit Gerhard Schröder versöhnt
hat sozusagen die russische
sie wieder zusammeführt oder wie muss
man das verstehen das ist mehr zu
verstehen aus der persönlichen Begegnung
viele Jahre davor und ausd dem zerwifen
hat nicht mit der ukraineepitik zu tun
also haben sie mit ihm darüber nicht
gesprochen oder das ist natürlich Unsinn
wir haben über alle möglichen
politischen Themen gesprochen auch über
das Thema des Krieges in der Ukraine
aber wie gesagt entscheidend ist eben
dass jetzt die Politik sich verändert
nicht was Schöder ich dazu meinen wäre
der noch ein Kandidat für das Bündnis
Sara Wagenknecht wollen sie den noch
hier dazu gewinnen weil es sollen ja
noch mehr werden als 450 Mitglieder ich
erwarte noch weitere Vorschläge von
ihnen bin dankbar und dann wird sich die
Partei mit diesen Vorschlägen
beschäftigen okay dann lassen wir das
mal so stehen besten Dank Oscar
lafontain für das Gespräch hier bei
phöniix ich danke auch ja und mit diesen
Eindrücken für mögliche neue Mitglieder
und auch der Position die hier sehr zum
Tragen gekommen ist bei vielen
Redebeiträgen zu einer möglichen Lösung
für die Ukraine wie man sich das hier
vorstellt in diesem früheren Kinosaal
mit diesen Eindrücken gebe ich jetzt
zurück zu meinem Kollegen Erhard
scherfer der wie immer weiß was sonst
hier im Saal passiert und er sich nach
wie vor fragt welche Rolle Russland
eigentlich in diesem Krieg spielt bzw
warum die Rolle Russlands hier so selten
thematisiert und angesprochen wird von
vielen Rednerinnen und Redner bei diesem
Bundesparteitag gut hier geht es weiter
zum
europawahlprogramm und da hören wir die
am besten direkt in den
nächsten wir leben heute in einer Welt
in der es keine
rüstungskontroll Verträge mehr gibt wir
leben in einer Welt in der es auch alle
vertrauensbildenden Maßnahmen die seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg aufgebaut wden
alle sind abgeschafft worden es gibt
keine mehr aber wir leben gleichzeitig
in einer Welt in der die Waffensysteme
ein ummaß an
Zerstörung hervorbringen könnte die wir
dann gar nicht mehr kontrollieren wir
sprechen von Hyper Schall
Raketensystemen Cyber war
weltalkkriege und natürlich in den in
artificial intelligence die da in in
Armee in Waffensysteme eingebaut werden
sollten so verlieren wir die Kontrolle
über unsere Waffensysteme und sie würden
alles zerstören es ist im Grunde
genommen eine Zeit in der sich gar kein
Krieg mehr erlauben könnte
und Europa Europa dass der Welt in zwei
Weltkriege hineingezogen hat hat nun
wieder ein einen Krieg in der
ukraineekrieg wahrscheinlich der
gefährlichste Krieg den wir seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg hatten und wir haben
keine Antwort darauf Europa die EU denkt
immer noch dass Waffen und Sanktionen
diese Antworten sind sie hat keine Form
der Friedens keine Diplomatie keine Form
wie man sich verständigen sollte und das
muss ich
und deswegen möchte ich auch zu EU gehen
und die Politik der des Bündnis SAR
Wagenknecht dort unterstützen mit der
Erfahrung die ich
über mit der Erfahrung die ich über über
34 Jahre gemacht habe fast
ausschließlich in Ländern der Welt die
in Kriegen und bewaffneten
Konflikten involviert waren deswegen
bitte ich um euer Vertrauen und eure
Unterstützung vielen
Dank Michael von Schulenburg war das aus
dem Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht
voraussichtlich wird er Listen Platz 3
einnehmen bei der Liste für die
Europawahl des
BSW nächster Redner auf unserer Liste
Stefan Falk auch ein ehemaliger linker
wie so viele die hier heute auftreten ja
wir leben in einer Zeit in der die
verrückten die Blinden führen das ist
kein Zitat von SAR wenknecht das ist von
Willam
King leer aber es bricht es trifft
glaube ich auch auf unsere heutige Zeit
zu ja liebe Bundesgenossen liebe
mitgründerinnen liebe Komplizen und
Komplizinnen ich bin gespannt gespannt
jetzt nicht weil das hier mein erer
Parteitag ist ich war noch nie in einer
Partei und auch nicht weil das jetzt
hier meine erste Parteitagsrede ist ich
finde es spannend weil ich hier eine
große energi merke und auch schon vorher
eine große Aufbruchstimmung und
Optimismus dass ich etwas ändern kann
ich bin Drehbuchautor müsste ich dazu
sagen und Spannung gehört für jeden
Autor und jeden Geschichtenerzähler
eigentlich zu seinem alltäglichen
Geschäft und ich meine jetzt nicht die
Spannung den suspens unter welchem Tisch
wird jetzt welche Bombe
explodieren sondern die Spannung für uns
wie geht es
weiter denn jede gute Story besitzt eine
innere Spannung diesen einen
faszinierenden roten Faden oder anders
gesagt was treibt uns an was ist der KN
unseres Projekts was ist der KN des
Bündnis Sara wagenkncht für Vernunft und
Gerechtigkeit für mich ist es die
Vernunft eine empathische eine
mitfühlende Vernunft denn in ihr steckt
immanent immer auch schon die Forderung
nach Gerechtigkeit in einer solchen
vernünftigen Welt dürfte man nicht dlden
dass es zu solch enormen unterschieden
zwischen Arm und Reich kommt und in
einer
solchen und in einer solchen
vernünftigen Welt würden
selbstverständlich friedenserhaltene
deeskalierende Strategien unsere
deutsche Außenpolitik
bestimmen aber
Szenenwechsel wir sind ja hier heute
auch versammelt wegen den Europawahlen
ich bin aus einer Generation die immer
mit Europa die schönsten Hoffnung
verbunden
hat Europa steht für mich für seine so
reiche und seine vielfältige Kultur aber
was ist daraus geworden heute scheint
mir dieses Europa zusammengeschrumpft zu
sein zu einer Art EU
technokratenprojekt damit steht diese EU
eben halt nicht für Verbesserung der
Lebensumstände der Bürger und
Bürgerinnen im Gegenteil Brüssel ist für
mich so einer Art Abklingbecken geworden
ein Abklingbecken für besonders
brennende gesellschaftliche Probleme der
letzten Jahre und Jahrzehnte wir
erinnern uns was ist eigentlich aus der
Finanztransaktionssteuer geworden nach
der Finanzkrise 2008 und was ist mit
einer übergewinnsteuer auf geradezu wie
ich finde obszöne Gewinner
internationaler bigtech Unternehmen
während der
coronakrise
und nicht zu vergessen was ist
eigentlich mit der versprochenen
europäischen Lösung in Bezug auf die
ungeregelte migration immer heißt es das
können wir auf nationaler Ebene nicht
lösen dazu brauchen wir die europäische
Regelung aber wir wissen haben sch
längst verstanden das ist der stank
münerleinstag 2024 ist übrigens ein sehr
gutes Jahr wie ich finde für die
Gründung des Bündnisses jetzt meine ich
jetzt gar nicht die anstehenden
Europawahlen oder die Wahlen in den
ostdeutschen Ländern sondern ich will
auch daran erinnern
204 ist das Jahr an dem der bedeutendste
Philosoph der Aufklärung sein geburtstag
feiert Immanuel Kant und der hat damals
schon vor langer Zeit bereits zu treffen
formuliert habe den Mut dich deines
eigenen Verstandes zu bedienen und ich
finde das ist eine perfekte lockline für
unser
Projekt oder auch mit Blick auf die Uhr
und gute Schlusswort vielen
Dank
vom bünis Wagenknecht übrigens ein
grimmepreisträger in früheren Jahren
drebuchautor und dafür ausgezeichnet
worden nächste Redner ist auch nicht
ganz unbekannt Michael Lüders haben wir
vorhin schon mal erwähnt als er sich
beworben hat für den erweiterten
Vorstand des BSW jetzt in der Debatte
zum
europaahlprogramm es ist doch so wenn
man sich fragt jeder von uns hat seine
eigene politische Sozialisation
Biografie meine ist ganz wesentlich
erfolgt über Willi Brand und Egon B zwei
von mir sehr verehrten Persönlichkeiten
deutscher Politik als Fernstudium
sozusagen Egon Bar habe ich zu späterer
Lebzeit noch persönlich kennenlernen
dürfen und ich habe mich häufiger bei
der Frage ertappt was wäre eigentlich
gewesen wenn die damalige Ostpolitik in
den 1960er 70er Jahren nicht von
Persönlichkeiten wie diesen beiden
geprägt worden wäre würde es dann das
wieder vereinigte Deutschland geben oder
das Europa so wie wir es kennen und
gleichzeitig ertappe ich mich bei der
Frage was wäre eigentlich wenn damals
schon die Stck Zimmermanns oder die
anderen Hardliner innerhalb der
deutschen europäischen Politik den Ton
angegeben hätten würden wir dann heute
auch hier friedlich uns zusammenfinden
können und uns gemeinsam überlegen wie
wir dieses Land Deutschland wieder nach
vorne bringen dennoch ist es so obwohl
wir beiden so viel zu verdanken haben
dass sie gewissermaßen in rein der SPD
fast schon als Untote gelten und wäre
die die Parteizentrale nicht nach Willi
Brand benannte der SPD wäre
wahrscheinlich auch wie weitgehend schon
der Vergessenheit an Heim
gefallen dennoch wussten diese granten
dass Frieden zwar nicht alles ist aber
ohne Frieden ist alles nichts und der
Weg geht in eine völlig andere Richtung
meine Vorredner haben das bereits
dargelegt ich finde es sehr befremdlich
die große Bereitschaft fast schon Lust
mit der die Europäische Union aber auch
die Bundespolitik geneigt ist die eigene
Wirtschaft zu ruinieren und die
Zukunftsfähigkeit Europas in Frage zu
stellen durch eine zu einseitige
Anbindung an nur eine der Mächte die
diese Welt maßgeblich prägen es war die
Europäische Union die mit ihrem Programm
Repower one dazu beigetragen hat dass
die Energiekrise in Deutschland
ausgelöst wurde die ja im Grunde
genommen die Urmutter ist der Probleme
die die hiesige Wirtschaft hat bis hin
zur zur
Deindustrialisierung und ich glaube dass
wir viel mehr darauf achten müssen genau
dieser Entwicklung entgegenzuwiken
natürlich braucht Deutschland braucht
die Europäische Union gute und sehr gute
Beziehungen zu den Vereinigten Staaten
aber es kann noch nicht sein dass wir
uns in einen Zustand der Abhängigkeit
begeben die dann dazu führt dass die
hiesige Wirtschaft ruiniert wird und die
amerikanische Wirtschaft blüht wenn man
es dort verstanden hat zwar Sanktionen
zu fordern an den man sich selber aber
nicht so sehr
Sarah Wagenknecht hat es in ihrer
fulminanten Rede sehr klar benannt es
ist ja schon absurd wir boukottieren
russische Energie weil wir die russische
Wirtschaft in die Knie zwingen wollen
aber wir importieren russisches Öl nach
wie vor über Indien die Türkei oder
Saudi-Arabien aber fünf bis zehn Mal
teurer und das gleiche passiert ja auch
mit russischem Gas das über
Aserbaidschan exportiert wird nach
Deutschland Ursula von derlin war in
Baku hat dort die Hände geschüttelt mit
Herrn aliev warum der jetzt
sympathischer sein soll als Herr Putin
er schließt sich mir persönlich
nicht es ist ein großes Problem dass die
Politik Europas vor allem sich darin
versteht dass man gerne eine Filiale
sein möchte der Vereinigten Staaten
obwohl es eigentlich ke Gebot wäre in
der Zeit der Krisen und der Umbrüche die
wir erleben uns zwischen den USA und
China zu positionieren die Franzosen
haben genau dieses verstanden die
Regierung macron versucht diesen Weg zu
gehen die Bundesregierung schafft es
aber nicht ich glaube das ist in
Deutschland fast schon ein blasphäischer
Akt von einem Regierungspolitiker zu
verlangen dass er in irgendeiner Weise
mal sich überlegt was nützt eigentlich
europäischen was nützt deutschen
Interessen allein die Frage nach
Interessen zu stellen passt offenbar gar
nicht in die Vorstellungswelt jener die
lieber über Moral
schwadronieren
die amerikahörigkeit und ich möchte noch
einmal betonen wir brauchen gute und
sehr gute Beziehungen zu den USA aber
nicht in der Art und Weise wie das
gegenwärtig passiert die
amerikahörigkeit kann auch bis Weilen
bizarre Blüten annehmen ich war
gemeinsam mit Andrej hunko im
Afghanistan Untersuchungsausschuss des
Bundestages und es ist wirklich
interessant ges gewesen frappierend zu
sehen wie man erstens in eigentlich
interessanten Fragen aus dem Weg geht
nämlich warum hat sich Deutschland warum
haben sich europäische Staaten so lange
dort in diesem Krieg engagiert man hätte
ja auch nach 10 Jahren rausgehen können
z.B die Franzosen haben das getan die
Holländer haben das getan und siee die
Welt ist nicht untergegangen aber die
Deutschen sind geblieben bis zur letzten
Sekunde völlig überrumpelt von der
amerikanischen Entscheidung du US haben
es auch nicht für nötig befunden
Deutschland zu informieren das im
Begriff stehen ab abzuziehen und ich
habe einmal im Zusammenhang dieses
Ausschusses einen namhaften CDU
Politiker gefragt warum eigentlich sind
sie diesen Weg gegangen sie hätten auch
nach 10 Jahren sagen können wir gehen
raus als Deutschland und seine Antwort
lautete gemeinsam rein gemeinsam raus
und ich muss gestehen ich finde das ein
schönes Motto für einen zwingerclub
[Gelächter]
z.B aber nicht für die deutsche Politik
und
ich denke nur in Europa das seine
eigenen Interessen selbstbewusst erkennt
und benennt wird im Wettbewerb der
Nation der uns erwartet dem immer größer
werden im Einfluss des globalen Südens
neuer Mächte die entstehen auf der Welt
es sind nicht mehr nur die USA die in
Zukunft den Ton angeben werden die
Europäische Union und Deutschland sind
gut beraten ein anderen Weg einen
anderen Weg zu sehen es ist ungut zu
verfolgen wie ursela von derlin ihre
Aufgabe hauptsächlich darin zu sehen äh
scheint die EU in eine
zweignniederlassung der NATO wie auch
der USA zu begeben denn am Ende haben
wir dabei nicht zu verlieren wenn wir
uns in eine Konfrontation zwischen China
und die USA begeben deutsche Politik ist
gut beraten und die EU-Politik ebenfalls
und dafür würde ich mich gerne einsetzen
mehr auf Diplomatie zu setzen und
weniger auf
seberasseln darüber
hinaus
darüber hinaus bedeutet es für einen
Neuanfang für den wir ja stehen
sicherlich auch dass wir den
öffentlichen Raum für Debatten
zurückerobern weg von den enggesetzten
leidplanken dessen was gesagt oder
besser nicht gesagt werden kann oder
sollte es muss möglich sein in diesem
Land mit 84 Millionen Menschen darunter
sehr sehr viele Leute die sich gerne
engagieren möchten andere Wege zu
beschreiten ich denke wir sind mit
dieser neuen Partei in der Lage den
vielen Menschen in diesem Land Hoffnung
zu geben genau diesen politischen Weg zu
gehen und ich denke wenn wir uns nicht
selber im Weg stehen und genau das sagen
wir mal die Vorgaben beachten die sehr
klug vorgegeben worden sind vorgetragen
worden sind dann sind wir auf einem
guten dann sind wir auf einem besten Weg
dann steht uns wirklich und steht
Deutschland auch die Zukunft offen
fangen wir an andere Wege zu beschreiten
ich glaube das Land und auch die
Europäische Union wartet
vielen
dank der Publizist Michael Lüders den
man aus einer Reihe von Auftritten im
deutschen Fernsehen kennt auch bei uns
ist er schon gewesen in den vergangenen
Jahren das ganze heißt hier
Generaldebatte zum europawahlprogramm
das ist der Titel dieses
Tagesordnungspunktes aber eine Debatte
ist es natürlich nicht sondern es ist
Selbstvergewisserung hier unter den
Anwesenden
Parteimitgliedern die ja noch mehr
werden sollen in den nächsten Jahren und
ich bin relativ sicher dass es beim
nächsten Parteitag dann auch ganz andere
Diskussionen geben wird auch in
untereinander und innerhalb dieser noch
neuen Partei ja okay man kann mich sehen
auch hören ich bin ein staharbeiter
deswegen muss ich auch wirklich auch
irgendwo ankommen liebe Freundinnen
Freunde ich muss erst einmal etwas
loswerden was mich wirklich heute
richtig bewegt hat alle reden wirklich
die hier oben an die Delegierten hier
gerichtet waren haben mit Sicherheit
allen Mut gemacht und mir auch es ist
wirklich bewegend gewesen also das ich
habe heute schon so die Stallarbeiter
die eine Perspektive jetzt haben
jahrelang an SPD geglaubt haben weil sie
aus der Arbeiterbewegung kam eine
Perspektive jetzt mit unsere Partei
haben die BSW die wird die Alternative
für die für die Arbeiter Klasse sein und
ich freue mich schon dieses an dieses an
an den an den Kollegen Kollegen
Vertrauensleute Betriebsräte und
Gewerkschafter die werden uns jetzt
ansprechen also Mutz
zur
zur industrielle
Entwicklung Vernunft industrielle
Politik und Wirtschaftspolitik bedeutet
gleichzeitig Arbeitsplätze sichern
Arbeitsplätze ausbauen meine wenn ich
vor 5 Jahren so diskutiert hätte in der
Linken hätten sie mich gejagt als
Betriebsrat wie kannst du sowas
überlegen wie kannst du sowas ansprechen
aber heute mit dieser Partei Bündnis
Sarah Wagenknecht haben wir die Hürde
gebrochen wir können jeden in der
Kommune auf Land und Bund überzeugend
sagen der Mut hat
gefehlt konsequente Forderung
konsequente Politik mit Vernunft
angepackt zu werden hat gefehlt liebe
Freundinnen Freunde als
Kommunalpolitiker kann ich nur sagen das
ist beschämend dass man durch diese
Schuldenbremse mittlerweile in den
ganzen haushaltsdiskussionen hingeht und
versucht statt Schulen Container wir
haben 170 Container aufgestellt obwohl
wir innerhalb von 8 Jahren 5000 Kinder
zusätzlich nach dußburg gezogen sind da
ist doch keine Antwort mehr drauf da
kann man doch kein mehr Antworten also
diese schuldenbrems Bremsen nicht nur
die Infrastruktur Kita Schule Brücken
sie gefährdet auch Arbeitsplätze die
industrialisier Industrialisierung
insgesamt eine eine Nation die seit
Jahren davon gelebt hat gerade in den
50er Jahren wo ich sag mal Montanunion
aufgebaut worden sind wie man dann über
Kohle und und Stahl vorangekommen ist
und die Entwicklung diese revolutionäre
technische Entwicklung weg von den
Hochöfen zu den direkt
direktionsanlagen da kann man no nicht
wegschauen und das ist nicht nur eine
Sache der nationalen Politik es ist eine
Frage der nationale Entwicklung bleiben
wir noch Industriestaat oder nicht wir
haben ausgerechnet dass
wir für die für den Ersatz der Hochöfen
ja direkdirektionsanlage die erste ist
in dursburg einer der größten mit zinh
zinh Millionen Tonnen die hat 2
Milliarden gekostet und 700 Millionen
vom Landbund das war keine
Selbstverständlichkeit die Vernunft ist
nicht nur die diese diese diese
unvernünftige Politik kommt nicht nur
aus der Richtung der Politik sondern
auch aus der Richtung der Industrie sie
haben bei uns am Standort keine
Rücklagen gelegt Sara warenknecht und
Christian lei waren bei uns gewesen wir
ringen jetzt um neue
technologiearbeitsplätze weil 800
Arbeitsplätze bei uns am Standort
unfantläusig kaputt gemacht worden sind
abgebaut worden sind zu guten Jahren
haben wir 100 Millionen im Jahre gemacht
nicht ein Cent Rücklagen alles den
Konzern weitergegeben und am Ende haben
die Betriebsräte jahrelang darüber
gesprochen und den Druck auf an die
Politik waren auch Gewerkschafter EG
Metall und auch
auch Betriebsräte wir sind immer wieder
nach Berlin gelaufen das können wir wenn
wir den Hammer heben dann fällt der und
wenn wir glauben an einer Politik da
kann man davon ausgehen dass wir diese
Politik und die Partei auch wirklich in
Zukunft vertreten auch wählen würden
dafür werde ich
sorgen
das das Vertrauen hat die SPD verzockt
eine Partei die aus der Arbeiterbewegung
kommt diese ampelregierung hat noch mal
ein drauf gesetzt es wurden ja gerade
noch mal gesagt dass die AFD ja nicht
von alleine groß geworden ist dass die
nicht von alleine stark geworden ist die
hat man stark gemacht indem man gesagt
hat wir bauen statt Schulen Container
wir schaffen es schon die wirklich auch
das Thema Flüchtlings und
integrations Politik nicht vernünftig
angepackt haben es ist erlaubt darüber
zu sprechen wie viel können wir uns
erlauben wie viel ist das leistbar
insgesamt für die kommun da tun wir
tagtäglich im Deutschen Städtetag wo ich
seit 13 Jahre sag mal drin bin sind wir
jetzt rechts nee wir sagen wer bestellt
der bezahlt und wenn man sagt ja wir
kriegen das hin und die Kommunen das
nicht in ich sag mal in die Reihe
kriegen ist es erlaubt das zu sagen wir
machen das richtige Leute lassen uns
nicht einschüstern wenn wir das
vernünftig an die Menschen bringen
stehen die uns sie wissen ganz genau
wenn Integration kann nur klappen wenn
wir das begrenzt machen wenn wir den
Berechtigten wirklich auch aufnehmen und
da Schule Kita auch Arbeitsmarkt auf dem
Weg bringen und sagen so läuft
sozialserungssysteme das können wir
sagen das müssen wir sagen ich
möchte mit
meinen Kollegin
Kollegen Freundinen und Freunde an der
Spitze mit Fabio
eine Politik im Europaparlament machen
was auch natürlich nationale Auswirkung
hat das kann man gar nicht aushebeln die
wirklich auch den Namen
verdient
Wirtschaft
Industriepolitik mit Vernunft wo
Arbeitsplatzsicherung
über Stiftung geredet sein dürfen wo man
wirklich über Ausbau der Arbeitsplätze
aber auch die Mittel zur Verfügung
stellt nicht nur national sondern
international weil wir sind gebunden wir
haben wir haben ich sag mal ja ja ich
bin gleich fertig ich bin
Stallarbeiter also also wir haben wir
haben eine Zusage bekommen man muss ich
mal vorstellen von der ich sag mal
Bundeszuschüsse als als Zusage bekommen
Landeszuschüsse das muss du noch mal in
Europäischen Parlament und die
Beschäftigten haben gezittert geht das
durch oder geht das nicht durch ich will
damit sagen die Verb also die diese
ganze Verknüpfung ist da wir werden auf
kommunale Ebene geb brauch wir werden
auf Landesebene gebraucht wir werden auf
Europaebene gebraucht ich werde mich mit
allen Kräften mit meinen Freundinen
Freunden einsetzen damit wirklich Europa
endlich mal versteht dass die nationalen
sage ich mal Bedingungen und die
Forderung
für eine
vernünftige Wirtschaftspolitik
Industriepolitik und soziale
Gerechtigkeit Land Kommune und Bund ein
herzlichen Dank
ich un sehr sehr viel Erfolg wir werden
sehr viel Überzeugungsarbeit leisten
müssen danke schön vielen
dank vielen Dank Erkan es folgt
Friedrich Pürner und dann kommt Jan
Peter
barnke Friedrich Pürner übrigens
ausgewiesener
coronamaßnahmenkritiker sehr Damen und
Herren ich muss jetzt die verlorene Zeit
wieder reinholen und ich tue mein Bestes
wir leben in einer Zeit in der wir
spüren wie fragil die Freiheit des
Einzelnen und die der Gesellschaft ist
wir leben in einer Zeit in der kcel
culture salonfähig wurde dieformierung
und Stigmatisierung die Debatte
vergiften und der meinungskorridor immer
enger wird ich war wovon ich spreche
diese Entwicklung müssen wir
entgegentreten ich kandidiere weil die
Ziele unserer Partei meine Ziele
sind Ziele die vernünftig klug und
sinnvoll sind Ziele die den etablierten
Parteien abhanden gekommen sind Ziele
die weder extrem noch radikal sind vor
allem sind es aber Ziele die den
Menschen wieder in den Mittelpunkt
stellen als Arzt ist mir unser
Gesundheitswesen im Gegensatz zu Karl
Lauterbach sehr
vertraut ich kenne die Stärken und die
Schwächen und ich kenne aber auch die
akelle Schieflage in diesem
Gesundheitswesen während der Pandemie
wurden kritische Stimmen nicht
gehört das hätte nicht passieren dürfen
und das darf nie wieder
passieren beruflich trete ich seit
meinem 19 lebensjahr für staatliche
Institutionen und damit auch für die
Bevölkerung ein
und nun möchte ich mit Ihnen zusammen
einen Weg einschlagen um politisch
gestalten zu
können vor allem im
Gesundheitsbereich sollte vieles nicht
auf EU-Ebene geregelt werden dieser
blinde Aktionismus verkennt die
Eigenheiten einer
wohnortnahen
Gesundheitsversorgung es braucht einen
gesamtheitlichen Blick es braucht vor
allem aber auch einen Blick frei von
Lobbyismus wir wollten ja Zeit
sparen Gesundheitspolitik war bisher
hauptsächlich Sache der Mitgliedstaaten
das hat sich aber während der
coronapandemie verändert die
coronapandemie wird nicht die letzte
Pandemie gewesen sein wenn wir die
Fehler nicht aufarbeiten die gemacht
worden sind und darau aus lernen werden
uns die Folgen der nächsten Pandemie
noch viel stärker
treffen wir spüren alle und wir sehen es
die Gesellschaft ist tief gespalten die
Gesellschaft ist erschöpft die
Gesellschaft ist
müde durch eine öffentlich geführte
aufarbeitungsdebatte können wir Hoffnung
und Zuversicht
zurückgewinnen die jetzige Politik hat
das Vertrauen der Bürger restlos
verspielt ich bin überzeugt davon wir
brauchen einen starken und einen
schlanken Staat aber keinen
übergriffigen Staat wir brauchen ein
starkes Europa aber kein überreguliertes
Europa hierfür möchte ich mit mich mit
dieser Kandidatur und mit ihrer Hilfe
einsetzen eine bitte noch lassen sie uns
menschlich bleiben herzlichen
Dank vielen Dank Friedrich es folgt Jan
Peter
Wanke und janpeter wke ist Platz 5 der
Europaliste wenn sie so abgestimmt wird
wie sie vorgelegt worden ist Friedrich
pner war auf der SE und das bedeutet
nach unserer Erkenntnis dass von den
ersten se auf der Europa
m sehr
herorragen worden wahres wird nicht
wahrer wenn man es noch mal wiederholt
also sehen Sie bitte meine Personen als
Unterzeichnung von den Sachen die gesagt
worden sind als Arzt würde ich ihnen
gerne noch mal eine kurze Analyse
unserer gesellschaftlichen Situation
geben ich glaube dass die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland derzeit ein
multimorbider
intensivpatient mit drohendem
Multiorganversagen ist und seit zwei
Jahren muss man diesem Land auch noch
suizidale Gedanken unterstellen nämlich
seitdem die Ampel
regiert die Europäische Union ein
Wunschtraum von mir ich teile all diese
Vorredner die genauso wie auch ich das
als Traum immer gesehen haben die EU ist
zumindestens bettlegerig und kann nicht
aufstehen weil sie sich mit seinem
überregulatorischen Wasserkopf Wahnsinn
in Brüssel so ans Bett fesselt dass ein
selbständiges Aufstehen nicht möglich
ist und die Therapien nach Diagnosen
wissen sie kommen ja immer die Therapien
ja die Therapien die es derzeit gibt
diese Therapien reichen von
schwachsinnig bis obsolet auf jeden Fall
sind sie
nichtunktion
wir suchen also eine neue Therapie
deswegen bin ich hier BSW ist eine neue
Therapie ich kandidiere für das
Europäische Parlament weil ich in drei
europäischen Ländern gelebt und
gearbeitet habe die Vorzüge Europas
gesehen habe und jetzt sehe wie Europa
im Ansehen der Bevölkerung anfängt zu
zerbröseln aus einem g Traum wird im
Augenblick Staub das würde ich sehr
gerne verhindern ich bin hoch motiviert
nachdem ich erlebt habe dass
2021 viele Ärzte für ihre Patientinnen
nicht mehr die richtigen Instrumente und
Implantate hatten weil es eine höchst
schwachsinnige europäische Regelung über
die Zertifizierung übrigens auch so ein
Thema ja zertifizierungswahnsinn das
eine ganze Industrie die da entstanden
ist uns am Handeln gehindert hat mit
diesen Argumenten und mit dieser
Motivation versehen würde ich sehr gerne
mit Ihnen im Namen des Souveräns im
Namen unseres Volkes für eine
verbesserte EU und ein besseres
Deutschland kämpfen herzlichen
Dank vielen Dank
Peter ja wirind nun leider an der
Situation dass wir zum einen den
Zeitplan nicht mehr ganz eingehalten
haben aber wir haben Generaldebatte von
einer Stunde wollten wir auch so
einhalten aber die eine Stunde ist nun
auch vorbei das heißt wir müssen hier
leider jetzt ein Cut machen und können
die weiteren Beiträge nicht mehr
aufrufen ich hoffe dass diejenigen die
sich hier gemeldet haben dafür
Verständnis haben aber ich glaube für
uns alle das waren alles sehr gute
Wortbeiträge für das europawahlprogramm
und auch für unsere Programmatik
[Applaus]
oder dann braucht ihr jetzt wieder eure
bunte Karte hat der Patrick heute morgen
gesagt ich habe erwähnt dass es keine
Änderungsanträge gab
außer das was wir bereits dargestellt
haben das Programm das heute ausgeteilt
worden ist nochmals ist das Programm
über das wir jetzt beschließen es gibt
keine Änderungsanträge wer dafür ist
dass wir bei der ersten Wahl des Bündnis
Sara wagenknch mit diesem Wahlprogramm
starten den bitchums
Kartenzeichen
Gegenprobe ich guck noch mal ich sehe
nichts
Enthaltung
einstimmiges
plus also das ganz toll und gibt viel
Motivation und um bedankt sich auch noch
mal bei allen die im Vorfeld mit daran
gearbeitet haben dass der Entwurf
hergestellt worden ist viele die wissen
dass daran gearbeitet haben vielen Dank
an vielen unbekannten dass das
europawahlprogramm jetzt
steht ja damit setze ich die Einigkeit
die wir ja schon wiederholt beschrieben
haben bei diesem Parteitag bei diesem
ersten
Bundesparteitag des BSW fort
einstimmiges Ergebnis des ein für das
europawahlprogramm und jetzt gibt's ein
paar Ergebnisse die wollen wir natürlich
überhaupt nicht vorenthalten wier das
Wort ja vielen Dank
Alexander ich würde jetzt
die Kandidaten für den erweiterten
Parteivorstand noch mal kurz auf die
Bühne
bitten damit wir dann die Ergebnisse
verkünden
können so das waren 14 Kandidierende
insgesamt 12 Männer zwei Frauen ich
fange schon mal und jetzt gibt's glaube
ich doch schon mal das erste Ergebnis
weil bzw während sich die Kandidierenden
noch mal auf die Bühne begeben
sollen80 Stimmen wurden abgegeben
davon gültig 380
ungültig
0 mit ja haben gestimmt bei Fabio deasi
363 mit Nein 10 Enthaltungen 7 Fabio
deasi ist damit mit 96%
gewählt lieber Fabio nimmst du die Wahl
[Applaus]
an kommen wir zu
johanlukas
Dietrich jeanlukas Dietrich
376 Stimmen wurden
abgegeben davon gültig
ungültig Null mit ja haben gestimmt
354 mit Nein haben gestimmt
mit Enthaltung haben gestimmt 13
jeanlukas Dietrich ist demnach gewählt
mit 94% der
[Applaus]
Stimmen
johanlcas nimmst du die Wahl an alles
klar gut kommen wir jetzt zu Thomas
Geisel abgegeben wurden
Stimmen davon gültig
433 433 doch das kann hier steht
433 dann wie okay dann entschuld dann
muss wir dann ist das ein
Fehler ja aber es W hier 433
abgegebeno
nicht so jetzt wei ich auch nicht
nochuckt werden muss Übermittlungsfehler
der jetzt noch geklärt werden muss
offenbar hat sich sich da ein paar
Zahlen verschoben 433
war genannt worden als diejenigen die
abgestimmt haben was mich ein bisschen
irritiert weil bei den abgegebenen
Stimmen bei den bislang bekannt
gewordenen Ergebnissen es deutlich
weniger waren die abgestimmt haben was
mich ohnehin etwas irritiert hat weil ja
hier ungefähr
450 da sein dürften und das von diesen
450 nur 380 abgestimmt haben könnte ja
nur bedeuten entweder haben es da ein
paar verpasst an dieser Wahl
teilzunehmen oder es sind doch gar nicht
da denn wenn ich schon bei einem ersten
großen Bundesparteitag bin und hier im
Saal Sitze im Kosmos wir nen
die um noch mal das Wort zu geben so
habe ich mein Satz einfach mal
abgebrochen weil jetzt doch mal Amira
Mohamed Ali ans Pult gehen soll geht sie
hin geht sie zurück jetzt geht sie doch
vor diese kleine Unterbrechung noch
etwas Schönes zu machen ihr habt das ja
alle mitbekommen wir bevor wir die
Partei gegründet haben gab es ja erst
den Verein BSW und dieser Verein hatte
ja auch Gründer Mütter und Gründer Väter
das waren mutige Leute die sich getraut
haben das auf den Weg zu bringen und
diesen Personen möchte ich jetzt von
dieser Stelle auch noch mal ganz
herzlich danken vielleicht könnt ihr
kurz aufstehen ich danke herzlich Jonas
Christopher
höpkin ich danke ich danke herzlich
agneske ich danke
[Applaus]
her ich danke herzlich Jana von
Helden ich danke auch herzlich Joachim
flakus ich danke herzlich Amelie
Gabriel und ich danke herzlich V asi
ohne EU Mut hätten wir das alles nicht
machen können vielen dank vielen
Dank
so das war Amira Mohammed Ali hat sich
noch mal bedankt bei allen die in der
Frühphase dieser wirklich noch sehr sehr
jungen Partei sich engagiert haben und
zum organisatorischen Gelingen
beigetragen haben wir sind auf der zielg
Geraden Mark steinhuser bitte ja erh
schärfer es ist so dass natürlich die
wesentlichen Punkte jetzt hier über die
Bühne gegangen sind nutzen wir das bei
Phönix um noch mal ein bisschen in die
Analyse zu gehen bei mir Miriam Holstein
vom Stern Timo Lehmann vom Spiegel Frau
Holstein mit Blick auf die Reden die wir
heute gehört haben das friedensthema
schien alles überlagert zu haben wie
haben sie das wahrgenommen was hält hier
dieses Bündnis eigentlich inhaltlich
zusammen ich fand ganz interessant SAR
wagencht hat ja gesagt es ist hier keine
linke 2.0 ja aber man hatte doch den
Eindruck nicht auch zuletzt aufgrund der
vielen ehemaligen linken Funktionäre und
aufgrund der Themen Friedenspolitik das
ist doch sehr ähnlich ist eine linke
plus alte Position plus noch ein paar
konservativ autoritäre ih Position aber
auffällig auch sehr sehr große
Geschlossenheit große Geschlossenheit
ein Parteitag der ja straff geführt wird
da wird eine
europaprogrammdebatte mal eben beendet
da werden auch Mitglieder ja gar nicht
befragt wo die Parteimitglieder die
Möglichkeiten haben Nachfragen zu
stellen Herr Lehmann das ist doch sehr
anders als bei WASG linken und auch z.B
bei der AFD da geht's ja richtig zur
Sache das war ja ja heute ziemlich
durchregiert oder ja absolut also das
verwundert mich ehrlich gesagt auch ein
bisschen weil gerade das wagennichtlager
was ich jetzt hier bei diesem Bündnis
Sarah wagenicht formiert hat ist
eigentlich äh bei den Linken Parteitagen
immer sehr auffällig für bei
programmdebatten und bei Streitigkeiten
gewesen aber genau diesen Eindruck
wollte man hier vermeiden und ähm das
ist vor allem das wissen ja weiß auch
Sarah wagencht und wissen die Mitglieder
dass das die größte Gefahr ist am Anfang
dass man sich sehr sehr schnell
zerstreitet und deswegen hat man das
also gestern gab es Generalproben und
ähnliches das ist ja alles von vorne bis
hinten durchorchestriert um ein
möglichst professionelles Bild abzugeben
und ich würde d sagen das hat bis jetzt
auch ziemlich gut funktioniert ziemlich
gut funktioniert von der Orchestrierung
Frau Holstein wenn wir noch mal darauf
schauen was jetzt da bevorsteht und mit
welchen Personen und auch mit welchem
Programm man jetzt vorantritt welche
Erfolgsaussichten geben Sie diesem
Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht also ich glaube erstmal
werden wir erleben dass es bei der
Europawahl passables bis gutes Ergebnis
vorweisen kann weil wir da eben auch
nicht die 5% Hürde haben interessant
wird's in einigen Bundesländern finden
ja parallel Kommunalwahlen statt unter
ander auch im Sachsen wo
das Bündnis antreten will sofern es denn
das Personal findet da schon mal die
Frage findet es das Personal und wie
wird das Ergebnis sein und dann eben die
große Nagelprobe sind die Landtagswahlen
und ja ich glaub da könnte es noch sehr
schwierig werden der Generalsekretär
Christian lei hat im Phönix Interview
auch gesagt es ist noch nicht klar ob
man bei allen drei Landtagswahlen
antritt mal unabhängig davon auch die
Frage Herr Lehmann ist das Programm was
man sich hier gegeben hat was bisher
bekannt ist
landtagswahltauglich weil die Ukraine
jetzt hier anzusprechen und Russland das
weiß ich nicht ob das in Thüringen jetzt
jemanden interessiert wenn es um die
landesthemen geht oder kann man auch
damit gut punkten also punkten kann man
sicherlich möglicherweise damit schon am
Ende wählen die Leute Sarah wagenkn
nicht aufgrund ihrer Position zu
Russland oder anderem und nicht explizit
landespolitischen oder
kommunalpolitischen Themen aber das ist
natürlich die Frage es müssen dann bei
drei Landtagswahlen auch drei
landtagsprogramme aufgesetzt werden das
müss muss die Partei alles noch
beschließen das ist alles noch offen
müsste sich überhaupt erstmal die
Landesverbände Gründen das soll in den
nächsten Wochen passieren also es jetzt
sehr sehr wenig Zeit und mal gucken ob
das auch alles so technisch ob die das
alles organisatorisch hinbekommen das
muss ja ein Generalsekretär leisten wenn
wir noch mal auch auf das schauen was
der Generalsekretär gesagt hat was Fabio
deasi gesagt hat mit Blick auf die
Wahlkämpfe immer wieder ist gesagt
worden man will nicht in die Ecke
gestellt werden als Putin knnechte und
Putin versteher auf der anderen Seite
wird ja gar nicht sozusagen die
Verantwortung Russlands hier klar
benannt wie kann das sozusagen
funktionieren bei den Wählerinnen und
Wählern ich glaube das ist einer der
Gründe warum sich so viele Menschen für
das Bündnis interessieren weil genau
diese Distanzierung eben nicht
stattfindet also Sarah Wagenknecht
bleibt da tatsächlich auch ihrem
kurstreu sie hat ja auch heute noch mal
erwähnt dass man energiezi Lieferung
direkte Energielieferung aus Russland
auch wieder zulassen müsste ist das aus
ihrer Sicht was wo sie sagen das ist ein
Alleinstellungsmerkmal im Parteiensystem
so wie das hier dargestellt wird also
dieser starke Fokus auf Friedenspolitik
ist in Anbetracht der Tatsache dass die
Grünen die ja früher damit sehr stark
identifiziert waren diese Position aber
mit Blick auf den ukrainekrieg geräumt
haben oder auch schon vorher davon
abgerückt sind ist es in der Tat ein
Alleinstellungsmerkmal ja wie sehen Sie
das Herr würden Sie sagen dass das so
das Thema ist mit dem hier am meisten
gepunktet werden konnte wir haben
weniger eigentlich gehört zu
migrationspolitischen
Äußerung das stimmt das hat man hier
heute so ein bisschen verdeckt gehalten
auch im Wahlprogramm sind die Aussagen
dort relativ weich im Verhältnis zu dem
was man vom Wagen nicht sonst schon
gehört hat ich würde sagen bei dem
Russland Thema gibt's noch eine andere
Partei die AFD die das Thema natürlich
auch sehr groß spielt aber zumindest bei
Ausrüstung Bundeswehr Waffenlieferung im
Allgemeinen sind andere Positionen hier
vertreten aber bei der russlandnähe
würde ich sagen oder bei dem Versuch
gegen die USA und alles da wäre noch die
AFD dabei dann Schlussfrage an sie beide
vielleicht erst Frau Holstein wem wird
dieses Bündnis gefährlich in diesem Jahr
im der
Parteienlandschaft ich glaube es wird
tatsächlich der Linken gefährlich vor
allem mit Blick auf die Bundestagswahl
ich glaube es wird ein bisschen Gelingen
von der AFD zu bekommen aber nicht allzu
viel und dann vermutlich noch aus dem
Lager der Nichtwähler und vielleicht
auch ein bisschen noch von der SPD
teilen Sie die Einschätzung volle
Zustimmung würde ich genauso sehen volle
Zustimmung hier bei Timo Lehmann vom
Spiegel Miriam Holstein vom Stern besten
Dank für Ihre Zeit hier bei phöniix und
für die Analyse bei uns ja und mit
diesen abschließenden Einordnungen und
diesen Gedanken werden wir an dieser
Stelle hier unsere Live Übertragung von
diesem ersten Bundesparteitag des
Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht beenden sie
können wie immer alles was wir hier
gesendet haben nachschauen auf
phöniix.de sie können es auch Youtube
und in den Mediatheken noch mal ansehen
wir haben ja auch viele normale
Parteimitglieder hier gefunden und
befragt ein bisschen Licht ins Dunkel
gebracht wer hier eigentlich sonst noch
mitmacht außer Sara Wagenknecht und wie
das Ganze überhaupt entstanden ist was
Sarah Wagenknecht getan hat bis zu
diesem Tag heute bis zu diesem Tag des
Bundesparteitages und quasi der Gründung
der Partei wie es dazu kam das hat mein
Kollege David damschen zusammengefasst
in einem Phönix plus zu SAR Wagenknecht
der neuen Partei tschüss aus
Berlin heute Vormittag haben wir die
Partei Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht Vernunft
und Gerechtigkeit kurz BSW gegründet ein
weiterer großer Schritt erst Abspaltung
dann Gruppenbildung nun die
Parteigründung bei ihren Auftritten
steht großes Medieninteresse die
politischen Inhalte noch wenig konkret
die Rhetorik dafür so schärfer in
Umfragen zwischen Höhenflug und
Fehlschlag sie gibt der Partei den Namen
ist diejenige die das von der Ampel
heruntergewirtschaftete Land retten soll
soweit der Imagefilm alles zugeschnitten
auf eine Person aber reicht der
Promibonus wirklich wenn man kein
konkretes Programm hat welches Potenzial
hat die neue Partei und wem wird sie
vielleicht
gefährlich klar ist das BSW will hoch
hinaus SAR Wagenknecht geht nun